as planned
[Music]
now from cincinnati a discussion on
africa and the future
activist kwame toure formerly known as
stokely carmichael and dr molefi asante
are part of this debate on
afrocentricity
this hour and a half event is hosted by
the united african organization at the
university of cincinnati
[Applause]
was born stokely carmichael in port of
spain trinidad in 1941.
during the time of the civil rights
struggle toure was arrested and
imprisoned more than 15 times while
organizing for voter registration in
alabama and mississippi
beginning in 1966 he was known as the
foremost exponent of the black power
movement which swept the african world
in 1968 kwame nkrumah moved to kona
creek guinea in west africa where he
worked and studied with osajifo kwame
nkrumah the president of ghana
here he began he became an organizer for
all for the all african people's
revolutionary party the aaprp founded by
dr nkrumah
trey has traveled and lectured all over
the world as an organizer for the aaprp
he has lectured at most of the major
universities in the united states and
has dedicated his life to the fight for
pan-africanism the total liberation and
unification of africa under an
all-african socialist party
it is truly an honor to introduce to you
kwame nkrumah i'm kwame toure
[Music]
uh thank you we asked you to excuse us
our pain in our right leg is giving us a
constant pain
and uh we have to stay off it off of the
leg as much as possible that's the only
reason why we're taking the sitting
position
uh
an africanism
what i'd like to do in the 20-minute
period we have is to give you its
general outline it's general development
and of course it's a future path
some people think that pan-africanism is
a response to colonialism
while certainly pan-africanism responded
to colonialism we must not think that
it's colonialism that brought
pan-africanism into being
of course to see this clearly we should
just look at the general evolutionary
processes of all societies on a
universal basis
all societies have a tendency to go from
a smaller social aggregate to a larger
social aggregate from the family to the
tribe to the clan to the nation to the
continent this is an evolutionary
process
this theory can be seen in living
practice if today we were to look at
europe
europe everywhere speaks of european
continental unity
even though europe has fought more
fratricidal wars than any other
continent or all the continents put
together europe still speaks of european
continental unity of course
africa will unify before europe but
that's not the point of discussion here
this evening
the fact that europe with all the
fraternal fratricidal wars she fought
can speak of continental unity shows
this evolutionary process africa like
any other society anywhere in the world
was involved in this same evolutionary
process going from family to tribe to
clan to nation to continent this
evolutionary process was interrupted
by european imperialism
it came in two forms slavery and
colonialism
first they took over 300 million the
strongest
out of africa and then they divided
africa at the berlin conference
so you can see that africa herself was
moving on this evolutionary process this
evolutionary process which would lead to
continental unity and africa will still
be the first continent unified was
interrupted by european capitalism since
it was interrupted by european
capitalism and evolutionary process the
only way that africa can unite today is
through a revolutionary process aiming
at a socialist economy
if capitalism destroyed us it doesn't
make sense to use capitalism to continue
with it we must use the
anti-antithesis of capitalism which of
course is socialism
and certainly if with evolutionary
process has been interrupted the only
way we can capture the time lost is
through a revolutionary process we state
these facts only to let you know that
those of us who are revolutionary
pan-africanist is not because we love
revolution it is historically determined
and we have no alternative but to follow
history and to use history for the
benefit of our people
so this then is the general outlines of
pan-africanism so you must not think
that africa's just began had africa been
left untrampled by european imperialism
we have a long time achieved continental
unity
secondly
an africanism must be seen as a movement
a mass movement and this mass movement
must be properly understood
africa of course because of racism is
belittled everywhere
and many people do not see africa's
constant constant underline the word
constant contributions to uh world
civilization
in the uh since the 1940s africa has
given even before the 1940s actually go
back to the honourable marcus garvey
africa has given to world political
movements a mass character africans
revolt in masses never as a vanguard
party if you look at the independent
struggle in africa it was nothing less
than mass
if you look at the struggle in the
caribbean for independence it was
nothing less than mass and even united
states america the only movement they
call a mass movement is our movement
therefore this mass character must be
properly understood and africanism has
this mass character africans have this
mass character responding and our
responsibility is to bring this mass
character together make it precise so
that it can direct its blows at the
enemy hitting him hitting him hitting
him until we knock him down therefore
the the task of panicking is to gather
the masses of our people together in the
same organization irrespective of where
they find themselves be it in europe be
united states be in the caribbean or be
it in africa this is the first aspect
then we must understand but africanism
found its organizational expressions in
1900
here a pan-african conference here the
word conference was organized by
africans from all over the world
they came together deciding that
something must be done for africa the
one of the leading organizers of this
conference was a man by the name of
henry sylvester williams born in
trinidad a man whom you should do some
history on a very very great man
dr w e b dubois attended the conference
but he was not one of the leaders in
nineteen hundred
by 1917 1918
the idea of a necessity for a
pan-african uh congress not conference
congress was to be called but most of
the people who did the conference were
dead and was invested williams was dead
a lot of them were dead du bois was
about the only one who was alive du bois
recognized he had a historic
responsibility
to continue the work of pan-africanism
so he called the first pan-african
congress make a clear distinction the
first one in 1900 was the conference du
bois being intelligent understanding
that a conference is limited and a
congress has more elasticity and can go
longer call it a pan-african congress
from the 1990s up until 1945 we could
say seriously dr w.e.b du bois just
about single-handedly kept the flame of
pan-africanism alive
one thing must also be underlined to you
pan-africanism was brought into being in
its organized form by the africans
outside of africa
this was done only because of the
oppression of africa at that time africa
was under total colonial domination
there could be no political meetings as
a matter of fact if you had the paper of
the honorable marcus garvey you could go
to jail so the conditions were such it
was difficult for the africans on the
continent to organize africans off the
continent recognizing this came quickly
to fill up that gap so an africanism
itself was brought to bear by the
diaspora but you must not think that the
diaspora brought africans for the
diaspora not at all the center of the
discussions has always been a freight
car this must be properly understood
some people try to shift it make it take
it somewhere else but africa has always
been the focus du bois carried on his uh
congresses up until uh the fifth
congress in 1945 because of time we're
just going through them uh quickly in
1945 saw the fifth and african congress
here you had africans born on the
continent in the caribbean and uh
africans of course
in europe and the united states at this
fifth african congress there were three
co-secretaries of course w.e.b du bois
george padmore of trinidad and kwame
nkrumah of ghana so he had an african
from the caribbean one from the united
states and one from the continent who
were co-secretaries of the fifth
pan-african congress the fifth and
african congress is crucial for us a
decision was made there
they said that
the final confrontation with colonialism
is coming after all this 1945 and you
must know that there's negative and
positives in everything i remember once
as a young man reading minecamp on an
airplane sitting next to a woman she
said what are you doing i said what do
you mean what i'm doing i'm reading
minecraft why are you reading it i said
well hitler's very important man he had
historical effects on the world you know
i'm sure i'm a jew i said have you read
it she said no i said oh that's bad i
said have you not read soon yet she said
no i said he says the first law of war
is to know the enemy if i were a jew i
would read everything there is to read
on hitler
of course
of course
[Applause]
so
while reading hitler she was arguing i
said well it had some positive effect
anyway she said what positive effect did
hitler have i said hitler weakened
european imperialism he weakened the
british he weakened the french he
weakened the portuguese he weakened the
belgiums and that's how we got
independence
the facts of life
[Applause]
these are facts of life when hitler got
through with britain when the indians
said they want independence britain
could do anything but get out the way
and let them have independence matter of
fact they got mohammed mohammed gandhi
quick because they didn't want to deal
with the armed struggle that the indians
were preparing for british imperialism
in india
and by the time india was free what was
over china came up after china of course
africa throughout et cetera et cetera
and by 1960
now 1960 in 15 short years of the
declaration of the fifth and african
congress in 1945 two-thirds of the
african continent was independent
you must understand clearly the
importance of this now at the fifth and
african congress they said
the only solution to the final
confrontation is mass organization
and i say if you look at africans we
have nothing but mass character in our
struggles of course this mass character
for the moment is spontaneous and must
be transformed to something that is
planned and permanent
but certainly the mass character is
there if you just look back to the
rodney king situation those africans who
rebelled rebelled in mass
they had no planning that's how backward
they were
they didn't think about it just on the
spot they said okay it's too much let's
go let's get them and everybody say okay
let's get them and we rise up as mass
and we get them and then we sit down for
29 years
of course
of course but the mass character is
there and we must understand this mass
character
the fifth and african congress most of
africa of course was colonized
kwame nkrumah came to change all this
by 1958 he threw the british out of the
coast and named it ghana
and kruma declared before the entire
world that the independence of ghana is
meaningless unless it's linked with the
entire continent of africa and its
unification and liberty
and ghana and kruma made ghana the base
for every movement that fought against
colonialism
mugabe who is now the head of zimbabwe
where was he trained in ghana
go on ask all of them and kruma set up
freedom schools teaching how to use arms
to go and fight it was incruma who built
the base and pushed pan-africanism he
understood that africa was divided in
1865
at the berlin conference and that we
cannot accept divisions imposed upon us
by our enemy africa is one we must unify
her this has been the task of course
since then kruma the movement picked up
the independence of guinea came in the
same 1958 later that year and with
secretary and kwame nkrumah the movement
really coalesced force the pan-african
movement of course was not going to be
left alone imperialism would seek to
divide it that's their job
secretary says if the enemy is not doing
anything against you that's because
you're not doing anything of course
matter of fact when they are not doing
against me i get scared what am i doing
wrong
so their job was to divide and if you
look they divided the pad african
movement in what was called the
casablanca block and the monrovia block
the revolutionaries and the
reactionaries to put in one simple word
of course the casablanca group included
the fighting forces in algeria the fln
which the other african states refused
to recognize
of course nasa had to be in it of course
in kuruma of course seculare tunisia and
of course mohammed v in morocco who
would just wait serious war to uh get
independence away from the french the
other group was called the moderate
group and they were all made up of
reactionaries and scum of our race who
didn't want african unity and raise a
million problems and sabotage it and
work for imperialism against the
interest of their people and that still
continues today
i always say one of the weaknesses of
the african revolution is that we are
the only people who allow our enemies to
struck with impunity amongst us
it's only because of our weakness so
because our weakness
is our weakness
plus another weakness is that uh and
this one is a very painful that uh we
have to leave our wounded on the
battlefields to be picked by the
vultures we cannot even pick them up
we cannot take care of our prisoners the
families of our prisoners who are in
prison
i mean we're just very very weakly
organized but
we are revolutionaries we don't look for
easy tasks we look for difficult tasks
we leave the easy tasks to those who do
not wish to advance we know men and
women can only advance before
difficulties therefore we look always
for difficulties
we said they divided pan africanism and
out of that a compromise was made called
the organization of african unity
many people think that the organization
of african unity is pan-africanism it is
not
an africanism cannot be built from the
top down and the organization of african
unity is a organization of the heads of
states in africa
pan africans must come from the bottom
up from the mass of the people up it is
here then we'll come to see the real
aspect of pan-africanism
we said in fifth and african congress
they call for mass organizations and
immediately mass organizations sprang up
throughout the length and breadth of the
african world the conventional people's
party a mass body sprang up in ghana the
democratic party of guinea a mass body
sprang up in guinea throughout the
length and bed of africa you had tanu
the tanzanian african national union
which is now the ccm my swahili is not
as good as yours
missouri that's very good oh
my god
exactly exactly and uh that's their new
party but all of africa mass bodies
sprung up if you look at the caribbean
mass bodies sprung up and if you look at
the united states mass movements sprang
up so the call was heated for mass
confrontation
of course the fifth and african congress
made two definite and precise
resolutions which i want to uh highlight
of course pan-africanism from the very
beginning was anti-colonial
from the very beginning it was
anti-colonial it was weak
so when they came they didn't say to the
queen we're going to put you out the
country they said you must treat the
natives right you must educate them you
must prepare them for self-government
these are things that are weak but
they're anti-colonial in essence we must
not look at the form and we get stronger
the more this anti-colonialism will
express itself now anti-colonialism is
nothing but anti-capitalism
because colonialism is nothing but an
offshoot an aspect of capitalism
therefore if you're anti-colonial you
must be anti-capitalist if you're
logical in your thinking of course and
your actions some people are not but we
are speaking of logical people here yes
if you're anti-capitalist then you must
be socialist
capitalism cannot unite africa africa
has to be united by socialism now
there's a lot of confusion here on this
question of capitalism and socialism
just recently a young man said to me but
socialism died i said it did you say
yeah about it i said i missed the
funeral
of course he spoke about the betrayals
that occurred in the east you must not
let capitalism confuse your thinking
this is a struggle which panaphism takes
on we struggle against imperialism in
the ideological arena because many
people think that capitalism just wants
to exploit your labor it wants to
confuse your thinking and make you think
just like them
and this is where the real fight occurs
so therefore this struggle of confusing
the thinking i told the man i said
you're talking nonsense socialism cannot
uh
disappear it cannot die he said yes it
can i said no he's how do you say that i
said well you are judging uh socialism
by socialist you don't do that he said
i've never heard such nonsense if you
don't judge socialism by socialist what
do you judge it by i say judge by his
principles every system is judged by its
principles never its adherence so he
still saw confusion he said you're just
talking double talk i said okay do you
judge christianity by christians
[Applause]
[Music]
so we must not be confused here
socialism doesn't fall because of
betrayal no system does the person
betrays themselves goes to the mud but
the system with its eternal principles
keep marching on if a system fell
because of betrayal christianity would
have been finished with judas at least
judas had the dignity to hang himself
some of these who betrayed socialism
don't have that dignity gobert shaw
still runs around speaking and picking
up 30 pieces of silver everywhere
yeah
so uh socialism is an economic system
and there can only be two in the world
capitalism or socialism because every
economic system must answer one
fundamental question
who will own and control the wealth of
the country who will own and control the
means of production the question can
only be answered two ways either a few
will own or everyone will own it's as
simple as that and under capitalism we
say
please
please summarize that we might have no
i'm going i thought i had 20 minutes
it's my i thought i had 20 minutes i was
going by the clock
how much time do i have left i'm sorry
maybe i'm off that's what i thought i
did i was watching it i'm watching my
clock i'm irresponsible i'm
revolutionary
fact i can say it in two words black
power
and today we've gone to one but
africanism
yeah so there are only two economic
systems and it's going to be capitalism
of socialism capitalism is a backward
system there's no need to discuss it
certainly anyone who's been made a slave
by capitalism ought to be hesitant in
trying to support the system
but as a conscious african i must be
against capitalism and i must of course
seek to destroy it so in when you speak
of pan-africanism you must understand
you speak of socialism and we want to
underline there's only one
socialismality and that's scientific
socialism
whose principles are abiding and
universal there's no such thing as
african socialism chinese socialism
russian socialism arab socialism there's
only one socialism the confusion arises
over ideology that is that which guides
you towards your objective so we're
saying clearly here panafricanism is not
an ideology it is an objective it is an
achievable pan-africanism is the total
liberation and unification of africa
under scientific socialism all we want
is a unified continent with a socialist
system that's all but you know africa is
the richest kind in the world when she's
properly organized she'll be the most
powerful
yeah of course of course and me all i
want is power
i'm not like others i don't want money i
don't want popularity i just want the
power i'm supposed to get that's all
that's awesome
and africanism is moving into its final
stages which calls for mass organization
the all african people's revolutionary
party founded by osaji for kwame nkrumah
has already outlined this in his book
the handbook of revolutionary warfare
there are many uh people here in the
audience who are members of our party
the all african people's revolutionary
party we have chapters in america we
have chapters in south and central
america we have chapters in the
caribbean we have chapters in europe and
of course we have chapters in africa our
job is to unite all these africans
together we're not worried we stand
squarely in our history
marcus garvey did this already a long
time ago therefore it's not anything new
and those of us who know our history
know that it will spread like wildfire
and africanism then is revolutionary it
cannot be anything else but africanism
is the only solution for africans
because as the honorable marcus garvey
never ceased saying
until africa is free no african anywhere
in the world will ever be free or
respected thank you ready
[Applause]
thank you
is it michael
thank you can you hear me
well uh i would like to thank mister
[Music]
next we'll have
next we'll have
who is a member of our central council
for the united african organization
she'll be introducing mr maleficent
thank you
goodbye
dr malefice
asante is professor and chair department
of african american studies at temple
university the premier center for the
graduate training in african american
studies
considered by his peers to be one of the
most distinguished contemporary scholars
ahsante is the author of 38 books the
latest are classical africa african
american history a journal of liberation
malcolm x as co a co as cultural hero
love dance poetry and illustrations and
the african intellectual heritage edited
by asante and dr abua abari
he has
published more scholarly books than any
contemporary african author and has
recently been recognized as one of the
10 most widely called i'm sorry widely
cited african americans asante received
his phd from ucla at the age of 26 and
was appointed a full professor at the
age of 30. at the state university of
new york at buffalo he is the creator of
the phd program in african american
studies and the director of more than 60
phd dissertations making him one of the
major producers of phd's in the nation
he has written more than 200 articles
for journals and is the founder of the
theory ethocentricity indeed his book
afrocentricities
the afrocentric idea and chemic
afrocentricity and the knowledge are the
key works in the field sought after as a
speaker and consultant nationally and
internationally
asante was born in vast dala
georgia one of his one of 16 children he
is a poet
dramatist painter and gardener
his work on african culture and
philosophy has been cited by journals
such as journal
the journal of black studies empotad
journal of communication western journal
black studies
and afrocentric scholar
recently the utne magazine called him
one of the
100 leading thinkers in america and
asante has recently recommended was
recently recommended in a survey as one
of the 25 influential african male
leaders in of the last 200 years
he appears regularly on shows like
nightline
night talk bt mcneil and leary news hour
today show and the tony brown show
and nightwatch
he has received honorary degrees for his
community and educational work asante is
the founding editor of the journal of
black studies
and was the president of the student
nonviolent coordinating committee at
ucla in the 1960s recently he was made a
traditional king
nana akuru kita asante carubia the first
and
shadihini of tafu in ghana dr asante has
been
or is presently a consultant for the
school district of detroit new york
baltimore camden cleveland the virgin
islands trenton new orleans and gary
indiana
for
writing curricula an activist scholar he
believes it is not enough to know one
must act to humanize the world
i introduce dr melife asante
[Applause]
what's up
i want to thank the united
african association
here at the university of cincinnati
for this opportunity to have a
discussion
with one of my heroes
i must tell you that those of you who do
not know because some of you are perhaps
very young
you
are having a very great
occasion tonight to be in the presence
of someone who has
made his mark and is making his mark
on our history
we we don't often
recognize sometimes
the people among us
and here is a
man who
has done so much for the african world
and i remember when i was a student
and working with snick at ucla
he was
at that time
one of the individuals that i
most
respected and i still
respect him quite a lot
that doesn't mean that i agree with
everything he says
but
quite
correctly however i don't think that
there is much that he said tonight that
i
take
a lot of exception to i am
normally not used to debating people
that i agree with
uh so much
i mean they normally have me pitted with
dinesh d'souza
or arthur schlesinger or
mary lefkowitz or somebody like that
but
tonight i'm really delighted to be able
to
explain what i think might be some
differences
in the discussion that we have heard
from
kwame tori
afrocentricity
is the theory that says
that african people
can never achieve unity
until we first have
consciousness
consciousness
precedes unity
unity
operates on the basis of common
interests and objectives
the african world indeed african people
here in the caribbean on the continent
of africa
all of us
have been moved off of our own
terms psychological terms
political terms economic terms
philosophical terms cultural terms
linguistic terms fashion terms name
terms whatever we've been moved off of
our terms we're not operating on our own
terms normally
when you are moved off of your terms and
you are not operating on your own terms
and you do not view yourself as an agent
that is as an actor
as one capable of acting
in any context
then you will never be able to create
pan-africanism
pan-africanism
or any
movement must first of all fundamentally
be based
on the notion that individuals see
themselves as subjects as centered not
as objects in the margins of europe
not on the fringes of the european
experience not imitating or following
after europe but are centered in their
own african experience as african people
and view themselves
from that particular perspective that of
course
means a number of things
that it is the european intervention in
the last 500 years
that is most responsible for moving us
off of our terms
i will never forget
reading once
what makalei said about the indians in
india when he was a colonial
administrator in india
that it was the purpose of the british
government to make of the indian people
british and opinion
british and desires
and ideas
british and aspirations
and everything british
accepting color
and i think that when i consider the
situation with african people
both on the continent of africa and in
the diaspora
i have to assume
that the
same purpose or the same intent or the
same mission
was meant for african people
consequently to move us off of our own
terms
that's why i always say
that colonization and enslavement
twins
of the capitalist
domination and exploitation of african
people
have been just as
effective with us
as with other people but even more so
when you think of the fact
that more
african people
have been destroyed
at the hands
of this domination
let me explain something
slaves are not born
slaves are made
but how do you make a slave
you make a slave by creating the loss of
memory
if you create the loss of memory and you
create historical amnesia
then it becomes possible for individuals
to no longer remember and when they no
longer remember
to whom they are connected
their own traditions
then they will follow any tradition
but you cannot have therefore on the
continent of africa or
in the diaspora any
unity that would bring about any
pan-african idea we have as juanitore
has told us
since 1900 since sylvester williams
we've been talking pan-africanism
but you know why we have not had an
effective pat africanism
operating because we have not had a
philosophical base
without afrocentricity you cannot have
pan-africanism you can have a discussion
about it you can have rhetoric about it
you cannot have you have to have
ideas
you must have interests
you must have institutions mechanisms
for carrying out pan-africanism
but you cannot have ideas or interests
or institutions until you have african
people on the same page
negroes do not talk to africans
and black people don't want to have
anything to do with colorful
and on the covenant of africa itself
we are suffering today
and the fracticidal wars on the
continent itself because we do not have
a philosophical base
i mean the who too
and the two things
it's a good example
the innovation of europe has created a
situation
that has not allowed consciousness
we don't have the same mission in mind
and that's why we don't have any african
governments
i lived in zimbabwe
not as long as kwame has been in guinea
but i lived there
but i didn't see an african government
there
i wonder whether or not we have one in
getting i haven't been there i can't say
that but in the other countries 27
countries i've been in i haven't seen
any african governments
what i have seen
i have seen african people in government
i have seen african people
running governments
but i have not seen an african
government
because african
people
do not yet have an afrocentric
philosophy
in terms of the masses of course we have
we have afrocentric clubs in
sierra leone and ethiopia zimbabwe and
nigeria and other places but but i mean
the masses
so that what we have
in the governmental structure
would be individuals who are imposing a
european system of government on the
masses
so you got black people in government
but they have never truly understood
the intellectual
ideas the conceptual ideas the political
ideologies of the old people
you will never have
anyone who will march into
the royal palace at kumasi
and have a coup d'etat
on the asante hini of the paramount king
it might happen in our crop with the
modern state government but it will not
happen with the traditional government
because
we have never
taken the
the village the legitimate
ideas and concepts
of traditional african society the
things that made those societies
legitimate in the eyes of people and
employed them in the modern government
we have had problems over and over again
take the empire of ghana it lasted 1500
years
from 300 bc
to 1240
when sundiata the king of mali defeated
suman guru the emperor of ghana
of 1500 years how did they do it
do we even investigate it
do we ever even think about it
and let me just say this
that when we talk about
afrocentricity
we are not talking about the philosophy
that is anti-anybody we're talking about
a proactive african
philosophy african people as centered as
subjects as actors we are not merely
to be seen only or to be seen at all
on the fringes of the european
experience we ourselves
people with ideas
with our own
concepts
of politics
and as for
economics i think that
we have to navigate between the
deformations
of socialism
and capitalism and i don't see
capitalism and socialism as their only
alternatives and this is why
um and kwame said that african socialism
wasn't a good idea julius naieri wrote a
whole book called african socialism and
i think that basically what the
president of tanzania was he was trying
to deal with was this whole question
that somehow we should not be pitted
between one european idea and another
european idea
that africa itself
has contributed enough
in terms of how human beings deal that
we don't have to be stuck with the heavy
baggage of historic failure that we see
both in capitalism
and in
the worst forms of socialism
bureaucratic authoritarianism
regimented regimes
i mean the collapse of socialism
in those instances in those examples
should be enough
to at least make us wonder how in the
world or why in the world would we
follow after false gods
it would seem to me that the
afrocentrist
would rather say
that pan-africanism comes about or can
come about
fundamentally when we first of all
have a clear understanding that strategy
is better than strength
that not only is strategy better than
strength but once we have a strategy
based on our own interpretation of
ourselves and history
we will understand
that common
origin
common
objectives
and common condition
of what creates
unity
i mean we could talk about the unity of
europe and how europe is unified but
europe is unified on the basis of common
interest
when it's unified
and i believe that the future of africa
is in the hands of those who truly
understand that for african people to be
free to be liberated in our own minds
is the first step toward developing
a pan-african unity between african
peoples
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
at this time we're going to give the
audience a moment to collect their
thoughts so
let's keep that
oh i guess we're going to go right to
the the questions
and miss jameson hall the moderator will
take over from here
[Applause]
[Music]
i'd like to address this question to
opposition
um
the first one it resolved is some
comments made by
dr sanchez how do you respond to
the
notion that you cannot have pentax
without eccentricity
that's the first one
and the second one
is how you respond to the notion of
socialism and
capitalism is really two european
concepts both of which might not be the
answer for
african people
without going through afrocentricity so
i don't know how i got here
but i got up in africa without going
through alphacentricity
i didn't go through afrocenturies to get
to pan-africanism i arrived straight at
it and pan-africans have been around a
long time before afrocentricity we said
the first pan-african conference was in
1900
just because we've not achieved
pan-africans today doesn't mean it's not
achievable that sounds like maybe you've
got uh some uh confusion with the
american capitalist system of uh
everything is instant you know instant
coffee instant this instant replay but
freedom is not instant it is an eternal
struggle therefore from 1900
[Applause]
therefore for 1900 up until now and i
began by showing you that it started
when we were first interrupted do you
think that the africans who were put
into slavery were not fighting for
africa they didn't fight they waited
until afrocentricity no the struggle
continues afrocentral is only a term it
doesn't give the content of the struggle
the struggle is always there there's a
scientific law wherever there's
oppression there is resistance even if
you cannot detect it with the naked eye
there is resistance look at the united
states of america they went all over
talking about their nafta thing they
thought they had everything under
control january 1st last year the japan
was jumped up started shooting up
everywhere where did they come from
wherever there's oppression there's
resistance even if you don't detect it
with the naked eye and i know that
wherever africans have been oppressed we
fight multi-form but we fight so uh
i don't understand that point
capitalism socialism also seems to be a
tendency here the afrocentrics
you know one of the errors i think they
make is that they allow hear me
carefully they allow the particular
history of europe to become the
universal history of the world and then
they react
no not me i know the particular history
of europe is not the issue of the world
i know this i know this
i know africa has made great
contributions to humanity great
contributions capitalism and socialism
are economic systems they have
absolutely nothing to do with europe
karl marx did not invent nor found
socialism even though many people say
that he just discovered it that's all he
discovered the laws of socialism he
didn't found it we call in america the
laws of gravity newton's laws but newton
cannot invent that the body falls at 32
feet per second squared
marx cannot invent that where capital
oppresses labor that labor will rise up
and overthrow capital marx cannot invent
this as a matter of fact i would like
professor
asante to go and read iban kaldun an
african indonesia in the 12th century
who in his writings use terms like
surplus surplus value property rights of
property he used all the terms that karl
marx used and he wrote in the 12th
century and he was an african the values
of socialism are to be found in
communalism and i'm sure professor
asante knows that communalism lasted
longer in africa than any other
continent
therefore obviously those values are
there easy for us to bring alive to a
socialist system socialism and
capitalism has nothing to do with europe
just like air and water has nothing to
do with europe though europe will let
you think that they invented both air
and water and you might think
[Applause]
[Music]
no i'm asking him to respond to your
response
well the first thing that came to my
mind just off the top of my head was
first of all that evan caldoon was a
racist and i have read him and called
doom
um and he said some very negative things
about african people
so
but let's get to the heart of the matter
um if we for example
take the notion of europe
and we look at uh europe in terms of it
a particularism and afro-centuries i
don't know any afro-centuries look at
europe in the sense of universal
as a universal culture in fact what the
afro-centuries have argued is that the
particular expression of europe
has been imposed on other people as if
it is universal that the europeans have
done that that in fact the europeans
have done that with with all of their
concepts whether they speak of uh the
classical world and they impose that as
if uh it's only greece and rome or
whether they speak of classical ballet
and impose uh
that as if it's only the dance of europe
the the whole notion of the imposition
of a particularism as a universalism
really is um
is not a afrocentric notion it's a
notion of it's a
european notion and that's what they
have done so we don't uh we don't we
don't we don't project that and then
attack that we see that uh as
part of what has happened to african
people that african people for example
in terms of uh
say pan-africanism if we take
pan-africanism as an objective
of african people that is
the unification of africa and the and
the african world uh and african people
if we see that as an objective
that an objective itself
is is not a program an objective is not
a philosophy
uh pan-africanism as a gold is not a
philosophy and so it is true that you
can have
pan-africanisms a pan-africanist
before afrocentricity but those
individuals like for example kwame
nkrumah
who articulated the idea of
pan-africanism
uh in a concrete way coming out of his
philosophy of cautionism
was what you might call an incipient
afrocentrist he wouldn't he didn't say
that but any individual who says
that our particular response to the
universe must be from our own culture
is an afrocentrist i mean that's a
person who's an agent that's a person
who's an actor kwame nkrumah believed
fundamentally in an afrocentric
worldview but you but what i am saying
my position is that if you say you are a
pan-africanist and you are not
afrocentric
then the question is
and perhaps
kwame tory can as it is
are you a eurocentrist
um more questions that i'd like to ask
before we take our break and then turn
over to the audience
the first one is
is addressed to both of you
um
dr santi how does that centricity
address women's
oppression
for
mr
toure how does the all african people's
revolutionary party address women's
oppression
africa gave to the worlds the very first
queens
centuries ago
and if my memory serves me correctly
it's a little pamphlet written by
professor john henry clark
he points out through great
documentation
that every time a queen was on the
throne and africa was attacked there was
no compromise at all
[Applause]
john henry clark points out that during
the reign of our queens in africa africa
advanced technologically economically
and in every other arena
therefore as a conscious african
i would understand clearly that i could
be easily directed by queens the only
queen you read about in the holy quran
is a queen that comes from africa
the only queen you read about in the
bible are queens from africa
therefore declare here as a conscious
african i understand the role of women
africa gave to the entire world
matriarchy on a continental wide basis
where here the woman has the power and
inheritance passes through her
therefore i understand this the
destabilization of our society was
caused by colonialism
making uh women then become the slave of
the slave
clearly so she now suffers triple
oppression not only from the colonials
but from african men themselves who
instead of fighting the enemy tries to
take out their frustration on the women
which is certainly backward there's no
question here the way to solve
the way to solve the problem
the way the all african people's
revolutionary party solves the problem
is that we have
looked at history and other
organizations we have inside of our
party the all
african women's revolutionary union
women are oppressed because they lack
organization
that's why they're oppressed
consequently if you're really serious
about liberating women you let women
create their organizations and give them
the power the all african women's
revolutionary union is the most powerful
arm inside our party there is no other
wing of our parties organized like they
are they're the most powerful we will
never have an all african men's
revolutionary union men oppressed women
if you want to stop the problem you
break down the organization of men you
create the organization of women and you
let things roll the women will come to
their rightful place therefore our
position women must be organized and
they must be organized to fight for
themselves they will not be liberated by
their brothers by their husbands or by
their lovers
[Applause]
the philosophy of afrocentricity
believes that
the liberation of women
much to
in the same order as samara michelle
once said
is not an act of charity
and because it's not an act of charity
but a fundamental necessity
for any mature people
the afrocentric
position
is that we must challenge any death
producing system
of gender warfare class warfare race
warfare sex warfare and women
have not as much right but more
are right
than men who have oppressed them as
paternalists
and in a patriarchal system than anyone
else to fight this liberation struggle
and afrocentric women are fighting the
struggle afrocentricity does not take a
position
against
women and we strongly believe
in
the historic role of women from the time
of hatch-up sudden before who have
participated fully in the governance and
the direction of african affairs i mean
we have in our own history of course
tremendous uh examples and we named them
fannie lou hemer anna julia cooper for
example and so forth so
afrocentric afrocentricity as a
philosophy
certainly
is a
is perhaps
the most progressive
position that one could have because
it's about agency it's about women
taking their own agency it's about
women seeing their own
sense of being actors as being
centered and subjects
as being initiators as being those who
are responsible for their own
perspective and viewing
the world through those eyes so
afrocentricity is that sense is
fundamental to the liberation of women
[Music]
um
[Applause]
i'm
[Laughter]
talking about the jesus
are there any questions
over there
please keep in mind that mr toure has a
plane to catch
there's somebody speaking
my question is as an african american
person african person born in america
how do we prepare ourselves mentally
emotionally
physically and spiritually for this
revolution
to me
to me or to both of us to you sir uh the
way we do that is by joining
organizations because revolution must be
done through a systematic manner and
organizations must do it one of our
weakest aspects of our people is that we
are totally disorganized
we can come together in a minute a
million more people and then sit down
and forget all about it we have no
sustaining power because we have no
organizations therefore to correct this
each and every one of us will join an
organization this has been our constant
theme i all my life i belong to
organizations all the great people i
know belong to organizations malcolm x
was so bad that when he left the nation
of islam he created two organizations
you know the muslim mosque incorporated
the organization african-american unity
martin luther king was a bad brother i
knew him had a chance to see him but he
had an organization the southern
christian leadership conference fannie
lou him a bad sister she has an
organization assata shaku bad sister she
got organization angela davis when she
left the communist party quite quickly
went to the corresponding societies for
correspondence everyone and i've always
been in organizations all my life our
people do not belong to organizations
they think that they are great they are
super banned they are greater than
martin luther king greater than malcolm
x but once we begin to humble ourselves
we will join organization once we all
become organized
freedom will follow just like the sun
follows the moon
[Applause]
thank you
questions respond to just say one thing
i agree with uh brother torre
except that i would just add one thing
that
it seems to me that we are
we are organized i mean if you look at
all the organizations in the
african-american community
the so-called not-for-profit
organizations the churches
there's a lot of organizations in the
black community uh so it's not so much
organization that we need but
organization with purpose
see i i don't i don't um i don't think
that i think that we have to be careful
about just simply saying organization
we need to be in organizations that are
clearly defined their missions are
clearly defined and they have a purpose
otherwise we're simply just
we don't have the proper vehicle to get
us to where we think we need to get to
save time i want to take you to a
logical conclusion listen to my
statement
bad organization is better than no
organization at all
you heard my statement
the fact what you say is not true
less than three percent of our people
belong to organizations go anywhere you
are among africans ask them which
organization i don't believe in
organization
oh they just jive they're corrupt
they're taking the money they ain't
doing right you know farrakhan ain't
serious you know all they can do is
criticize they don't belong to
organizations asking you how many people
belong to organizations you will see we
do not belong to organizations this is a
tragedy we have more organizations than
any other community in america but less
people organized in them the naacp has
less than two percent of the population
as members
so how can they were organized
well perhaps we have different
statistics it seems to me that the the
great
number of african-americans are in
churches those are organizations but
they're not
the kind of organization that will lead
us to where we need to get to but
they're in organizations black people
are in organizations and i think that
what we really need to talk about sorry
it's very clear i said organizations
struggling to free the people up but
then we agree okay
but
i just
i just i guess i just took your idea of
precision yeah i wanted to make sure
that i was before i said it before but i
also want to let you know now during the
1960s those churches did a hell of a lot
of fighting in the south
that's right and produced some awful
powerful preachers like fred shuttlewood
ct vivian that's true
is enhanced by the agreement between you
two because i was just about to say that
after synthesizing what mr torreira had
to say and what mr ashanti had to say it
seems like it's a kind of a word play
really both positions really support one
another i think before we can have an uh
pan-africanism we've got to have us
our own cultural terms and viewpoints so
our our schools curriculums board on the
continent and in the states in the
caribbean wherever we are has to be
similar today in africa we all read i
read european history i didn't know
anything about myself i was born and
raised in nigeria it makes me a
caricature of the european not the black
and that i need to be
so in order for us to pan-africanize
we've got to
offer centric size thank you
[Applause]
so that we can take advantage of the
time so so my question is to mistake
me to write
and we we've gone way back you know that
so would you address
my position
which is in order for us to and
africanized we've got to first of all
after century science
but
but this could only be done in an
organization my brother
if you sensitize yourself of what good
are you to the rest of us
and you can't even sensitize yourself it
must be done in organization unless
we're organized we're not doing it our
part of the all african people's
revolutionary party in 1972 told
everyone that we're going to make
africans in this country use the word
african and we're not going to do it
through the press we rolled up oscars
and went to work they even call
themselves african americans today soon
they're going to get rid of the
americans and come right home africans
in america
so you can't centralize uh by yourself
it has to be an organized form i want to
let you know now if you speak of
pan-africanism you speak of organization
of revolutionary organization as precise
as that which the vietnamese had when
they destroyed american imperialism
brother tuvay my question is to you on
the issue of african government do you
agree with dr asante on the point of the
african iran country is non-existent
he's uh he's probably correct the
overwhelming majority of our leaders all
over the world represents nothing but
the scum of our race that's just a fact
that's just a fact
yeah it's a fact
but uh
but of course he wells knows that uh
since independence great moves were made
to carry out what we're speaking about
here kwame nkrumah made them uh julius
nerey making movements uh seculare of
course patrice lumumba uh nasa uh
gaddafi is still making them so
these attempts were made of course the
job of the empiricism to knock them down
one by one and make it appear as if
there is no alternative except
neocolonialism but kwami and crew
informed us that neocolonialism is the
last stage of imperialism we're going to
knock it down and go straight to a
unified socialist continent
with that point with that point being
made with that point been made if that
is the case that we are up against as
far as our continent mother africa
then how can we align ourselves here in
america and other parts of the country
that's a true unity if we don't have a
country that is ran by the mass of the
people for example the all african
people's revolutionary party has great
relationships with many organizations
revolutionary organizations in africa
many of them we have relationship with
the democratic party of guinea we have
relations with the african uh party for
independence in guinea guinea
guinea vasa and cape coast paigc
since they split
yeah
we've had relations with all the
liberation movements zappos mpla for
limo p-a-c-a-n-c swappo japo et cetera
et cetera we continue these
relationships the relationship for us
must be made with the peoples that with
the governments when the governments are
corrupt in libya you have a serious
government there was no qaddafi is not
corruptable that's what they don't like
about him that's what they're like he
cannot be corrupted do you agree doctor
yeah i think i basically agree with that
thank you
yes my name is uh my name is deville i'm
from dayton ohio
27 year old businessman own my own
business uh record label i'm an artist i
have other artists that's down with me
and um we positive for the black you
know we're uh racist we respond to
racism and i just wanted to take a few
seconds probably about a minute and 10
seconds to just drop something for y'all
and everybody that's in here okay
i just
i'm taking you to another style while
serving the same serious subject i'm
leaving the [ __ ] in the dust trying
to get brown people to retrospect and
check in charge people the panther
that's pale and pink he's trying to get
and be a tan man but he cannot stand the
original man who's black but also
sometimes call us brown but we were the
first to see the sight to hear the noise
of sound is proof in the bible it says
the man was made from the dirt of earth
bad news to the pink people uh oh oh no
there's no pink dirt
so here's some advice pink people get it
fixed cause a big big big bunch of the
bible took place in egypt yet and still
you led to jesus christ movie come on my
tv and i see nobody know one body with a
complexion the same as me this really
makes me sit back start cracking up i'm
laughing at you cause you act like you
don't want me to know that egypt is in
africa
but for me it's easy to squint and see
the brainwashing things you do so i tell
blacks and average whites to get them
against them mad at you i do this only
so to know the place you trick to keep
control
but blue eyed devil i'm warning you now
you will be selling your soul to the
brown eyed devil two fingers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a rhetorical question
[Applause]
this question is for uh
brother tourey and brother
asante you're both arguing good points
but what's of interest to my mind is
brother toure what is your
view of african centricity and brother
asante what is your view of
pan-africanism
[Applause]
uh
trying to claim a lot of people is
afrocentrist of course i was very
shocked when he said kwame nkrumah was
an afrocentrist because uh i don't know
why the word afrocentric why not african
uh thought
uh instead of afrocentric thought uh i
do not wish to put afrocentric thought
in europe i just want to keep african
history clear and then look at the
history of europe look at this from the
eyes of an african
uh the fact that we've always said that
the ideology has come from culture is
nothing new the animal mark is god he
said this
uh
so and that's been a long time ago of
course uh
um
if you read increment promise said i've
read all the great books in the world
i've read hegel i've read marx i've read
lenin but he says the book that fired my
enthusiasm the most was the principles
the philosophies and opinions of the
honourable marcus garvey
and so it's clear that when you find a
lot of writings if you trace them back
from increment you'll find them going
right back to marcus garvey uh africans
are what was for cultural struggle as a
matter of fact we think one of the
problems with uh european revolutionary
movements is that they didn't rage
cultural revolution this was done
outside of europe since the 60s mao cito
raised a cultural revolution in africa
cultural revolution throughout
central and south america and the
caribbean cultural revolution so
cultural illusion has been waged
cultural revolution has to be waged by
those who've been colonized because they
first have to get their culture back in
their hands in order to guide their
movements forward so when you say that
afrocentrism needs this it's a fight
first of all to regain the integrity of
our culture
and this fight you have to wage serious
battle for it doesn't just fall from the
sky and then you read a lot of books and
said okay i got my thoughts together let
me go watch it and fight no it's in the
struggle that you become
a politically aware not away from the
struggle it's in the struggle because
it's only action that verifies theory
[Laughter]
you knew where i was going
yes
pan-africanism to me
is
is the goal
the objective
of the unification of africa
it's the it's a it's a grand objective
whether or not it will be realized in
the next 100 years
i do not know in fact
i hardly think so the reason
it cannot be realized in the next
hundred years
is because we do not have the mechanisms
in place
the institutions in place
to articulate
a commonality of interest
of african peoples in fact
that is what
i believe
brother torrei is working toward but i i
don't think that you can
effectively create that
uh without having
some common consciousness on the part of
the people
and
consciousness
in fact
may come through struggle but it does
not necessarily come through struggle in
fact
one of the things that we learned in
southern africa
was that when the people in mosum beat
claim
that the revolution
was itself
a university and all we had to do was to
get people involved in the revolution
and we would have change in their
attitudes
what we discovered
was that after the revolution
and the people came out of physical
struggle
they were still psychologically enslaved
in fact if you go to zimbabwe right now
and well let's not even take zimbabwe
let's take south africa if you go to
south africa right now
you will discover in south africa that
the masses of people even though they
had gone through struggle at least in
part
are still psychologically and culturally
and educationally and economically
dominated so struggle
is not necessarily
the
vehicle for consciousness it ought to be
and in most instances it can be
[Music]
good evening good evening brothers my
name is victor
um
you know i'm listening to the
discussions and the explanations of
afrocentricity or african-centered
thought however one would would perceive
to define it in our limited english
language and then also uh the concepts
of pan-africanism
and to me
i seem to absorb both equally well and
easily it seems like my right side
understands the critical thought
necessary to organize and seek out
organization and my left side
understands the creative thought
necessary i don't see why there should
be really
maybe i'm perceiving this wrong
i'm trying to get please please
understand that
a sound by question won't help me get to
what i want to get to i'm going to hurry
up
the problem
behind you
okay okay the problem that i see is that
i don't think there's one before the
other i think they must come together
and i think at the same time i'm worried
about what i have seen in many black
movements and that is the support of a
totalitarian state though a black
nationalist one or a technocracy a black
nationalist one that doesn't really
foster the ideas of freedom and in my
idea democracy and i'm not using any
european sense so please help me with
this this concept here and
offer some reassurance that neither one
of you are doing something that would
eliminate our our freedom and our
ability to grow as a people that we're
part of this movement you understand
brothers thank you
[Applause]
yeah i i think that uh that even taken
uh taking um a
quantitative notion of pan-africanism
and scientific socialism and
afrocentricity i think that we are both
uh totally committed uh to uh human
freedom and to
the fulfillment of the human personality
and to the expression of social justice
i mean i don't think and i think that
we're committed to participatory
democracy
so
i don't think you have to worry about
that but i think that i agree with the
top
end of your question statement uh
regarding the fact that
pan-africanism on one hand uh you
understand with your right side of your
brain i guess you said and um
and uh afros intricitated with the left
uh
that's
that's plausible and it's plausible
in ways that i wish i could get my
brother cuemotore to understand
um that
i i have i believe in pan-africanism and
i think that it is possible
that the political philosophy of
socialism
uh might
have something to contribute
to some form of african communalism
that we may not yet have explored
however
it is fundamental that pan-africanism
not be viewed simply
as an objective without a vehicle
it has to have an intellectual content
it has to have
some perspective so that when i view
someone from nigeria or from ghana
they will not see me
as not being a part of the african
continent in other words we had that
problem in dar salam where there and we
had in lagos in festac where there were
continental africans who did not want
afro-brazilians and afro-cubans and
africans from the united states to be a
part of the colloquium because they felt
that they were somehow not african or
they did not control government this is
only because there was no philosophy if
there had been an afrocentric philosophy
where we understood
that wherever we were in whatever
capacity as african people we were
self-actualizing we were actors we were
agents and we would we would have
greeted each other but that cannot
happen until you have a philosophy and
there is no philosophy that moves
pan-africanism that way
let me uh
and i think that we have i think that we
have reached for socialism because we
never created afrocentricity
[Applause]
let us try and use precise terms from a
revolutionary point of view
there is an objective and an ideology
there's been much confusion in the world
since the 1900s
and this confusion was spread and
unfortunately aided by the soviet union
that marxism leninism was the only
revolutionary ideology in the world
of course as a young man studying
masculinism just created a lot of
confusion for me
the first aspect of the confusion was
found in the fact that if one is a
feminist one must be atheist
certainly atheism in the african
community
they said no you know you believe in god
don't you know you believe in god
you know so there's there's no way and
the second point was their limited view
on nationalism and its role in struggle
these are my two conflicting of course
there are many others i'm just pointing
out two
so since the 1960s those of us who were
conscious strugglers i've been really
examining this problem
conscientiousness was written in 1964
it was called subtitled philosophy for
decolonization
therefore the philosophy is giving our
party has as its objective i've never
said anything since tonight i've said
pan-africanism's objective our ideology
is in criminism to raise them
therefore we do and that that i i'm
sorry i didn't know but anybody who's
familiar with our party knows that our
party's ideologies and criminalism
tourism our objective is pan-africanism
therefore it's the thoughts and actions
of incriminating tourism which
represents all the struggles of africans
who came before cabral all the others
leading us to pan-africanism so we do
have this problem solved for our party
we agree with you there is much
confusion around pan-africanism and most
pan-africanists do not have an ideology
some try to use marximism to get them to
pan-africanism that cause a lot of
confusion i just gave two examples but
our party has no confusion here and
criminalism tourism is our ideology
leading us to pan-africans
so would you please
um continue with your questions
how does the pan-africanist and the
afrocentrist view the role of
spirituality or spiritual culture in the
liberation of african people
africa is a
very
spiritual continent
if we're just to isolate our
contributions to world religions we
would see this
the first sacred book in the world was
written by africa
in africa by written by africans in
africa over six thousand years ago
it's incorrectly called the egyptian
book of the dead
thanks to our struggle by many of our
intellectuals today who've applied their
skills to the people struggle they've
come to show that the real title should
be the book of coming forth i imagine
this is your area no much better than i
it was africa that gave to the world
monotheism belief in one god
it was africa that gave to the world
judaism and this one must be properly
understood because here a lot of
confusion comes into play and zionism
plays an evil role here trying to
confuse everything
uh judaism was given to rule by africa
it could only be given the world by
africa because in that part of the world
the only place where monotheism had been
accepted and was breeding was in africa
if you looked east to africa in persia
they were worshipping the sun
to the north of african palestine they
were shipping idols that would do so
until the prophet muhammad peace be upon
his name came to give them monotheism in
the form of islam so it was africa that
gave judaism to the world i know the
first jews in the world were africans
that's why i'm never confused they call
me anti-jewish i'm anti-zionist i can't
be anti-jewish my people gave you the
religion
on the question of christianity again
africa's role as you know when jesus
christ peace be upon his name was in
trouble it was only africa that gave him
refuge
that's where he grew up as a young man
learning and growing
the very first country mentioned the
bible
genesis 2 verse 13
uh is
nubia and ethiopia if my memory serves
it correctly i think in the bible they
call havilah and sometimes kush that's
genesis 2 verse 13.
if you just take the physical analysis
of the bible you will say egypt and
ethiopia is mentioned more than israel
of course we know of the role of africa
in giving protection to the disciples of
the prophet muhammad peace be upon his
name when they were in trouble and even
given refuge to uh
joseph when he was sold by his brothers
into uh egypt so africa is very
spiritual
society this spirituality must be
respected and must be understood but uh
by this we do not mean this betrayal be
broken down to religions that's where
people get confused between spirituality
and religion we just want to make that
clear but africa certainly has uh
throughout the continent a great sense
of spirituality and one which even if
you're not african when you're in the
continent you become amazed
[Applause]
i don't need to add very much to that in
fact what i do need to say however is
that in terms of afrocentricity and
spirituality
we we believe and we
also
think
that in terms of spirituality
that it is necessary
first of all to understand how african
people view
the universe
everything is everything
and if everything is everything
then it is
also
possible for us to see how
one develops ethics morals values and so
forth
if the earth does not belong
to you
but belongs to all the people
then there are certain ways you treat
the earth i mean there are ecological
assumptions that can be developed
uh
how you treat the rivers
how you treat the trees
uh the spirituality of african people
which is fundamentally
based essentially on the idea
that we all we all are part of the
universe and we're part of each other
means consequently that relationships
are basic
to african spirituality our relationship
to the ancestors our relationship
to
the unborn our relationship
to the deities our relationship to
nature all of these things are
relational and this is the fundamental
part of the african spirituality and we
have not often it seems to me since we
have been on this side awaken ourselves
to the full potentiality
of our spirituality and it is different
from religion because religion in this
country maybe everywhere religion
becomes whether it is islam or judaism
or christianity or hinduism
or yoruba
religion becomes the deification of your
nationalism it is the making sacred of
your
historical traditions and consequently
it is different from spirituality we're
open
to the spiritual challenges of the world
on the basis of our
being a part of the total universe
next question
my name is
and uh
brother there we were last together in
accra in 94 with maya angelou at the
padmore uh conference and my question to
you and um
professor asante he's kind of
clairvoyant he almost answered it but my
question to you is how do you given the
historical persecution of africans on
the continent and in the diaspora how do
you reconcile socialism and capitalism
seeing that historically neither has
seemed to work for african people and
and to professor asante
how do we reconcile the differences that
seem to be vast between continental
africans and africans primarily in
north america
well i don't understand your statement
where you say that socialism has not
worked
for africans
and how you can bring both them together
where our principles are concerned there
is no compromise there is no middle
ground
either you
tell the truth or you tell a lie there
is no middle ground
either you believe in god or you do not
there is no middle ground
capitalism is an exploitative system
either you're for an exploited status
exploitative system or you're for
socialism a non-exploitative system and
there can be no in between between
there's no in-between between slavery
and freedom
for me capitalism is slavery socialism
is freedom from the economic change
which capitalism holds us under of
course i may be incorrect but this is my
logic and you must understand my logic
well you know
[Applause]
i i don't want to i don't want to ask uh
professor torre this question so it's
going to be rhetorical and that that
question was following what the brother
said uh could he give an example where
socialism has worked but i'm not going
to pursue that uh let me just i know you
wouldn't because i know you wouldn't
but but and we and and we should get on
this question of principles and the
christians um because i i make my
judgment on christianity on the basis of
the christians but that's another story
in in response to
you know that
[Laughter]
in response to the question about the
continental i have never had any
difficulty with continental uh
africans so i whenever i hear this
question it always um
bothers me and i always try to figure
out
what the situation is and i think it has
a lot to do with the approach you know
that um
africans on the continent or maybe
africans in the diaspora take toward
each other
but
as an afrocentrist i take a fundamental
approach which is that the enslavement
and the colonization experience of both
of us
really put us in the same condition
and consequently i see people in the
caribbean and on the continent
and in south america as my brothers and
sisters and so i think that perhaps with
me
i would argue
that a strong
afrocentric orientation
toward pan-africanism might be a
solution to that problem
well they're beginning to talk about it
yeah but they're beginning to talk about
that's what i'm saying he said that
africans don't talk about afrocentricity
well afrocentricity is only 16 years old
as a as a intellectual philosophy and
and
the afrocentricity of the book came out
in
1979 or 80. so it is relatively a new
philosophy but already you have for
example herbert villikazzi in
south africa one of the professors there
is a strong
afrocentric scholar
you have many in africa i mean i could
name them in congo and zaire and so
forth so there are number of people uh
throughout the continent of africa even
in nigeria and ghana who consider
themselves to be afrocentric
philosophers thinkers so um so what i
would argue is that
the more we have the kind of
consciousness that we're talking about
the better it will be even for the kind
of relationship that we should have
my question is how will we finally be
able to come to a solution to stop the
corruption
among you know even the even those that
would be in charge you know what i'm
saying that's all i would like to know
once we finally arrive
at these particular points you know how
do we safeguard against the corruption
that's that's all i got thank you
the only question is through a
mass organization
which uh without fitting with our
mercy stampedes our corruption into
oblivion that's the only answer anything
short of that will not do it the reason
why our leaders are so corrupt is
because they don't have to account to
anyone
they do not have to account to anyone
there's no force with people organized
making sure that they're in power and
they will carry out nowhere so they do
whatever they want to do they're held
accountable not to us but to our very
enemies
even here you can look united states of
america after we shed blood to get the
vote they become mayors and become more
corrupt than the white mayors
and the reason they do this because they
have no one to roll accountable the only
answer is
[Applause]
when we're properly organized
when we're properly organized this
problem of corruption will cease because
once you have an organization you can
deal retribution
we said in the very beginning that one
of the weaknesses of the african
revolution was that traitors to the
revolution struck in our community with
total impunity and i mean they struck
that's right in the 1960s i snitched for
the fbi i got this brother killed this
brother went to jail and they just
stopped
nowhere else will this happen because of
our lack of organization therefore if
you're really concerned about it there
must be organization i want to tell you
now
i do not have any immediate solutions to
our problems
the only solution i have is constant
struggle
constant struggle constant struggle and
this struggle has to be matched with
constant political education of the
masses of the people
constant political education of the
masses of the people
of course you know in the back our party
always uh recruits it in the back when
you go out you find a table of our
responsibles from our party brothers and
sisters who try hard to organize us if
you're interested you should stop by
there if you want to join our party of
course you always invite you to but ours
was a revolutionary party a serious
party so if you're not serious go to
another organization and you would do
whatever you can but now
just one more question
i'm sorry our time is running out this
has been a great experience but i think
we can only take one more question mr
toray has the plane to catch
one more question
hi my name is steve
this question is directed towards mr
toure
i would like to know how would you see
the masses taking pan-africa socialism
and placing it in america would this
goal be accomplished by legislation
economics force or a combination
by
any
means
i'm looking for a little more direction
when you say that
i said i guess my question my question
just asked a little more direction no
that's the question of the organization
you join we have we have a map worked
out uh is anybody in our party he has
any propaganda which talks about
ecommerce and tourism by chance
you have please please uh make sure that
dr asante gets it uh we
no i'm sorry really i thought you knew
this i really did i'm sorry we solved
this problem of course we've just been
revolutionary circles we've solved this
problem uh so it depends our party has a
solution if you go to the local mosque
here the minister of the nation of islam
he's here is he not
minister is he here
he left
there he is right if you go to the
nation of islam and you should visit it
they give you another program
if you go to naacp they give you a
program your job is to decide which
program you think is the correct program
to lead us to freedom and if when you go
to the nation of islam you find oh they
just talked a lot of nonsense you go to
aprp they're just talking nonsense you
go to naacp they talk nonsense well then
you do what is necessary for all of us
you create the organization it's going
to lead us to freedom dr sander do you
have any response to that uh
the only response i have is that we all
have to collectively revise the
the the text of our people and we
collectively revise that tax
by struggle by constant struggle and
vigilance
and the national afrocentric institute
which is my organization
tries to do that
very effectively so
i've enjoyed the discussion with kwame
today thank you thank you all and kevin
has a word for you thank you all very
much shall we give them a hand
[Applause]
it's on to new hampshire for the
nation's first primary
tuesday night our live coverage begins
in manchester with the simulcast thanks
my pleasure as always
next a tribute to kwame toure formerly
known as stokley carmichael
in the 1960s he was a civil rights
activist with the student nonviolent
coordinating committee
mr turay was recently diagnosed with
prostate cancer and this tribute was
held to assist him with his health care
costs
before we introduce the next speakers
we'd also like to thank the
um
our partners exodus radio network
association your urban radio think tank
which is broadcasting live the living
tribute to kwame toure via satellite
nationwide please thank them
exodus is a radio network association
dedicated to linking urban communities
through satellite radio show the show
airs every sunday evening from 9 to 11
o'clock p.m eastern standard time for
those of you in the audience you can
become an informed member by picking up
your brochures in the foyer i'd also
like to announce that the documents that
mrs mazeek passed out will also be
available to a certain degree outside in
the hallway at the party table
if you would leave your name and numbers
there someone will be in touch with you
regarding those documents
as many of you know kwame is world
famous for his affinity with what we
call the people actually it's each and
every one of us individually as we know
him and as we love him
our next speakers are members of the
community that many of us know in a
small way and some of us might know in a
large way because they touch our lives
in different ways but we ask you
indulgence as we
uh invite several members of the
community to come and just give very
brief remarks about their love affection
and interest and support of kwame toure
they are
brother malik el farah khan with
ceasefire don't smoke the brothers
kwame arya organizer for the pan-african
student youth movement
and mr roach brown staff assistant to
mayor
the mayor offenders
affairs office
and after that we will have a cultural
presentation from the fantastic steel
band
[Music]
him
[Music]
in the name of allah benefits and
merciful all praises are due to allah
appear to us and the person
mastered every fraud muhammad and who
raised up in our midst one of the most
greatest leaders we had the honourable
master elijah muhammad and who also
raised up in our midst
minister louis farrakhan
a great and magnificent leader
and i would also have to add in there
brother kwame true this brother is so
great that i like for all of us to stand
and say long live
kwame true ray
i'd like for like the head from you let
me ahead
[Applause]
keep on saying if we can't say it enough
[Music]
we love you my brother
we love you my brother
and i would like to say it is a pleasure
and an honor to be here to say a few
words in his behalf
the brother has touched my life in 1968
coming straight from out of the belly of
the beast marin illinois one of the
worst prisons on the planet
i was in the nation of islam at the time
and they had an office on new jersey
[Music]
between o and p right next to a gas
station
and when you're in the nation you go out
and you do a little fishing
you try to get a brother or sister to
come out to the service
and the first brother that accepted my
invitation
was brother kwame to ray
and that was the greatest pleasure
that i had had
the brother touched my life not only did
he touch my life
he touched so many lives of brothers and
sisters that are truly inside of their
belly the beast and there
because they were true revolutionaries
they were also brothers and sisters they
were banned gods
when these brothers
and these sisters were out mobilizing
we knew that we had to have their back
we knew when they had the free breakfast
and free lunches
that they had to pay for some of these
things so there was a lot of brothers
who would go out and it was not
permitted and near one of these
organizations to do this
but a lot of brothers were guarding rob
banks
send money back anonymously
they was putting in the papers being
criminals and things of that nature
but when you truly down for your people
you're going to do what's needed
you're going to do what's needed if
brother kwame to ray
we're still in washington dc today
he would be going out in the street to
the young brothers that are in these
so-called gangs not to disband them but
to mobilize and organize them in the
right way
huh
he would say brothers people take this
in your community
he did it back then
and what did they do
they branded the brother
they made
or tried to make the community believe
that he was a straight
barbaric insane man
because he wanted freedom
and liberation for our people
the brother had him run across the world
for his life
brother kwame charade
i can sit up here and talk all day
but i'm not gonna do that
your work speak for itself i just wish
he was more in 1996 like you sir
the brother was truly about actions
not a bunch of words i mean yeah he
but he got out and demonstrated
what he taught he's a true leader
here we are today
in washington dc
chocolate city is no longer that
this is what i'm telling you
we let the people on capitol hill
punish us because we had enough guts to
elect
our mayor
huh
we didn't go out and do nothing about it
brother kwame toray would have been in
the forefront
he'd had a gang of brothers and sisters
out there
they put the control board in what did
we do
nothing
nothing
but brother kwame terrain
would have mobilized
he would have got brothers from all
across the country to be here
to tell these people no way
you're not gonna do it
what do we do
brother kwame
there's a lot of pain in my heart
looking around in this audience this
auditorium should be filled
they should be all up and down old
cattle town for you those of you that
don't know what that is georgia avenue
that's right out there
it should be all the way up to silver
spring brother
here on and you tonight
see it's a profound pleasure for me to
be able to do it because most of the
time we honor one of my brothers he's in
the grave
but you
are right here in front of us brother
right here in front of us
something else that i want to say
a lot of people don't understand
that the organization
the brother kwame charades started years
ago
took the youth from out of the street
made them into the soldiers that they
truly are
threw up the power sign black pile
started right here at howard university
i also made a piece of history with
brother kwame toure back then
because it was his speeches that caused
me to come to howard university back in
1968 and bring the muhammad speech
newspaper up here
and sell it
1996 we have a mars
on campus
but it all started with brother kwame
terrain
but the hurting part of it is i come
home three and a half years ago
i do
black history collages
did one is 50 000 years of history
sent it out right out here in the front
right here in front of krampton
auditorium
and about 20 or 30 brothers and sisters
went past and i said i will give you
twenty dollars
if you can name five persons or five
events
that represent our history do you know
it was so sad that not one person got 20
dollars
after this brother mobilized this here
where is our mindset how are the elders
and i got to go back to the elders how
are we letting our young brothers and
sisters out here in the street go buck
wow
get this book brothers
make it a part of your household
i'm sorry brother kwame to ray
make sure that you're young read it
don't fall a victim to the foolishness
brother kwame two way is still alive and
in good health
and brother we're gonna love you
with all our soul
and i just hope that i have the
fortitude in the guts that you have
brother to make the move and do what you
have done in your lifetime
your true living legend
assalamu
before we continue with remarks from the
other members of the community i'd like
to bring on ed and pearl murphy to make
a special presentation please
good evening
brothers
you thought i was my son
yeah you said oh yeah i know your dad
but i like first to thank uh bob brown
for inviting me here and giving me this
opportunity to see a
an old old friend what is the saying uh
one of the pleasures of
old eyes to see old friends something
like that but anyway it is a pleasure
you
have been a great deal to me and i know
you were not aware of it because be
honestly i was not aware until i saw the
reflect
that what
has given me my point of reference
and it goes back to the black united
front which you came here and organized
and i'm surprised no one mentioned it
uh
that's what shaped our present
government
i would there say that uh
three-fourths of them within the black
united front and went to the city
council
but that something would have strayed
we assume
yes you know where i'm going with it
yes
we assume
that the things we discussed that you
were teaching and preaching about in the
black united front that they were going
to carry it out once they became a
government official
that didn't happen they weren't trying
to
uh
better the community in terms of the
revolution they wanted to be part of it
and that's what seemed to be happening
now
and two important factors just
man-to-man saying what you delivered to
me to give me my point of reference
which incurred me through these years
that racism is institutionalized
i didn't understand that in the
beginning you know i own my little club
i'm doing my little thing but coming to
those meetings of the black united front
it sort of give me a point of reference
the other thing which was very important
and you caught a lot of flack in the
community in the press
when you talked about the white liberals
coming into the community
you said you wanted them to stay in
their own community and preach and teach
you understand so i came to the
conclusion out of that then that means
we must do for self
so then we begin to organize that is in
my head in the business community to say
we have to circle the wagons and support
each other it's not waiting for
someone else to do whatever for us
you also used to preach just how
ridiculous was to sit at a lunch account
let somebody spit on you and give them
your money too uh-huh so i'm just saying
i was just thinking how and where
i got my input and it was from the black
united front which was a spin-off to the
black united fund
which i was the secretary of and put the
first hundred dollars in to get that
started the black united fund with crowd
and roloff that came out of stokely
carmichael's the black united front
but i i just want to
really thank you and i really appreciate
being here and just to say these few
words because it's been a long time uh
since we were together and talking about
any of our
issues
so at this time i'm gonna turn it over
to my other half who wasn't there with
is my wife pearl murphy and we should
have a few words to say to you
thank you all so so so much and on
behalf of the over 1 000 members of the
african-american business association
brother kwame two ray we are ready for
the revolution and speaking of being
ready for the revolution we gotta be
ready spiritually
we gotta be ready politically and most
of all we gotta be ready economically
and when it comes times for us to
support each other we have to put our
dollars where our mouths are
just for that reason ed murphy is here
this evening to present two checks
totaling one thousand dollars being
presented to brother kwame to ray
[Applause]
and we want to leave you uh definitely
by saying god speed god bless you we
know that the lord is going to see you
through this is a temporary hurdle
because you're going to move on and just
to let you know did you ever know
that you
are here
it's on us to be
all
you helped us fly
higher
than
any yeah
you
have been
and you still are
the wind
beneath
[Music]
god bless you
good evening
all praises to god to allah
and to you brother uh commentary because
of you i'm here today
you turned my life around you gave me
parole mental parole
i was in prison back in the 60s when you
were doing your thing on 14 from you at
the drugstore and meehan's hardware
right up the street during the same time
he was doing a piece up at the clifton
terrace
we were inside a prison it was easy to
go to jail for committing the crime but
i couldn't understand how a man could go
to jail for what he believed in
it was easy to take something or to rob
or to steal but to go to jail because of
what you felt and what you believe took
a kind of heart and strength that was
unusual foreign to me as a result of
that
your actions inspired a whole movement
inside a prison
there's an old saying when you stand on
a rock on a bank and take a rock and
throw it into the river there's ripples
and you've made a lot of ripples brother
and some of the ripples stopped inside
of lord reformatory and other prisons
around the country as a result of what
you were doing out in the street
during the sixes we would call it
colored they had those lunch counters
that we couldn't go in the same thing
was going on inside a prison
we had segregated dining rooms inside a
prison we had a color count where the
black guys got on one side of the room
and the white person's got on the other
side of the room and what you were doing
out in the street gave us the idea why
should we put up with the same thing in
here we're doing it out in the street
as a result of that guys start
organizing when the ride happened in the
60s we had rise inside of prison very
few people are aware
that the civil rights movement in the
60s was also happening inside the
prisons as a result of what you were
doing hrab brown brother hobson and a
whole lot of other folks feather stones
folks have been involved
during the 60s you could not worship
except two religions in prison
catholic or baptist
if a guy wanted to be a muslim he
couldn't study inside a prison and
because of what you've done
in a spa that motivated a whole line of
guys who were called jailhouse lawyers
and they wrote laws they got bills
passed they got folks rights to web
you could wear your hair long you could
wear mustaches we had white products
inside of prison when you came around
when james brown came to washington
would that say it loud and black and
proud
we had all white products in the black
prison we were buying alberta of vo5 and
prairie and vitalis we didn't have
nothing black inside
as a result of this consciousness the
whole prison population turned around we
had educational courses we asked for
college courses guys started writing it
was like the harlem renaissance guys
started doing all kinds of uh creative
endeavors inside of prison as a result
of that i was able to come out of prison
and get my whole life together for that
brother i want to thank you from the
bottom of my heart and merry christmas
to you
[Music]
on behalf of the pan-african student
youth movement we would like to thank
the friends of kwame tori committee for
putting this program together
as pan-africanists we always seek to
place emphasis on organizations
organizations rather than individuals
and we see that brother torre is a
shining example of an organizer for our
people since the days of snake torre has
consistently worked been working with to
uplift the masses of our people to
organize structures and formations his
work validates the pan-africanist
approach to recruiting and organizing
students and youth who have always
played a major role in our struggle by
sparking revolution in addition brother
torre has played has given us a
practical example of how students can be
lifelong servants of the people
so we see that brothatory deserves our
everlasting love and respect not only
does brellatore deserve our everlasting
love and respect but the non-violent
action group the student nonviolent
coordinating committee the black panther
party the all african people's
revolutionary party and the democratic
party of guinea deserve the same we
understand that no individual develops
in isolation and therefore credit these
organizations which gave our comrade his
ideological direction
as our movement has deepened in its
ideological direction we see that kwame
torre has been right there with it
growing in his understanding of how to
heighten the struggle and consciousness
of our people tori has been a leading
proponent of revolutionary
pan-africanism the complete and total
liberation and unification of africa
under scientific socialism and was the
first one of the first to make the
ideological leap from black power and
nationalism to the to raise
so because of your long and impeccable
history of struggle the pan-african
student and youth movement would like to
extend our utmost thanks
and gratitude to our brother in combat
kwame toray
one unified african people one unified
socialist africa thank you
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
pantastic from kwame's homeland trinidad
and tobago
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
let's give our brothers a round of
applause
and sister
i know everybody wants to hear more of
it but we have we still have a way to go
and we want to move on i have the
responsibility now of introducing the
next three speakers everybody's all
right
all right
first speaking on behalf
of the national committee
for independent political action
will be attorney arthur conoy
followed by
a representative from a very strong
organization
the southern organizing committee for
economic and environmental justice
sister ann braden chairperson
and then a dear dear brother and friend
representing the american indian
movement babunanini vernon bellacord
all right
our sisters and brothers
it's an honor to have been invited to
participate
in this tribute to kwame
he has been a symbol of courage
of fearless struggle against the power
structure
the ruling class in this country and
throughout the world
i had the privilege
of meeting him first
in the early days of the 60s
in the deep struggles
that the black people in the south
had
developed
leading us all
i knew a man as stokely carmichael
he was the leader of the student
nonviolent coordinating
committee and those of us in the south
as people's lawyers
learned
fundamental truths from him
and what did we learn
that the most elementary rights of the
people
could be protected and won
only by
the mass struggles of the people
and as lawyers for the people
we had to learn
that litigation in the courtrooms
had to be understood
as organizing
tools for the people
we had to take the offensive
to challenge
the underlying conspiracy
of the
rulers to destroy
and abandon
the most elementary rights of the people
and to frighten the people
through their use of force and violence
of burnings and beatings
and lynchings
and they haven't stopped doing that
and kwame
was a role model for all of us
the struggles he led in the 60s
for the most elementary civil rights
not only for the black people
but for all the oppressed peoples of the
country
and the lesson he taught us
together with the other black leaders of
the battles in the deep south
was a lesson
that we must all remember today
and what was that
that the road
to freedom and equality
and a decent life
requires
a breakaway from the two-party system
controlled by the rulings
and the building
of a truly
independent
political party of the people
and these lessons
were essential for the past
and our crucial lessons
for today
so kwame
i have to say this to you
you were
a hero in the old days
and you are
a hero
today
so give this to him
my name is ann braden i am very
honored
[Music]
i'm very honored to be included in this
event tonight
because i'm one of the many people kwame
who's like in whose life you have been
very important
our paths crossed a number of times
over 30 years ago
when i was editing the southern patriot
the little newspaper that was covering
the freedom movement
i would often go to mississippi and
other places of activity and i'd always
find you if i could
because i knew you would tell me what
was really going on and what it meant
and then there was a time i don't know
whether you remember it or not when you
spoke at a board meeting of the southern
conference educational fund skeff which
i worked with then
skeff you may remember
was an interracial organization
whose outreach was to whites in the
south
we were trying to convince white people
that they should be on the front lines
supporting the civil rights movement of
that day
because it would mean their freedom too
obviously we didn't reach masses of
those people but we did reach and
activate some
our board was meeting in nashville i
believe it was spring 1967
and you were in towns speaking at
vanderbilt
and we ask you to come talk about black
power
and you did and there was some
discussion and you left
and later that evening all of us left
and after we were all gone nashville
exploded that night
one of those happenings that some people
called riots but we called them
rebellions
started i think by
as i recall a situation with the police
near fisk university
well for years afterwards we had to
fight about that
the police the mayor the newspaper and
senator mcclellan who purported to be
investigating what they call
disturbances in the cities
claim that you and we plotted that
uprising at the skeff board meeting
and all you were really doing there was
patiently trying to explain black power
to a bunch of white folks
then there was an incident
i guess you never knew about
i live in louisville kentucky
and one day we heard you had been
arrested in lexington kentucky which is
80 miles from louisville
and we wanted to know so we could raise
hell
but we couldn't find out
so i called the lexington police chief
and i said we hear stokely carmichael's
been arrested in lexington is that true
and he said no stokely ain't within a
hundred miles of here
and i said oh how do you know that
and he said because if he was anywhere
around here he'd be in jail
and i said oh
what would he be in jail for
and he said for being stokely carmichael
police chiefs were terrified of you
kwame
presidents of the united states were
terrified of you
but for maybe
for maybe more of us than you know
whether we were black white or green
those of us who were trying to transform
this society into a place that could be
good for all its people
for us you were like a flash of
lightning across the sky
illuminating our world and the and
making the thunder roll
when you began traveling the south the
southern campuses shouting hell no we
won't go
what had been a
protest movement against the vietnam war
became a resistance movement
everything changed
i guess skeff was one of the few maybe
the only
interracial organization that came out
in strong support of black power
we lost some financial support
but we were right
for we knew enough history past and
current
to understand that when
move in this nation
the country moves
we knew that the civil rights movement
of that period had already won
very real gains
that were resulting in the beginning
of progressive and humane policies that
were benefiting all of our people white
as well as people of color
and we knew
as we said in a 1967 statement that when
african-american people achieved real
power
we would be able to build the real
democracy for everyone that we
envisioned
we knew that it was our job to help
other white people understand that basic
truth
and we did convince some
unfortunately however
the voices telling white people that
african-americans had been had taken
away something from them and were
causing all their problems
had access to more white ears than we
did
and they kept up that refrain over the
past 30 years
which goes a long way to explaining why
this country is in the bad shape that it
is today
so today for those of us who are white
in 1996 in a sense we're fighting the
same battle for the minds of white
america that we were fighting in 1966
last week i reread parts of your book
black power and it sounds very current
one thing you said was
it is hoped that eventually there will
be a coalition of poor blacks and poor
whites
this is the only coalition that seems
acceptable to us
and you went on to say that to talk
about such a coalition then was purely
academic because there was quote no
power base among poor white people
dedicated to the goal of a free open
society
we worked to build a power base like
that kwame
we had some small breakthroughs and in
the years since then there have been
more breakthroughs but it has obviously
not been enough i want you to know
though
that many of us are still working for
that goal that you held up before us
today
the organization i work with now the
successor to the southern organizing
committee
is working for that
and i think perhaps has a better chance
than ever existed before of achieving it
as i know you know there's a new mass
movement
which we're working with
that's growing in communities of color
in the south
to stop the toxic pollution that is
literally killing people
and that movement
that movement
offers the only hope for survival
for working class white people who are
also sick and dying from those same
toxics
but as in the past coalitions don't
happen automatically
and you don't always win in the short
term
another thing we've all learned from you
kwame is that you don't quit when
victories don't come right away
we know as you know
that we're fighting 400 years of history
and the world we seek may not come in
our lifetimes
but we know too that what gives life
meaning
is to keep on working for that new world
and to know that we're on the right side
of history
that's where you've always been kwame on
the right side of history and we thank
you again tonight
[Music]
good evening dear friends greetings
my name is
i'm better known by my missionary
colonial name as vernon belcourt
a national representative for the
american indian movement
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
in
1972
a historic event took place
when indigenous people of many nations
across this land came to washington dc
as part
of a campaign called the trail of broken
treaties
it was an effort to fish and petition
this government
particularly the administration of
richard nixon
how ironic at a time that we should come
to washington to try to talk to
honorable people
we ended up with that gang
as many of you may recall
we were under siege at what is called
the bureau of indian affairs building
for seven days
and three of the first people
that walked into that building to
express their solidarity
was brother kwame toure and
representatives of the all african
people's revolutionary party
and we thank you very much brother
for that support
beginning then and continuing in today
we have come to love this brother very
much
fact is in 1976
on the 200th anniversary of the founding
of this settler regime called america
i was listening
i was listening to a radio broadcast on
national public radio
all of a sudden i heard this voice that
sounded familiar
and the message that this man made on
the 200th anniversary
went something like this
the indians have a history
the indians have a glorious history
it's not to be found in america's
history books
but it will be when the indian people
find their proper nationalism and
there's no power on this earth that can
stop it those are the words of brother
kwame toure we remember them well
at that time
we all became the targets of
two covert programs of the united states
government the fbi program cointelpro
and the cia program operation chaos
these programs were designed to
infiltrate various movements
to misdirect to disrupt to discredit to
demonize the leaders of various
movements in order to destroy these
movements
during the church hearings
on fbi and cia abuses
it was revealed that the black panther
party and other black organizations
the weather underground
and the american indian movement were
number one two and three
on a hit list
for this program
recently we received the first of
seventeen thousand pages of unclassified
documents from the justice department
the fbi
the cia
and the nixon white house
it was revealed in 1972 that richard
nixon himself directed john dean
to contact the justice department as you
recall the attorney general was john
mitchell
the cia and the fbi to launch a special
covert program
against our movement
we know now in reflection that the same
programs targeted
martin and malcolm
targeted fred hampton
and targeted the all african people's
revolutionary party and they tried to
discredit our dear and beloved brother
kwame toure but it has not worked
the victims of those programs was
leonard peltier
who is now in prison for 22 years for
allegedly
shooting two fbi agents
in reading the documents we find that
this was an fbi botched job
that caused the death of joe stunts one
of our young brothers and the two agents
this program also claimed the life of a
young woman anime akwash who was set up
by the fbi for execution
so today the best tribute we can give to
this brother is to continue talking
about the continuing struggle
and so i want to invite you all
we're going to revisit along with dave
dellinger one of the chicago eight
we're going to revisit the democratic
national convention in chicago
in the last week of august
and we are going to raise many different
issues
like the imprisonment of leonard peltier
we're going to raise the issue
and i want to be as brief as possible
in the interest of time
the united states is now looking at
bosnia
and they're talking about serb
atrocities
they're talking about mass graves they
support the world court to try the
bosnian serbs for their crimes against
humanity
but i want to tell you beginning in 1954
when the cia overthrew the democratic
elected government of arbenz in
guatemala
perhaps as many as 300 people have been
murdered and put into mass graves
throughout guatemala a hundred and
twenty thousand indians my friends have
been murdered tortured raped
in the last 15 years and the cia and the
united states government's fingers are
dripping with their blood
let us be talking
about the world court
or other international tribunals to try
the united states
for similar crimes
we are also going to be talking about
lifting the barbaric
embargo on iraq
on cuba
and now we're going to be talking about
the condition facing the palestinian
people today who are starving because of
the treatment by the zionist state of
israel
finally
about five years ago i attended a
pan-african student youth movement
conference right here
on howard university
young brothers like
obi aboughino and others
raised the issue
of howard university
and i heard a young man earlier talking
when i think about howard university i
think of all the african leaders that
came out of this institution like kwame
toure
but when we as indigenous people think
of howard university
and i was on campus i asked several
students who was howard a lot of them
thought he was a great african leader
and when i told him he was general
howard a pathological killer
who brought about the ethnic cleansing
of indigenous people
they were outraged
and so i think it's time
and we should not have to set up our
teepees out here
i think it's time that the
administrators of this university look
out and find a great african leader that
they can name this institution after
there are enough out there
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
finally
finally in conclusion
staple toure
at the end of the colonial period in
guinea
the president of france charles de
gaulle tried to offer them a
commonwealth status to keep their ties
economic social political ties to france
when they asked seiko to ray if they
would
agree to a commonwealth status he said
something like this
i'd rather live
like a pauper and be free
than to live like a king and be enslaved
i think brother the name that you have
carries on in that spirit
and as we watch television recently
the program eyes on the prize while we
have seen many people fall by the
wayside
we still see this brother with his eyes
clearly on the prize and for that we
love you very much kwame toure
[Music]
[Music]
i'm very happy and pleased to present
our next speaker
james turner is chairman of the malcolm
x commemoration
committee and a long-time friend of
kwame toure and a long-time friend of
most of us we've all known him in the
struggle a very long time
please welcome james turner
thank you sister kubay and thank you
brothers and sisters
it is clear that the the hour is late
uh the time is going
people in the back are concerned that we
are going to go overtime and ask who's
going to pay for that
so they've asked us all to be brief
there is so much of course that we'd all
want to say to brother kwame
but i think there are a few things that
are important from my point of view
and my comments are going to be personal
as well as political
we have all asked ourselves why are we
here this evening
it is clear to me that we are here
because we should be here
it is our solemn duty to be here
we are here because we love and respect
kwame toure
we respect and love him because kwame
has been a firm
soldier in the struggle of our people's
liberation
he has not wavered in 35 years and he
has refused to be intimidated he is a
stalwart image for the generations now
and those to come
he is a brother that every young african
in the street ought to know and take as
their role model
we are here because we are supposed to
be here
we have grown up with this brother he is
a part of us he is all that we have
become
like a good song
we can mark important parts of our own
political development by the persistent
sound of kwami's political voice
he has been consistently on point
on the progressive point of our people's
struggle
he has continuously argued before us
that freedom for us is much more than we
understand it to be it requires more of
us than we are willing to hear
he challenges us to understand that the
fundamental character of the oppression
of our people
is deeply embedded in international
capitalism he has been clear
that racial oppression is deeply
involved with the abuse of our people's
labor and the misuse of our people
he raised the question of america as a
settler colony he has been consistently
reminding us that we are the daughters
and the sons of those africans
and that we are now as we have always
been africans
which means that we must by nature
politically be pan-africanist and
revolutionary african nationalist
he has advanced the concept of the
united front
he has argued that we don't have to all
love each other we don't all have to
particularly like each other we don't
all have to be in the same organization
but we must work with each other for our
people
he has argued consistently that it's not
enough to argue what we are against
but we must be clearer about what it is
that we're for we're fighting for
he challenges us to organize to organize
he is of course in the best tradition of
african revolutionary nationalism
from harriet tubman to malcolm x
from fannie lou hamer to steve biko
from david walker to ella baker from
kwame
nkrumah and sakuturay to kwame toure
we are here tonight because it is our
duty to our ancestors and our people to
be here
he has called for us to be here and we
are making it clear that we stand
unequivocally with him
tonight tomorrow day after tomorrow next
month next year and in the hereafter
kwame
has left us with
an enduring legacy
when i was much younger like many of us
i used to remember a comment that he
made which i think is so fitting he gave
us a value by which to live our life he
would say
first our people
and then and only then you and i thank
you very much
[Music]
um
it gives me great pleasure behalf of the
all african people's revolutionary party
to
bring to you
our dear brother kwame
you know for those who know our party we
do not put great emphasis on individuals
because we understand that the masses of
our people are the makers of history
so for the
aprp and his friends and supporters to
organize tributes may seem a little out
of our character
but it's important to note that
an individual
such as kwame and others
only can represent the best
that our people
have to offer the best in our people
and i think that
in this
tribute and they have been held all over
all over this country
that what we have come
to pay tribute to
is the struggle
of our people
to free themselves
from capitalism
imperialism
zionism
racism
and gender oppression
and kwame has been out there
with the masses
fighting
to free our people
so in paying tribute to kwame
we in the all african people's
revolutionary party pay tribute to the
uncompromising and relentless struggle
of the masses of african people
so without any other words
we'll bring out
the man of the night our brother kwame
terry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we thank you thank you
[Music]
okay
son
we thank you very very much
as a young man
working for the student nonviolent
coordinating committee
when i graduated from howard university
i
was paid the 9.64 cents a week when we
got the money
and most of the time we did not get the
money
and of course there we're working with
the very poorest people that we had the
peasants the sharecroppers
but i knew from an early age when we
would go into a house where nobody there
knew us
in some little body shack they just knew
that we were freedom fighters and we get
in there about two o'clock in the
morning the people will get out of their
best beds bring out their best sheets
and their best grandmother quilts and
give it to us
so i've known from the time i was small
but once you're revolutionary and you
struggle for the people you will lack
nothing because the people will give you
everything
everything
so we want to thank you for
demonstrating this for reaffirming us
we have very little time
and we want really to concentrate our
time on how we are to advance the
struggle as a people
of course we know that history is made
only by the masses of the people they
are the only makers of history
if we were to look at the history of
africans just in america we would see
this clearly
it is only when the masses come into the
movement the movement takes on mass
proportions that we advance
of course when we look very carefully at
our people especially at our culture
if you look carefully at us as a people
we act together
but we do not
think together
this is one of our greatest weaknesses
but this acting together takes on great
proportions
i am a revolutionary
and unlike dr martin luther king my
dreams are the dreams of urban
rebellions that's the stuff they're made
of
and i know from scientific work that
were we to plan a rebellion in a given
city let's say washington dc we would
need at least 75 cadres honest sisters
and brothers ready to give their lives
the drop of hat for the people ready to
sacrifice everything
and probably over a period of 18 months
before you can really bring off a
rebellion i know this is my this is my
job
but our people
can raise up a rebellion without the
slightest planning without the slightest
forethought and put the police and the
army at bay at will
when the policemen were freed in
california
over rodney king without thought without
planning without talking in action
everybody rose up and went to a
righteous rebellion against police
terrorism
as we act together
but since we do not think together once
this action spins itself out we sit down
for 20 years
were we to go back to the same watch we
would see in 1965 what said one of the
first rebellions in the 1960s in this
country
and if we were to compare 1965 with 1996
there's only one difference in 1996 the
rebellion was quantitatively greater but
there were no qualitative improvements
at all
we know that in order to have quality
you must have quantity
but we know you get quality by
critically organizing quantity
and this is the error we make as a
people we do not critically organize our
quantity to make qualitative
in
results
1996 they didn't even get a poverty
program
in 1965 at least they were poverty
programs
the need then for us to think together
is crucial
we can even look at ourselves as a
people
when we ask ourselves where we come from
what are origins even though we're one
we get a million answers i'm black i'm
american i'm human i'm african i'm
african-american i'm colored maybe i'm
negro
yeah all of this from the same people
all of this from the same people
unless we have a clear recognition of
our origins and our history it's
impossible for us to understand the
present let alone map out the future
since we're all going in different ways
the african people's revolutionary party
has taken upon its shoulders the task of
organizing the masses of our people
this is a task from which we will not
run
it is not an easy task it is a difficult
task but we are revolutionaries we don't
run to the easy we run to the difficult
any conscious woman knows that if you
run to easy problems you will not grow
it is only when you confront difficult
problems overcome these problems that
your confidence grow preparing you to
overcome any problem
any problem
[Applause]
we've taken on the task of organizing
the masses of our people to organize
them we must think together therefore
for us the question of ideology becomes
supreme
this ideology must come from the culture
of our people must come from it
we have seen what ideology is not coming
from our culture trying to organize our
people have done in this country it's
wrecked havoc on them
some ideologies came to tell our people
that you can fight but before you fight
you must get rid of god that one will
never work
not with these africans
simply because they are so oppressed
that they use everything to liberate
them starting with their religion
and the same religion brought by the
slave master to enslave us is the same
religion the denmark vessel uses to cut
off the heads of the slave masters in
righteous rebellion
[Applause]
[Music]
the same religion that the
segregationists used to try and keep us
segregated was the same religion that
martin luther king used singing freedom
songs marching against dogs and hoses to
break down segregation
we say carefully here that this idiocy
must come from our culture
we know that it is only the masters that
make history and our people make history
of course sometimes we get confused the
history books here and confusing our
conceptions will have us think that we
make history when one african becomes
the first this or that
so in history book you read oh the first
uh president of this association was an
african the first doctor to come to this
hospital was first african doctor the
first african to do this the first
african astronaut the first africa it
makes it as if our history is a history
of individual advancement into the
capitalist system
this is not history
history is made by an oppressed people
only in fighting against their oppressor
this is the only way you make history
only
way therefore if you want the history of
our people in america we give it to you
in one sentence
they have gone from burning plantations
to burning cities if they don't get free
they gonna burn a nation
the american capitalist system is weaker
today than it's ever been before
all we need is the slightest
organization and we can bring this
monster down
we are going to bring down the
capitalist system whether we are
conscious or unconscious
of course we need conscious people but
we tell the capitalist system even if
you stifle the conscience of our
community as africa as our mother
unconsciously these africans will burn a
nation but they are going to be free
absolutely free
[Applause]
the capitalist system is weak we say
america is more ripe for revolution
today than it's ever been it's more
right for revolution today than it's
been in the 1960s
only one example would give this clear
we'll give this make this glare for us
in the 1960s the white ring in the white
right in this country the right wing in
this country supported the government
they want to maintain the status quo
every time we move the government
unleash them against us you will find
workers in the street beating down
students against vietnam you find
right-wing groups talking but today
the right-wing have changed their policy
they have declared that their major
enemy is no longer the minorities nor
the leftists their major enemy is the
united states government
[Music]
of course we know their major enemy is
capitalism they just don't know it yet
it is our job of course it is capitalism
it's our job to help educate them so
they will know it's not the government
it's the system
the american capitalism will elude us
and let us think that the people you see
up front is the one with power what
stupidity clinton has no power
the power's the multinational
corporations that pay his campaign to
whose tune he dances
we have to organize ourselves
we have to organize ourselves so that we
will not be taken the way we're taken so
lightly
most of our people in the democratic
party in this country vote democratic
we have more democratic mayors than any
other ethnic group in this country
inside the democratic party and we have
less power than any other ethnic group
inside the democratic party
they hold us with nothing but contempt
you can see a clear example when we look
at cuba
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
africans in this country love cuba and
love fidel castro
[Applause]
[Music]
be down be down
give the yankees hell
give the yankees help
give the yankees help
you will look in miami and in miami they
have what are known as gusanos
gustanos is the spanish word for the
scum of cuba those who ran away from the
problems in cuba to run to money in
america in order to invade their country
and go back to scum of cuba
they don't vote
yet clinton pays more attention to them
than he pays to africans who vote him
into office
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
we must come as a people to organize
ourselves
i shed my blood for the vote therefore
the vote for me is something
serious i didn't shed my blood for the
vote so that i can join and become a
corrupt mayor or a corrupt this or
corrupt that my people shed their blood
for the vote therefore i misuse the vote
to qualify and to bring dignity and
integrity to the political system in
america to ease the conditions of the
poor everywhere
this is our job
we can only do this when we are
organized
this aspect of organization will not
stop
we have told you it's a fact if you look
at history i have known no great man or
no great woman that didn't belong to an
organization not one
the american capitalist system was so
confused some of us that we will
actually think that we by ourselves can
lead the people to their freedom
there's no such thing as rambo or
superman it exists only in hollywood
fidel castro as bad as he is he needs a
communist party of cuba to help direct
cuba
vi lenin as rough as he is he needed a
bolshevik party
karl marx was a great man had to
organize the international working men's
association
the honourable marcus garvey saw clear
and long but he needed the universal
negro improvement association of the
african community leaves
but jesus lumumba was a great man he
needed organization
harriet tubman was a rough sister she
needed organization
rosa parks sat down so we can get up she
needed organization
malcolm x so loved organization that
when he left the nation of islam he
created two organizations the muslim
mosque incorporated for muslims and the
african-american organization spotted it
after the uh africa the organization of
african unity
everywhere you will see the need for
organization
martin luther king was a righteous man
but even he recognized the need for a
southern christian egypt conference
and while nazi mandalay
mandela is known all over the world he
still has the african national congress
every brother or sister who truly seeks
to advance the world must belong to an
organization
this we will not stop telling you we
appreciate the love that you give us we
certainly do but we want to tell you the
love that you give us is a reflection of
the work we do for you and the only work
we do for you is to organize you
therefore if you truly love us you will
be about the job of organizing the
masses of our people
the scenery is clear
the scenery is absolutely clear look at
the difference between an unorganized
sporadic urban rebellion in los angeles
and one that is organized
could you think about that
i want to think seriously about it
that we don't just jump up we prepare
molokov cocktails we get the highest
buildings we put snipers up there we
decide what streets we're going to burn
ties and block off the police where we
will block the army off how we would get
supplies in how we would get food in
once we organized like this the american
capitalist system will take us seriously
seriously
we must stop our sporadic movement and
transform them to permanent organization
when you struggle against your people
you must not struggle up and down the
police do not struggle against us up and
down they struggle every single day
against us using all the technology they
have to increase their oppression
against us if we are to fight against
the police we must fight every day
this is the message we want to drive
home to you
you know when you have disease like
cancer and they tell you well you are
only so much time to live you have to
decide what your priorities in life are
my priorities are always there i'm going
to serve my people until i die there's
no question here
we come to prioritize our work before we
end we want to tell you a little bit
about the work of the
african united front which brother ed
murphy spoke about entitled the black
united front we want to give you just a
brief history to show you that those who
work for you do not sleep
as brother murphy correctly pointed out
in 1968 we organized in washington dc
the first black united front he was
correct but he made a mistake 92 thirds
of the people united fund go to
government practically all of them it's
not right john bailey
practically all of them therefore the
base bill from the united front was that
base that carried
marion barry into office and carried all
the others with him
even uh
yes of course walter fontroy was a
member of the united front yes he was of
course he was of course it was yes he
was yes it was
since the united front was broken down
the all-african people's revolutionary
party gave me the assignment of creating
an african united front in this country
this is not an easy task it's a very
difficult task
the first enemy we have standing before
us is nothing other than zionism stark
and naked
[Music]
zionism do not want us organized at all
they'll do everything to block us they
will create all sorts of confusion they
even have a new magazine they made here
in washington dc in howard university
called community quest for black and
race black and jewish relationships
which is stupidity we africans were the
ones who gave religion to the world how
could you separate black from jewish
they're one of the same if you
understand religion
[Applause]
yeah the confusion is they want to take
a religion and make a religion a
nationality
they've done everything to stop us but
we've tell them over and over again
you are getting weaker
and the plans you make for mr arafat are
bouncing off on you
they thought certainly when they made
their little peace deal that arafat
would be assassinated by some extreme
palestinian terrorists but it was rabin
who got assassinated
it was ravine who got assassinated and
now they're split right down the middle
over the question so they're the ones
who split the palestinians are coming
together tighter
they're going to defend themselves
stronger once they've gotten a piece of
the land you can be sure they are not
going to give it up just like that
the struggle therefore increases
zionism does everything possible to keep
us divided
in 1972 after much work with the
commission of race
uh the commission of race of the united
church of christ we finally got all of
our people to agree to a meeting mr
louis farrakhan was to come at that time
roy wilkins from the nwac was alive he
would come mr abernathy of the southern
christian leadership conference at that
time vernon jordan was with the urban
league he decided to call mr dorothy
height was there we had everything
prepared and zionism came and destroyed
that meeting this was
1972 we are revolutionaries
secretary tells us if the enemy is not
doing anything against you you are not
doing anything
[Applause]
therefore we expect everything we do
to be in contradiction with the society
they must attack it they knocked it down
but we are revolutionaries we don't get
tired we'll never get tired of doing our
job
we continued
and by 1982 i was able to take minister
louis farrakhan to meet johnny jacobs
who was then head of the urban league in
new york
they met
sent out a letter both of them signed it
asking for the meeting everything was in
place and then mr lewis farrakhan joined
jesse jackson in the campaign for
presidency i am sure everybody knows the
history within a few months they had him
saying god of religion dirty religion
whatever they put in his mouth and then
you know everything was split he and
jesse jesse attacking him johnny j
attacking him once again zionism came to
create confusion
we have been moving very strongly
against zion as to bring unity
they have come to create a literary
agent here their magazine called common
quest out of howard university
we know that like the indigenous people
in this country tells us zionism like
capitalism doesn't lie some of the time
it lies all of the time
all the
time
the only time it tells the truth is when
it tells a double lie
that's one time you hit it
we are going to organize the african
united front
as soon as i go to the hospital my first
task was to come to visit mayor marion
barry
i came to see marion barry i said my
brother you're in a position which you
must serve the people now
we need this african united front after
hosting the million and more march
you're in a position where you can
really be of service to people by
calling this meeting together
brother mary and barry of course uh had
to uh leave for two weeks and i myself
had to go to cuba for which we were ever
grateful to the cuban people for the
great health they took care of us
especially brother jose ponce who we tie
it out with so many facts and do this
and do that but the brother responded
all the time don't worry everything is
cool we got you covered in cuba just
going down there so we want to thank you
thank you
[Applause]
marion barry just saw me this evening
and told me well he's very sorry he has
a lot of problems he won't be able to do
it that's all right send me a letter
we're not going to stop we're going to
get an african united front in this
country
[Music]
the task is trying to isolate minister
louis farrakhan
and the zionists want to isolate him
because of one thing
he doesn't bow down before them
[Applause]
as long as you bow down before them they
won't bother you at all
but once you keep your how your head
unbent standing up dignified in the
interest of your people they must strike
you down
they cannot isolate
farah khan from this community they know
absolutely nothing about this community
get jesse jackson with all the press let
him have a meeting he'll never fill any
stadium
get farakan without the press he'll fill
every stadium
these are just facts of life
farrakhan has an influence upon the mass
of the people because he defends the
interest of the people and is not afraid
of striking out at the enemy starting
with zionism
[Music]
all we want of an african united front
is that all the organizations working
for our people be able to sit down meet
and discuss a common program to help us
mutually respect each other and work our
programs for the common good of our
people who can be against this except
our enemies
who can be against this except our
enemies
the right white
on the right wing we said is moving to
revolution
and the chances for revolutionist
country are better than they were in the
1960s in 1960s the right white was glued
to the government they didn't move but
today they're demanding changes
the changes they're demanding is not the
same changes that we're demanding but if
the right wing is demanding changes and
the left wing is demanding changes the
possibility of changes become easier
that's it this time we are treading a
very serious path in our history
we must come to organize quickly
we must encourage the white right to
keep their bullets going against the
government against the multinational
corporations
we must keep telling them over and over
again the british say to the victors
belong the spoil if you beat us we ain't
got nothing you ain't gonna get nothing
aim your guns and those who have power
when you whoop them you're gonna get
some power
we must direct them to the capitalist
agents in this country
we must direct them to the multinational
corporations in this country we must
show them precisely who their enemy is
my sister said to me you're talking so
much about these white people and you
know they hate us i said well that's
true some of us had to hate them before
we got to capitalism
of course
of course so they're hating us is only
natural our job is to show them we are
not your enemy
and we have no power over you at all we
are at the bottom if you want to fight
and win something let's together direct
our guns against the capless pigs in
this country and bring the system down
this work can only be done when the
african masses are independently
organized
because we are the most revolutionary
instinctive group in this country
we burn this country at the drop of a
hat no other group does that
we shoot at the police when we want no
other group does that
we can bring the army in to try and
quiet us down no other ethnic group in
the country does that we do it
we must know precisely who we are what
we are and what our struggle represents
we stay with the most revolutionary
instinctive people in this country if
you will look at all the fights for
justice country you will see us always
on the front lines
begin the very first struggle here in
this country when they had taxation
without representation the first person
to get shot was an african christmas
addicts
always on the front lines fighting for
justice if you will look at the movement
the labor movements this country we're
on the front lines as a matter of fact
when you talk about labor revolt labor
strikes the first strike in this country
was a slave revolt that is a labor
strike
it is a labor strike
if you look at the peace movement when
snake came out of the beginning talked
about moving into resistance as uh
comrade and braden so precisely pointed
out that we're not going to just go
we're not going to go we're going to
break the track we're going to destroy
the draft if they don't have no draft
they can fight the vietnamese and the
vietnamese movement anyway destroy the
draft and the vietnamese gonna walk over
them just like they did
just like they do
this need to organize the people is
crucial
we say the africans must independently
organize themselves
every time africans in this country have
gone into a progressive group with
whites it never fails when the whites
change the program the africans are at
their mercy
we point out just the populist movement
the populist movement was a movement
that sprang up in this country after the
civil war
a white man by the name of tom watson
came and spoke beautiful words to us he
said we are both fleeced by this rich
white man so us ex-slaves and us poor
whites we must get together and run them
out and we certainly did we followed tom
watson
and if you would look at the period
which they call reconstruction which uh
brother was giving some history on you
will see clearly that at that time some
of the most radical solutions the most
radical programs were passed in this
country
it was robert smalls an african from
south carolina who passed free education
for everybody in this country
if you will look they were some of the
best ones but once the white south had
made its bargain with the white north
and this has children compromise came in
1787 tom watson who had come and spoken
to us about getting together became
leader of the ku klux klan and by
lynching drove us out of the party this
time we must be all good
nice
organized
[Applause]
it is to the benefit of the
revolutionary forces in this country to
have the african masses organized along
revolutionary lines because we will not
go back once we're properly organized we
just go back because we're spontaneous
and sporadic but we've shown the will
the determination to fight in the last
30 years this country's seen free over
300 urban rebellions all of them created
by us this determination is serious it
must be organized africans we must say
good night
we wish you to understand seriously your
responsibility to your people
i know the reason my people love me is
because i take seriously responsibility
to them
i will always do that
i will never compromise my people's
struggle and there's no way they can buy
me off that's clear i'm too old now
anyway
they missed me when i was young they
certainly not gonna get me now that i'm
old
ain't nothing they can give me now they
couldn't give me nothing when i was
young only thing i want is to see my
people organized
the only thing i want is to see every
african in this country when you ask
them what organization you belong to
without the slightest hesitation they
will say to you i'm a member of the
national association for the advancement
of colored people i'm a member of the
urban league i'm a member of the
southern christian leadership conference
i'm a member of the re republic of new
africa i'm a member of the nation of
islam i'm a member of the all african
people's revolutionary party when every
one of us can claim allegiance to an
organization fighting for our people i
promise you as africa is our mother not
only will we bring this system down but
we will create for the world a system
that will astonish them we must organize
thank you ready for evolution
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we ask you not to leave
we ask you not to leave
we have three more expressions
of tribute to kwame tere that we want to
do
in the next few minutes
number one we would like for the
political organizations
to come and pay their honor and their
respect
and hopefully i beg them to forego any
speeches just to simply say who they are
pay their respect because the revolution
continues there will be more programs
like this we will then have the android
culture dancers and drummers do an
expression of tribute and honor to kwame
terrain we will then have our sister
nailing foxworth read a special poem
which he has written for kwame tere and
then power praise will rock us on home
to africa rock is our home to mecca
rockazo home to heaven rock us on out of
here please stay and we ask why mr ray
to stay here with us to help discipline
us because we were a half hour late all
right we were a half hour late and we're
now running a half hour late so please
give us about five or ten more minutes
please can the organizations come and
state their names and their small piece
of tribute and then we can move on with
our brothers and sisters to dance before
we
before we have organizations pay tribute
we need to pay a very special tribute to
kwame toure
i'm hoping that everybody will sit down
right where you are
and we want the folk who have the
buckets who are going to collect the
money to get ready to move
i represent the inter-religious
foundation
emphasize foundation for community
organization it's a 30 year old
community organization foundation that
has distinguished itself by being
faithful to the struggle of our people
we have been faithful in that task as
kwame has stated himself to be faithful
to the revolutionary aspirations of our
people
we're honored to have been asked to be
the fiscal agent for the medical fund
that will provide for the medical
resources necessary to keep this brother
in good health
and
in order to have
the free voice and the powerful voice
for freedom and for revolution and for a
critical analysis of the time we're in
and the system that we're under we have
to keep them healthy i think the church
ought to say amen
and in order to do that
we need
money
and therefore unashamedly we're asking
everybody who clapped
to stick your hands in your pockets or
your pocket books
even as the sister said earlier if you
did once do it again
because we want to give generously
to keep this voice free and to keep this
brother healthy
and that's what
this tribute is about tonight
to provide for the medical fund that
will undergird and support
this wonderful revolutionary spirit that
we need among us
he's not asking
the government for anything
he's not asking the system for anything
and he didn't come begging us for
anything
but i believe that we
out of our own sense of revolutionary
responsibility
out of our own sense of appreciation for
what he has done is doing and will do
we have to dig a little deeper and take
care of our own and not expect the
government to take care of him
if the government takes care of him
if the zionists take care of him
they own him
he's not about to be owned by anybody
but he is obligated to us and therefore
we ought to be obligated to him and so
i'm asking you to give more than you
thought you were going to give when you
came in here tonight
make your checks if you want to make
checks that are tax-exempt
to ifco that's the acronym for the
inter-religious foundation for community
organization
and make it ifco
kwame toure medical fund
i think all of you have another flyer
that has the ifco address on it
so you don't have to give everything
you're going to give tonight give
everything you got tonight and then next
week when your ship comes in send
another check to the address that's on
this flyer
it's the inter-religious foundation 402
west 145th street in new york city
and you ought to know why we were asked
to be the fiscal agent
to be the tax-exempt entity to receive
and to
nurture and to protect and to make sure
that the gifts that you sent are handled
with integrity it's because we've done
this for the movement
for 30 years
it is because this is the organization
the inter-religious foundation that
incorporated the national black
united fund not the front but the
national black united fund that operates
in 23 cities our people giving for our
needs it is because this organization is
the organization that organized the
national
anti-clan network that was conceived by
ann braden and others
and we put the energy behind it and it
is now called the center for democratic
renewal
and that is the organization that along
with the center for constitutional
rights is in the forefront of dealing
with the battle against those who are
burning black churches throughout the
south
this is the organization that has stood
with organizations like
center for constitutional rights like
the center for democratic renewal like
the national black united fund we have
proven that we handle your resources
well
and we will handle these resources well
and make sure that they serve the
purpose for which you give them there
need be no question among us about how
our resources are being used these
resources will be used to do the job
that you have instructed us to do
through the friends of kwame toure and
so we ask that the
ushers will move now
and we hope everybody will give not only
those who are seated
out in the audience but i want you to
come up on the stage because those of us
who have spoken and who are about to
speak we ought to lead the way in giving
i know that my that my good brother who
is the executive director of ron daniels
of the center for constitutional rights
is going to join me in giving a hundred
dollars right brother where is it
he said he's down with that so that's
two hundred dollars to start with and i
hope the rest of you will give at least
that much from the looks of this
audience there's some of you who can
give four or five times that much
vernon bella court looks like he could
give about five hundred
one hundred dollars from vernon bella
court
all right
and braden came all the way from
kentucky to give at least a hundred
dollars didn't you ann
she said yes
and i know arthur canoy
didn't come from montclair new jersey
tonight to give anything less than 200
100 for him and 100 for barbara right
he said yes
all right
uh where are the ushers are the ushers
moving we want to make sure that
everybody has an opportunity to give
[Music]
all power to the people
i can't hear you all power to the people
kwame we love you
we love you because
and only because you love revolution
that's why i love you because you love
revolution i wouldn't love you for no
other reason now brother but i love
revolution too
i know that you over in cuba and you
spent some time with the soul of the
black liberation army
sister assad of shakur
come on let's see it for asylum
and i would like to extend to my
brother's greetings
from the black liberation army brother
matulushika brother sekou odinga and all
of the other brothers who are now
serving life plus 80 plus life plus life
because they chose to do the same thing
that brother kwame toray has done
brothers and sisters revolution
continues if you're not a part of the
process you're part of the problem let's
be very very clear again my love to you
my brother my love to the revolution and
may the struggle continue all power to
the people
i
i don't know if everybody knows who this
is and uh this is our reverend lucius
walker
[Applause]
reverend lucius walker just was fasting
for some 70 odd days 79.95
94 days
and the reason he's been fasting and
he's going to show you now the american
government and the capitalist system is
getting weak they have made so much
propaganda against cuba and it being
godless and atheist and killing
christians and closing down their
christian churches and nobody can pray
etc etc but
reverend lucius walker represents church
people and these church people have
gathered over 400 computers to send to
cuba in their hospitals to take care of
the cuban people who are sick
this is a
this is a great ideological defeat for
american imperialism because of all the
talk they talk because these are church
people and do you know the american
government refuses to let those
computers go because they will help
somebody you know their principal if
they're against somebody the whole
country they hate gaddafi they're going
to bomb the country they want noriega
they're going to bomb the country they
want to get rid of kiro castro they're
going to make the people suffer but uh
revolutionist walker must be appreciated
it must be loved and we must thank him
because he's doing a great job working
on forefront to be a good christian
to take care of his neighbors and the
needs of his neighbors and we want to
thank him and let him know that uh we
support him 100
and just one last thing to show you how
the american capitalism can't win you
know one of the reasons i went to cuba
was because i know they have great
herbal doctors and the reason they do
that is ironically because of the
embargo since they embargo they have to
go deeper into solving their own medical
problems themselves so when the
computers were stopped people in france
people in the netherlands people in
germany heard that america were blocking
some 400 computers and they got together
and sent to cuba more than 400 computers
[Applause]
i want to make a connection between
what brother kwame just mentioned to you
and what he said previously and his
comments to us
he said that
revolution comes from the people it's
the power of the people
we fasted there are five of us another
sister who's here and four others
stand up lisa
we god bless you
we fasted for 94 days
but what really brought this government
to his knees was not just our fasting
fasting but you
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people around this country
that rose up that spoke that marched
that went to jail
sent letters faxes called the treasury
department and the white house
someone in the white house said that at
one point you were calling the white
house at the rate of a call every four
minutes
you are the ones that really put the
pressure on them and enabled us in this
climate of hostility against cuba
to achieve what many people thought
could not be achieved
first of all
some of the computers are now in mexico
awaiting delivery to cuba
secondly
the bulk
of the computers have been released to
the custody of the united methodist
church and are in san diego in the
control of the united methodist church
out of the hands of the u.s government
thirdly
we have clear indication that there are
a few other computers that are on the
canadian border where they were seized
they too are going to be released within
a few days and then we will gather all
of these computers and go to cuba
representing you hundreds of thousands
of people from this country and
delivering over 400 computers to the
wonderful medical care system of cuba
that has already demonstrated its
revolutionary commitment to the health
and the well-being of people throughout
the two-thirds world let's give a round
of appreciation for the cuban people who
deserve our support
[Applause]
i can stand there
[Music]
free the land
on behalf of the republic of new africa
d.c unit
and the national alliance of involved
educators i pay tribute to our great
revolutionary leader kwame turay
i had a speech prepared but you can see
the long list of people so i'm going to
say
that
a lot of great people have said that
those who the gods would make powerful
must first organize we've heard the
speech about organization we don't need
to say any more about that
i do have to say however that in 1966
and 67
when i was
first appointed as an administrator in
the fairfax county schools right after
integration
county supervisor of business education
and was subsequently told at annandale
high school by the principal that no
negro is going to supervise his teachers
and subsequently put in jail it was my
nights that i could come from fairfax
county over here to washington and sit
in this very auditorium and sometimes
hear speeches that would keep me
encouraged speeches by kwame panel
discussions right here on this same
stage
and of course years later
my son in the 80s at whitney young high
school the magnet high school in chicago
after having graduated from
the edward wilmot blyton center for
creative development at northeastern
university he went over to whitney young
and he wrote a paper
for africa for american history
on
stokely carmichael kwame toure his pro
his teacher told him that that was
unacceptable because he certainly had to
write about a person who was significant
in american history we held our grounds
because of the background of the
independent schools that he so heartily
supports tarik is now in saudi arabia
and medina finishing his fourth year at
the university he simply was inspired by
all that he read about
the great kwame terrain
your flame is inextinguishable we love
you and it is in the power of love that
we embrace you and we know that love is
healing
and we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keep coming for us forever we love you
[Applause]
we all love climbing
i've written a poem for climbing it's
called in spite of them
performing kwame toure
in spite of them
we have survived
and we remain the same
in spite of them with their covert and
overt hunting game we have come in spite
of them we are determined everlasting
noble ones yes we are revolutionary
serious pan-africanist thank you kwame
thank you kwame thank you for the black
power thank you for the black power for
the woman power and the manpower and the
precious african land power thank you
kwame
my name is adria ayatoro and i'm the
director of the national conference of
black lawyers she's a bad lawyer
[Music]
and on behalf of the national conference
of black lawyers i it gives me great
pleasure to be here to give tribute to
you you're so inspirational to us all
and it is in your spirit that we
continue to fight
my name is ron daniels i represent the
campaign for him no no before he speaks
he got to get us an independent
political party don't let him off the
hook
well i represent the campaign for a new
department new tomorrow which is a black
and people of color-led multi-racial
independent political organizations
seeking to become an independent
political party so we're on that chance
and we simply want to salute brother
chromatry ray uh using the words of
amico cabral for returning to the source
and working for the masters of african
people we love you
[Applause]
dear brother kwame we have had your back
for 33 years as organizers and as sister
friends we brought some young adults
here tonight so that you could ignite
the fire of pan-african revolution in
their hearts as well they never heard
you before we're so happy you're here
with us and we love you and respect you
always
my name is conrad world i'm the chairman
of the national black united front and
whether you believe it or not kwame i'm
ready for the revolution
[Applause]
[Music]
bismillah
on behalf of the committee to free
sheikh umar abdul rahman and the muslims
of the united states we want to wish
life and health and wellness to our
brother who is fighting against the
zionists and the imperialists and let
him carry on and let us carry on in his
footsteps after he is gone and while he
is with us and let us not forget that we
must stand as one against our common
enemy the
allahu akbar
[Applause]
brother stokie i like to honor you
brother call michael
that's the brother i know you asked me
when i was teaching brothers in the
street i teach them about the brothers
from snick and let them know that you
can make a major role and be very
important out here us the brothers from
the streets
we know we can make a difference and we
making you an honorary member of
cease-fire don't smoke the brothers
[Music]
and we want all you all to know out here
all our elders if all you like be like
the brothers stokey car michael lewis
fur car marcus garvey then the youth
will wake up until you start teaching
the youth the truth they gonna be asleep
we need brothers like this everybody to
stand up and stop faking on the youth
and then we can make a difference
[Music]
[Applause]
we wish that you go in peace
this concludes our program
the revolution intensifies
[Applause]
the revolution intensifies we thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
friday senators debated federal reserve
board nominations
a vote is scheduled for next thursday
june 20th
senate lawmakers next meet on tuesday at
10 am eastern time and begin
consideration of fiscal year 97 defense
spending and bob carey and various house
members discuss their ideas for social
security reform
and later at a quarter to six
former president gerald ford gives a
tour of his museum in grand rapids
michigan
first a tribute to black activist kwame
tire
wednesday he was honored by nation of
islam leader louis farrakhan washington
d.c mayor marion berry delegate eleanor
holmes norton actor wesley snipes and
others
mr tierray was responsible for
registering many black voters in the
south during the 1960s when he was still
known as stokely carmichael
he was also an organizer with the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee before he moved to guinea and
changed his name
this two-hour event took place at the
marriott wardman park hotel in
washington d.c
thank you you know one of the things
that we've been accused of is not
writing enough about our experiences
and
there may be some of you in the audience
that's that's not aware
that
kwame is writing a book
[Applause]
and one of the nice things about it is
that he's writing it with a friend um i
could farewell
thank you brother winky
and i'd like to congratulate the
organizers of this event and
particularly the heroic karen spellman
for bringing this along
if this were
excuse me call me a truly african event
i would have i would be obligated to
call the praise names and strong names
of every member of the high table
individually
and all the high titles of rank
which would then use more time than has
been allotted to me
by sister judy
but what i will do
is greet
all my friends and brothers the heroes
of snake
even after so many years you are still
heroes to me
[Applause]
my assignment which i probably won't do
was to read a section
from kwame's book
but the fact of the matter is
that with the time we have
that might not be possible
but i do want to lit to rest one
misconception
especially since i've been here this
evening a lot of people seem to have the
impression that i'm ghost writing for
this book
or that i'm helping palmer write this
book
that's not true my role is much more
modest than that
in tradition
in traditional african culture
there's a metaphor for the impossible
and they say when i want to say a thing
is not possible the man
or the woman who would do such and such
a thing is not yet born
and his mother is dead
i don't want to
kill my mother
but i will say that the man or woman who
will put words into call me to his mouth
our ideas into kuala mutua's head is not
yet born
my role is very very modest
i'm like the arranger
kwame is a composer it is his life
he gives the information to me and i
merely put it at the right places sort
of like the arranger in a composition
that's written by somebody else
i'm simply giving it structure it's an
editorial function the book is qualm is
the life is form is the story is
extraordinary
and
on the good advice of my publisher
who is here tonight ms maldo she says
don't read from the bookmark let them go
to the bookstore and hear their minds
like everybody else
no she didn't say that
but there is something else i wish to
read to you
and it's a letter
that i was asked to bring to kwame toure
it says kwame toure all african people's
revolutionary party
my dear brother
my wife christy and i
wish you to know
that we would have been happy and
honored to be present among your friends
and admirers in washington this evening
that was not physically possible
but you can believe that our admiration
our respect and our love are with you
i am not in the habit of presuming to
speak for all people
and indeed i am often quite suspicious
of most of those who claim to
but on this occasion
i'm confident that i speak for
multitudes of progressive african
patriots
when i say that your courage
your insight
and your devotion
have adorned the struggle in our time
and continue to inspire us
may the ancestors continue to protect
and strengthen you
in this your latest battle
warmest fraternity good wishes
your brother
and there's a evil term
which translates roughly keep on keeping
on
i'll more precisely keep on doing
exactly as you have done
jide
chinua achebe
and
that was accompanied
by a contribution which i give to winky
right now
i also
have to recognize
the presence among us of miss graham and
miss marlowe scribner's magazine
which is a company that will be
published in kwame's autobiography
and show every sign of taking the book
very seriously
they have their present at this very
event
and i think intend to see do everything
they can to see that it's a major
american document
and with them
at table number three
is miss francis golden
who was kwame's agent in the negotiation
of this book contract but who is also
the agent of mumia
abu jamal
and brings this meat
and miss golden who was last week with
mumia
says he is in high spirits
his courage and his fight and spirit is
not impaired and he sends his warmest
brotherly and revolutionary greetings to
this meeting
[Applause]
and having consulted my elders and
betters
you will have to um
go to the bookstore if you want to read
them from connie's book
the one thing i will say
the one thing i will say prior to
leaving
is that to ask anybody from snake
particularly anybody close to kwame
to be confronted with an open microphone
at captive origins
and to speak for four minutes
is a provocation and an invitation to
bogar the bank
but they know
that mike thurwell is disciplined
and would not do that
and so i was sent here to set a good
example which i have done
thank you brother felwell he is as
always eloquent and as very unusual
brief so we appreciate this thank you
ladies and gentlemen you'll notice in
your uh
program that
dorothy height is listed unfortunately
she had an emergency today and will not
be with us
now we enter into what is what we refer
to as a period section
um most of us
know
that have spent any time with kwame know
how much he feels and how much he's
talked about nag
and
both cleve sellers and karen house are
going to come and give some remarks
about the neg period and after cleve and
karen gassed the kneel
good evening good evening good evening
good evening good evening
cleve asked me to go first i know why
um because as as i started reflecting
about our time at howard i realized i
came before cleve i came before mike
feldwell i came before kwame
so i came to howard before there was an
egg before there was a snake
however it was an interesting time
because we began our student movement
days the summer of 1960 at glenn echo
amusement park
and those students
formed the nucleus of what became nag
the non-violent action group and the
rest is history
well
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she has taken her a lot of time and now
turn it over to me
exactly i came to howard university from
a small
town in south carolina
anticipating and looking to see all of
the civil rights
activists
at howard university
and i came to howard university with all
the expectation
and when i got there
i was able to find
a few sturdy committed
individuals
and one of them was a lanky
young arrogant
intellectual
from new york
by the name of stokley carmichael
and you know coming from
down south and coming up north there was
a certain amount of cultural shock
in any event
i wanted to be a part of the movement
and i learned that stokely had been a
arrested in mississippi and sent the
parchment penitentiary
and i thought that maybe he would be the
person that i would
come to know
and over a period of time the friendship
in the bond grew
and i was able to
learn about a very caring and very
compassionate
and a very deeply committed
young man
with an affectionate personality
a young man who would go on to become an
icon
certainly for human rights
black empowerment
pan-africanism and socialism
and so when i look at
this event tonight
we need and we are celebrating
the life
the
legacy of kwame toure
i remember the times when we went to
mississippi
the summer of 1964
and when we got to oxford ohio
we found out that our three comrades
were missing
in philadelphia mississippi
and there was a group of his eight
others
that were asked if we were interested in
going to
philadelphia mississippi and seeing if
we could find our comrades
and i remember
charlie cobb
and i remember
stokely carmichael
and i remember
five others of us who travel to
philadelphia mississippi
during the day we stayed on a barn
and at night
we would go out into the
night and we'd search ravines and
old houses and
wells and
all kinds of places where
either the bodies of our comrades might
have been
stashed or where hostages might have
been held
and we did that and during that time we
had an opportunity to talk
and we talked about a lot of things but
we never talked about fear
we never talked about
the kinds of sacrifices that we were
making
and i remember stokely very well
during this time
talking about a deeper commitment that
we all had to make to the struggle
stokely has made
that commitment
and one of the things that we have a
responsibility to do
is to go forward and teach our young
people about the legacies of those
individuals who have given sacrifice
now there's one other thing i'd like to
get straight since i'm sitting on the
diocese and that is is that i was a
field secretary i was not one of the
leaders and field secretaries mostly
were in obscurity okay but we worked
hard
and i do want to thank the committee
that pull this together it's so
important
for us to have these kinds of tributes
tributes and to give
those of us who have made the great
sacrifices
our roses
before we have gone over to the other
side
in closing
i would like to have
a young lady
who was named
by uh
stokely carmichael nosis way
and she is my daughter
and she is presented
she is presenting
roses to kwame toure for all of us
okay ladies and gentlemen um
i think judy has kind of said it in
terms of the
the cultural importance of our community
and there's one such individual that
stands out particularly in the north
particularly here in washington dc
and that's gaston neil gaston
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you see
[Applause]
here
[Applause]
this is one of those nights if you're
not here you're not here to breathe it's
not here to feel
that's so important
because the margins are not down here
the struggle is not
and we will be here
and years
is
yes
[Music]
history
because we not only fight the struggles
as
workers cultural workers as political
workers congressmen
as mayors
but we fight this battle as human beings
my job as a public touch
on the human being
personal job
the seed of my day begins as the
torturous night ends
and the common birds great shrill
interrupts the flocking of a morning pea
and it is eyes of a dog the soft eyes
locked in too long in some cramped yard
with the touch of his ass
cutting violently the soft of somebody's
wand
and i regard this day as every losing
wood and i need a god
and as the morning seed grows
the blue of the sky mingles with the
twisted black features of winning trees
and sounds loses its clutches on a
beginning day
and i sit here where the pain and
urgency that i must attain discipline
that i must attain discipline
for brotherhood and unity
softly say it down brothers
softly say it now down in the soul
discipline
satan brothers
saints or the brothers
sing
[Applause]
refusing to let death know the rhythm
refusing to let death know the time
refusing to let death know
the melody
refusing to let death know
the rhythm the melody the africa of the
nation
the soul the march to tomtom the juju
refusing to let death know
the rhythm the time the melody
[Music]
refusing
to let a death known
[Applause]
this was to a system that was known to
all of us that worked in the movement
and not only does this woman
you know capitalize
and
give us all the beauty and all the rage
and all the wonderment to whether we are
and what our business journey has
brought us and has
taking us
and she stood by your side
insisted once
this journey
[Music]
from out of the water
walking a thousand hysterical nights
if you look closely it's in the eyes
the water the pain the search
like touching the eyelids of a hundred
dead slaves
knowing the wood the brownwood of a
mississippi shack southern skies and
dirt that pushed this journey
in an african way the scars is whipped
this rhythm that keeps [ __ ] with us
this rhythm fighting a thousand pharaohs
we reach out to each other touching
underneath guts
from out of the water we have fought the
cold death
blowing the tears and millions of bodies
trapped in seed forgotten in the
atlantic
this rhythm that fighting with us
driving the seasons of our earth
it is always in your eyes florence the
sun the rain tie itself
like holding my destiny within one of
your tears
it is a song emotion a movement i hid in
the blues coming out of your mouth
that way deep in memphis
began a journey
rhythm like
colored light
red
[Applause]
[Music]
we fight for the war we fought about the
war we marched about the war
we died
billy mcdonald
was one of those faces those those
vietnamese lives we were talking about
young american lives
who had died
for a dream that was not driven by us
billy mcdonald was one of those
[Music]
down
down
brother mcdonald brushed his teeth at
every meeting
but the mcdonald's studied his homework
made great grades ran track playing
football
when he done studied his homework made
good grades ran track playing football
playing baseball was popular with
everybody billy mcdonald even made love
in the back of a car
billy mcdonald
was
the best
billy mcdonald became a captain in the
army
one day billy mcdonald was shot down
trying to blow up yellow men in their
families
and now billy mcdonald's name is on the
wall people come and get traces on brown
paper
i went to that wall
and cried for philly mcdonald
cried for all that goodness cried for
his pretty mother
cried for the way good souls can be
taken and made mindless
cried because tears can touch and hug
and on that cold afternoon
my tears touched
and hugged
to let it die
[Applause]
and she didn't exemplify what it was to
be in the movement
she reached past the clouds over the
dark night she reached up to the sky's
stars and caught the rare heart light of
the north star
she opened the earth walking with
blood-soaked feet she challenged the
fire pulled from the bodies of slaves
made into laws courts and prisons
screaming white heart flames of agony
she challenged millions of head on this
dragon and ripping apart impossible to
the moments of time
shipping vessels of history destroying
the fabric the godlike cloth of our
destiny
with a gun a knife and a cannon
building the hideous wall of blood
called slavery
she challenged it with burning eyes and
black skin
with torn the skin red skin degraded
skin smashed in
[Music]
one man set free is worth a thousand
speeches
one man set free is worth a thousand
speeches a thousand speeches one man set
free is worth a thousand speeches
set free
set
free the north star the north star the
north star the north side
she saw the dog she saw the death she
saw the new day
she saw the red hot light at the north
star
she heard the song she sang the song she
was the song
go down go down go down moses
go down go down go down
go down let my
let my left mind let me go down go
let my people go
break down the walls of blood
break down the walls of blood and terror
pharaoh break down the laws of blood
terror pharaoh
let my people go
past the chains past the field of blood
pass the houses of mangled souls
past the broken back children
past the history of twisted cathedrals
praying to insidious gods for more lives
more darkness more arms and body parts
to run the foul smelling [ __ ] of laws
constitution and rights
to the north side
to the north star
to pick up the gun to fire the cannon to
march the human march for freedom
to the north star
to the north star for all that is good
to the north star for all that is
is
yes neil
thank you gaston
uh this evening i wanted uh karen
spellman to share with us
a number of things that are taking place
and she's so busy trying to keep this
thing going i i'm going to make an
attempt and it's going to be a very
brief attempt
i understand there are at least five
camera crews here
that's recording this event
c-span is doing it i believe live
i understand that wesley snipes is here
also um recording this event
um
there is a video cast that is that is
taking place kwame also has a a website
um so it's it's possible that this is
being seen throughout the world at this
particular point in time
now we would like to introduce the
former chairmans
of snake and what what i'd like to do is
to have them
come in this order
marion barry
charles mcdew john lewis jameel
and phil hutchins
[Applause]
good evening again my brothers and
sisters
assalamu alaikum
first of all let me thank god
for allowing me to live to see
this evening
and give me the privilege of being a
part of this program
many of our freedom fighters have gone
on made their transition
but their spirits
are alive and in this room let's give
them a round of applause all their slain
freedom fighters
have made their transition
i want to thank them
the fan of new hamers and the hermit and
valla lusso and others who
made the transition
and also
i brought my son who's 17 years of age i
wanted him to see some real live freedom
fighters
because what has happened we've not done
enough to let our young know
the struggles
that we have gone through
many of them think that
they came into this world it was like
that forever and for the many of them uh
the freedom fight was a storybook story
something you read in history but i want
christopher to know that this is real
live history and that there were some
freedom fighters who fought long before
he was even thought about who made a
difference in this world
i'm not going to be very very long some
38 years ago
four young men
in greensboro north carolina
sat down so we could stand up
that started
the modern civil rights city and
movement
i was a graduate student at fiscal
university
going about my business trying to get my
chemistry work done
and the movement came to nashville
tennessee
there was diane nash
and james bevel
bernard lafayette
and others who
moved the movement
in nashville
on april 15 1960 dr king
sent out a movement
memo to come to raleigh north carolina
shaw university
and students from all over the southland
from louisiana georgia and alabama and
south carolina and north carolina and
tennessee and
and florida
all this up mississippi
somehow another mississippi was was was
so close that we didn't have anybody
there that april 15th that i can recall
from mississippi
we all debated with each other as to
what should be the direction of the
movement
and the mother of the movement ella
baker
said you young people ought to stand
on your own
dr king had wanted us to become part of
sclc the youth movement we said no we're
going to stand on our own
because we have a direction that we have
to go
you see that april 15th weekend over
easter it's really kind of interesting
looking back on it because for
for me who's a christian baptist
that friday was a crucifixion
and the sunday was a resurrection
that weekend was resurrected the student
non-violent coordinating committee
and we came together and i was elected
the first chair
we went about our business sitting in
all over the southland
and moving and moving and moving and
doing things there were several things i
remember about that movement
that was very
uh
rememberable to me
early on in the movement we had a big
debate and and brother uh kwame
remembers this debate as to whether or
not we should go to direct action route
or go voter registration route
uh many of us thought that the
candidates trying to buy the movement
out because they put some money into the
voter rate i'm just telling the truth
now and that they they put some money
into the movement and we were afraid
they were trying to buy us out
trying to keep us brother george from
continuing our direct action movement
and so we formed two separate grouping
but yet together i think diane nash and
bevel and myself on the direct action
side of that equation
and others who are on the voter
registration public equation looking
back on it both were important
because you could use direct action to
stimulate people to register to vote
registered voters stimulated direct
action and so that was the beginning of
that great movement the other defining
moment i think in the movement and i
think i know where brother kwame was on
this issue
there was a whole big debate at snick
about whether or not we should seek keep
guns and freedom housing because these
white folks have been shooting their
freedom houses bombing freedom houses
and shooting their people in freedom
houses and so we came together to debate
that question because we had nonviolent
in our name and so some of us felt that
you ought to be consistent and others
say well look if you're being shot at
you better shoot back and brother kwame
i know which side he was on he was going
to shoot back probably he said you know
what people we're going to shoot back
you know we're going to shoot back
and that was something interesting about
that those people who were in the field
well that view some of the people who
were in the cities who didn't same kind
of people shooting at them could say
that uh in terms of non-violence so
those were the kind of things that that
went on but we were committed and
finally
i recall and think of the national
tendency and brother comey was an
organizer
way back when
and uh this is no offense to anybody who
was a part of our leadership but uh
brother cromwell sort of waited till we
all got real sleepy
and i think about three or four o'clock
in the morning had an election
for a new chair
he knew how to do it back in those days
outweigh them
we woke up late morning and we got a new
chair stick
that time stoked rick carmichael
and uh
that just showed that he was born a
revolutionary
he grew up on revolutionary ideas
and he practiced revolutionary tactics
of knowing how to out organize some
other kind of people
oh good listen to us if you want to win
you can't this is not a this is not a
situation for sprinter this is a long
distance runner kind of movement and
brother kwame was one of those people
and finally i got to i knew how black
power happened because we really rich
where's willie rick he's running
somewhere
besides where is he
anyway
you know willie and and brother comey
coming had worked this thing out where
uh brother o'connor said black power and
victory by power pretty soon that power
like power that's how the black power
scene came about everybody said back
what do you want that power brother
kwame we love you
respect me
i was
in on those debates
and when we uh
talked about whether or not we'd have
voting or direct action
we decided we had a small two-room
office
on sweet auburn
we decided we'd have on one door
the direct action people most of whom
were from nashville
and were devoted totally
to the ideas of non-violence and felt
the being involved in politics corrupts
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the nashville people and direct action
people my good brother
i'm going to speak on
it was among them
uh we said we'd have we said well
perhaps we should have two doors
on one door we'll have the direct action
non-violent people will have a
dove with a
olive branch in his beast
and would say
student
non-violent
and on the other door we'd have a male
fist with lightning and swords
saying coordinating committee
but the wonderful thing and we and snick
nearly split
at that time
over those questions
the second time we nearly split was
after uh herbert lee was killed
and we asked ourselves can we do this
because people are going to die
we said that we had to do it
in order to stop people for dying
and since we were prepared to pay the
price
of our deaths
we could do it and we could continue
through all those debates what impressed
me was
that we used to when we started we said
we were banned brothers
and sisters in a circle of trust
and that was true
and through the movement
we came to know
the greatest love
we ever knew
a love for each other
because
unlike the accident of birth
when you're just born into a family
where you have no choice in that
we chose each other
and we chose to love each other
to stand with each other
and to die with each other
so this
meeting this evening
speaks to me a family
one of us is hurting
we are needed
and we have all come home
we always said
we may be of many minds
but we have one heart
in our heart
my heart
you would give kidney
we'd give blood
we would give anything
to help and protect each other
and the other thing that became
an important part of our family
was
the lessons as cleve pointed out he has
his children here and many others of you
do
that lessons that our children
in this country
should know
is that what we did was important
um what we did was courageous
and we lived with with the idea that
america had gone for years saying
sending us off to die
in a vain fight to quote make the world
for
safe for democracy
we pledged very early that we would only
fight to make democracy safe for the
world
and the last thing we said is in order
to do this we have to tell our stories
that is a way to keep the movement alive
to tell the stories
of our comrades
we've gone
and
those who struggle
and we need to support each other in
that
as a part of that i want you all know
that uh
joanne grant um
just published a book on alan baker
called freedom bound
supported
by
read
read microsoft stokely's book that
farming book
the book on the children about the
nashville people
read that we must support each other and
we must know the truth
of what we've been through
i remember being in jail in macomb with
bob moses
and bob those of you have seen this here
now
when the family gathers everybody comes
and we talked about the only way
that we could make our lives meaningful
was that the world knew our story
and we had to
tell the story
continue that obligation
tell the story
of kwame toure
tell the story
of what you did
tell the story of us all
and how our love
moved us further on up through the road
[Applause]
stokely
for me to read
my friend
[Music]
my brother
my colleague
mr chairman
i salute you tonight
because of your courage
your raw
courage your great strength
[Music]
you know i had a great
blessing
and tonight i feel more than lucky but
blessed
because i serve as chair of
snake from june 1963
to may 1966
during the time of the march on
washington
mississippi summer
and the march from selma to montgomery
and some of you may remember
executive secretary of snake
james foreman used to call us
a circle of trust
a ban of brothers and sisters
so stokely
you are a warrior
because you dare to stand up and speak
truth
to power
and so tonight i come to say thank you
brother stokely thank you brother
terrain
as a participant in the movement
i spent time with you
in atlanta
in mississippi
in alabama
in cambridge maryland
you cannot forget the time we shared
a room together
for a few nights
in greenwood
in the home of
freddie and george green parents
back in
to
1964.
starkly
you have been guided by what i like to
call the spirit of history
you allow the spirit of history to use
you
to track you down
and you realize that is an old african
proverb that says something like
if you care
move your feet
you've been moving more than your feet
you move your mind
your talents
and your skills as a great organizer as
a great teacher
we're better people
we are a better nation because of you
and it's my belief
when historians pick up their pians
and write about this period
they will have to say
brother terrain
for me to read
brother stupid kaimaka
made a difference
that you spoke up
you stood up
and you spoke out
you spoke out for those who have been
left out and left behind
you're a good man
you're a good leader
you had the ability and the capacity to
put yourself in the way
and you're still in the way
stay in the way
continue to agitate for what is right
for what is fair and for what is just
you forgot about your own circumstances
and you got involved in the
circumstances of others
thank you my brother
thank you my friend thank you mr
chairman thank you
due to allah who has created man
and has not left him
but indeed has given him guidance
as to that which is liked by the creator
and he has commanded upon man
struggle
with consciousness and awareness in his
behalf
it is with this in mind that
we see that the trust that has been
given to man
is always dispatched for again the
creator has
commissioned he has commissioned the
soldier to fight
to jihad the teacher to teach
the organizer to organize
and for the muslim he is commanded that
we invite that we give an invitation
and the invitation again is based and
centered around
that you invite people to the
consciousness and awareness that
struggle is an ongoing process
for allah has said in the quran he has
created man to toil and struggle
the word that is used in the quran for
struggle is kabad
which gives a general sense of struggle
meaning that everything and everyone who
comes into this life engages in struggle
to survive
the baby when he is born
he transforms from breathing a liquid
into a breathing a gas
it is said that when the egg is
fertilized there's a competition between
the sperm for fertilization of the egg
and this is implanted upon the
individual himself so he knows the
nature of struggle
but then allah in the quran commands a
higher level of struggle for he says
into jihad
feasibility
to struggle with an awareness and a
consciousness
and so it is that kind of struggle that
distinguishes the people
those people whose commitment allows
them to honor the trust to become
conscious and aware
and to struggle in a manner in which
they first deal with themselves
and then that which emanates from
dealing with yourself begins to involve
the environment
that is the social context of struggle
and it is a struggle that is the higher
form of struggle
so there is
a sense of commitment that we make as
individuals and we ask the creator with
consciousness to guide our heart and to
guide our tongue
we seek refuge in him for misleading and
from being misled
from betraying and being betrayed into
ignorance by others
and on the basis of this commitment we
are able to distinguish
those people who have made similar kinds
of commitments
for indeed in struggle and war there is
a kind of camaraderie that is forged in
war in the heat of war
so therefore the communications are
shortened between those people who
struggle on that level
i don't need to come and tell you a
whole lot about kwame
it is evident
for allah has allowed him to struggle in
a manner that is clear to the people
blessed are those who struggle
oppression is worse than the grave he
said it is better to live
and fight for a noble cause than to live
and die a slave
and it
again it is with this understanding and
awareness in this context that we begin
to understand those people who will
propel not just kwame
and kwame being you know a leading
figure from an era of movement and
struggle
but the people whose names that kwame
may know and i don't know
and who other people know and other
people might not know it is that sense
of struggle that kwame has committed
himself to not just we come forth
and give applause or that we say things
kind about him because with myself and
kwame there are certain things that that
we can see in the shortest of forms
that has a deep meaning because again we
have similar experiences in struggle
but we do
extend an invitation to kwame and to all
creation
that there is a level of commitment and
consciousness that you have to make and
struggle to be able to be successful to
take it from one level to another
how do we bring about good people
again when we look at ourselves in the
context of the sixties we see one of the
major shortcomings was
that we were emulating the people that
we were fighting against our morals and
our ethics were the morals and ethics
that were taught by the people who we
fought against
how do you raise a people how do you
again
bring about in a consciousness and
awareness amongst humanity that makes
them strive for the best
and again it begins with ourselves if
you can't beat yourself you can't beat
nobody else everybody can fight but
everybody can't win there's a discipline
there's a price
that is paid to win so the creator in
not leaving us alone to figure out
worship has instructed us concerning
worship
he says to be a better person one has to
be able to commit himself to a practice
says prayer five times a day for prayer
restrains and keeps you from bad
behavior fasting during the month of
ramadan for it teaches you
self-restraint and discipline charity
because you will not have believed until
you want for your brothers what you want
for yourselves and hajj because it is
that sense of community and
pilgrimage that makes us aware that all
come from two and the law says in the
quran all come from two and he has
created the races that men might get to
know each other not that they would hate
each other the best amongst you is he
who is most righteous the companions of
the prophet asked him what is
righteousness he said good behavior he
said of the things that will make you
successful there too
allah
that is consciousness of the creator and
your ability to do good to have good
behavior it is this sense of struggle
that we left the 60s within we continue
with an awareness that struggle has not
stopped it didn't begin in the 50s and
end in the 70s if our analysis of
struggle is that it began in the 50s and
ended in the 70s then there is a total
failure of closure on the part of our
struggle that we are involved in
again no
the movement sense of struggle which has
always visited struggle it says that the
anti-slavery movement marcus garvey's
movement the black power movement civil
rights movement they come and they go
but the struggle is continuous until
allah has righted the wrong that has
come about
again may allah be pleased with the
effort that has been put forth by all of
the people who have struggled here and
again with kwame that he knows that
allah has raised him and that allah has
commanded in terms of a higher level of
struggle from him and that allah will
allow him to understand the importance
in this life of making the declaration
concerning that which is truth and that
allah will allow him to understand in
terms of that when allah begins to
move us from one condition to another
it's for a reason
and it's a mercy that he gives us time
to reflect and to grow
so again we ask allah for a look that is
merciful of knowledge that is useful or
heart that is enlightened the tongue
that is truthful an intellect that is
unerring a countenance that is pleasing
to allah may allah give us success in
this life and in the hereafter may he
raise us in the company of the righteous
may allah allow the invitation that has
been given to be accepted that's lama
lagoon
[Applause]
always very hard to to follow the chair
person that's nick
before me
i want to thank uh karen spellman and
some other people who are on the
organizing committee for
letting me know about this event and
allowing me to come across the country
from california to be here tonight
um it's actually a dream being here
in many ways i think of um
stokely carmichael was no longer
the chairperson of snick in
1967 he came to washington dc to
organize a black united front
i'm looking at who's here tonight
looking here at the diocese you have an
internationally known leader minister
farrakhan
you have the mayor of washington d.c you
have several congress people
future mayor of chicago hopefully
academicians
leaders in the movement for of islam
and in the audience yourselves
you have a very broad base of support
and united front
i want to just actually take a quick
second to mention one of them who is one
of the strugglers who went before us and
is still with us
former congressman charles diggs from
detroit
so the black united front is not
something that is over that is
historical that is something of 1967
it is something that is ever present and
something that we are creating and
struggling to create daily as we move
into the 21st century
but the other thing i think about in
coming here it reminds me of the phrase
of the great african revolutionary
amicar cabral
when he talked about the return to the
source
it was 38 years ago
a few months hence that i first met
stokely carmichael
as a freshman
[Music]
to howard university here in d.c
yes me
shows how old we all are or how young we
still are in many ways also
but what i want to say
because part of coming to howard and
joining nag and there were a few
comments about nag and i just want to
say a few more because it was a nag that
i got to know stokely carmichael
it was an egg that in many ways more
importantly turned me
as a
i would say a brash
smart alecky young high school graduate
coming from cleveland ohio
who was thinking that i was going to
become a professional middle class
professional
and
help the race in that way
it taught me something very very
different in a different way of life
and coming into howard meeting
the people in dag getting involved in
the struggle i mean my remember of nag
and meeting stokely was doing rinse
strikes
on gerard street here in washington dc
in 1961.
it was getting tear gassed in cambridge
maryland or arrested in baltimore
freedom riding on route 40. food and
clothing drives for the people of
mississippi and alabama
that's how i changed my idea of what it
was to be
a political person i was always
interested in politics
but the question that politics should be
about principles it should be about
helping people it should be about
working with people at the bottom
and beginning to come up with new
definitions of who was qualified to lead
in this society
i learned that from nag and from snick
sitting with people like fannie lou
hamer john buffington and many other
people all over the south
and also in parts of the ghettos of the
north where i used to work in newark new
jersey during the 60s
snick provided that whole opening and
stokely was always a very key part of
that
because stokely i mean stokely was one
of those people who got in your face
and stuggly was a person who not only
had that intellectual brilliance i mean
we all knew that he majored in
philosophy and could talk that talk but
he also believed in putting his body on
the line
right now let's go do it i found that
combination totally
unbeatable it changed my whole life and
it also put a vision of what
political practice should be all about
both the mind the intellect and the body
putting your body on the line and the
struggle and stokely was always there
and stokely was there as a very much
clear personality for me as a model of
what a black man should be about and
that to me was what i learned through
black power
i mean
whoever in this audience ever had an
argument with stokely carmichael
raise your hands who had
whoever disagreed with stokely
carmichael whoever wasn't treaded by his
ability to be crystal clear
at all the great political points
whoever rode a car with stokely
carmichael or had a long bulls bull
session all night at a party afterwards
and go out with and went to jail at
stokely carmichael
that was a whole
education in itself
a real
american education in the best sense of
that word
and so when i think about all those
things what's most important why we are
here tonight in many ways is what chuck
mcdew said
and stokely we're here because we love
you
some of us may or may not have political
differences with you today but that's
not the most important thing tonight
we're here because of the struggle the
example that you have done
all your life
and
for black people
for people of other colors native
americans latinos a man who has upheld
the importance of the cuban revolution
past and present
and also
a person who has given his all to the
struggle
but finally we are here because stokely
kwame toure has made our own lives
more useful
more rich
he has given us a sense of how to live
and struggle and persevere
and we are better people for that
and so i'm going to end with a really
quick
poem
by the chilean revolutionary poem pablo
neruda
and this is my own interpretation so you
purists out there don't uh quote me
directly in this
neruda says there are some people
who come to the struggle
and struggle for a time period for a
campaign
and those people are important and they
really are because we need all the
people in the struggle and the mass
movement that we can get
but even more there are some people who
struggle for many years and they are
extremely important
because the struggle goes ups and downs
in and outs it has setbacks as well as
it has victories and we need people to
fight for many years
but finally there are some people
who struggle all their lives like kwame
toure
and they are just irreplaceable
and in that sense i want to say that
kwame toure
has set a model for us into the next
century
a transition point from black power to
international black power to the power
of african people all over the world and
for that we salute you we love you
brother terrain
for me to ray when i spoke earlier i
forgot to do something
i want to present a check tonight
to the foreign terrain
testimony for a thousand dollars
you notice i took the check
[Laughter]
um
i'd like for all the people from ned to
stand up
would you please
i just want to see all of you from from
nag
thank you very much
i'd like all the children
from snick
to stand up
i know my daughter is over there
all the children from snake
all the children from snake please stand
up
thank you very much
um not very long ago i was commenting to
um doreen
kwame's
cousin about uh
the fact that he is he has such an
enormous capacity to remember events
and doreen said well he takes it after
his mother
i'd like to introduce you to his mother
mrs
carmichael
[Applause]
we neglected
we neglected to mention two things one
is that um
jim foreman whom all of us are really
close to and who helped a lot of us
develop myself certainly
was too ill to attend tonight and so we
just want to make sure that he knows
that our thoughts are very very much
with him and let's just get a chance jim
the other thing we neglected to do was
to to give um time and this will be one
to two minutes of for the ambassador um
ambassador mustafa ngani from tanzania
who has honored us with his presence and
will bring words of greeting and then
following him sandra honore who is
representing trinidad and tobago and
tobago whoa tobago and she will follow
um the ambassador so ambassador and
gagne thank you
brother kwame
your excellency minister farakan
honorable congressman
your excellency honorable the mayor
excellency civic leaders distinguished
guests
brothers and sisters
for me it is indeed an honor and
privilege
to be given the opportunity
to bring you very warm greetings
from the people of tanzania
the land of kilimanjaro
and then that the land of malim julius
[Applause]
former chairman of the front line
the then front line states of southern
africa
and founding president
of tanzania
brother carmichael
i want you to know
that the people of tanzania remember
your contribution
in the struggle for self-determination
and your struggle against racial
discrimination
here in the united states and in south
africa
they remember
how you engaged
the most powerful
so that they could not have time
to engage in africa
you preoccupied on this you preoccupied
them on this side
wild african peoples preoccupied them on
the other side
[Applause]
i want you to know brother
that
the people of tanzania
honor you
cherish your wisdom
cherish your clarity
cherish your bravery
and cherish
your
principles of standing for the truth
always however however better
however difficult
but
the legacy you have left to the african
peoples is that you are a principled
human being
you as has been an outstanding
contribution
to the struggle not only of the african
american people in the united states but
to all the african peoples in the
african continent
and yours
is an outstanding contribution
which all people
of good will
worldwide
recognize
i join you brothers and sisters
in wishing brother kwame toure
all the best
we wish you
all the best
and we will stand
try to follow
the legacy
that you have
given us
in the united states and the african
peoples in the african continent thank
you very much
god bless you
thank you and all the best
[Applause]
thank you
kwame turi
ladies and gentlemen of the head table
i am honored to represent the government
and people of the republic of trinidad
and tobago
at this evening's testimonial organized
by the friends
in honor of kele kayla kwame
toure if i may address you also in
malinke as warrior
a native son of trinidad and tobago
of whom we are justly proud
there is no need ladies and gentlemen
for me to add to the plaudits that have
been bestowed on him
by the very eloquent speakers who have
preceded me
his work is self-evident
it has been said that he has played a
part in shaping the way a generation
shaped itself
he has been acclaimed internationally
indeed he has been most noble
in continuing the philosophical lineage
of distinguished trinidad and tobago
pan-africanists
and contributors to our development
such as clr james
george padmore
and henry sylvester williams
the honor being paid him this evening
echoes in a sense
that accorded him by trinidad and tobago
during his visit there in 1996
on which occasion he was paid special
respect by the government of prime
minister bastro pandy
he was also honored then by the trinidad
and tobago emancipation support
committee
whose lecture series he inaugurated on
that occasion
the honorable prime minister has asked
that his warmest greetings be conveyed
to you this evening sir
and has requested that i reiterate his
government's desire
as expressed in 1996
to assist with your
care we salute the friends of kwame turi
for the initiative taken in organizing
this event
as we pay tribute this evening to your
work
your influence
and leadership
throughout the diaspora
we commend your legacy to the youth of
today
and to their children of tomorrow i
thank you
thank you council monterey thank you
now we're going to move right through
the rest of this agenda um oh i feel
like i'm in a meeting um right through
the rest of the program could i just
have um the world famous jamaican poet
um mutabaruka just stand up so that we
can acknowledge him
i don't know where he is
yes
and just as an acknowledgement thank you
very much
thank you thank you very much
all right
all right thank you so much
oh okay
uh well no we don't quite have but it um
should we is it possible to do a photo
is it possible to do a photo just go
ahead
is it that point okay
all right if brother baruch would like
to join us here for a poem all right
[Applause]
continue
generally
i know you just continued
okay wonderful thank you
[Applause]
brother baruch was a special guest of uh
brother kwame toure
thank you
[Applause]
while that is going on i'm wondering if
we could move through and if brother
willie bricks and brother bob mance can
come forward
where did they go here we go brother
mance and brother willie ricks
all right
and where is so here we go all right
now
both of us are here here we go no we're
gonna come on over here okay
all right
now
all right black power all right
let me just do the intros and then they
can get to their stuff and then we can
get to kwame um willie some some people
saw ricks in the video organizing around
the concept of black power in the on the
meredith march rix is so respected as an
organizer that i think he could probably
get the klan and maybe even that
dangerous fool award connerly out in
california to pick it in favor of
affirmative action okay that's rick's
bob mans
uh bob went into lounge never left uh
he lives there with joanne who is
another strong soldier
from the southwest georgia movement
black woman hello and continues to
organize there now what i remember about
it is looking at eyes on the prize
working on it seeing the footage and
looking at the footage of bloody sunday
and seeing john and hosea at the front
of that march and then right behind him
bob with his knapsack on his back ready
for whatever was coming next that's
right so you all got two minutes
i bring you
greetings from lowndes county alabama
the home of the black panther party
lord
sometimes my concept gets so heavy
i came brother kwame
to assure you
that many of us
have and will continue to keep our eyes
on the prize
to
realize
that freedom is a constant struggle
and that we will never
turn back
black power
listen
when we say black power
we say it more than one time and we say
it like we mean it so let's say at least
five times say it like you mean it and
remember the masses that the people of
the world are listening and looking at
you black power
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
i'm going to talk a minute
i've introduced kwame to ray
hundreds of times
and i've never attempted to say a thing
about kwame toure
because i don't know much about him
all i can say that kwame toure is like a
star in the sky
that's giving off energy and life
this light traveling at a speed
i hate it
2 000 miles per second
the light sometimes is so far away
that it starts shining toward an object
and the source
of that up the source of the light
dies
the sun
the star burn itself up
but the light is so powerful that it
keeps shining and traveling
thousands and millions of miles away
from his stars and traveling and
traveling and traveling and i set out to
say
that climate 2 ray
is a beacon of light
that even when the size of that light is
gone
kwame rain will shine for thousands and
hundreds of years to come long live
quality race
now i would like to say
that black power taught us to help uh
want power to want land to warn a nation
and to be willing to stay up and fight
and take what we need in this world
kwame two ray tell us that all of
africa's hours and the diamonds and gold
and all in robin's heat and carpentry
cobalt in africa the land should be
united the people should be united and
we should take our land and use it and
feed and clothe our own people and the
only way we can do that is through
revolution revolution is the only way
and africa is our most important object
we must fight for africa so in closing i
would like to ask you to do another
thing
hold your fist up and i want you to send
to kwame two ray and say to your people
at least five times africa must be free
africa must be free africa can hear you
africa must be free africa must be free
africa must be free africa
[Applause]
thank you willie
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
greetings from kingston jamaica
you know say would i really feel bad if
you come so far and don't give our
tribute
yeah that's that so
they'll call me a man sit down can't
work
we have a poem here that was not written
for this occasion
and when i was a youth
most of these people that i see near
influence a lot of youth in jamaica
maybe they don't know that but i am one
of you with them that
i never knew that i would live to see
the day that i come in the same room
with so much of these black luminaries
from i mean i coming from jamaica and i
read so much books about these people
and to come here no one see them it's
something else
so we give thanks for this moment in
time
but you know what this is where it gets
bitter no this is where it gets bitter
because if you come to jamaica no one
asks people about black leaders apart
from marcos gavin who come from jamaica
it's only two
in my age group they will tell you about
they will tell you about
louis farrakhan
and stuart carmichael
yes
that's the only two
people know right now apart from those
who died like malcolm x and martin
luther
this poem
is bitter but i have to read it
the tears
the fears
cannot wipe away the years of struggle
the words used
were you confused about black power
garvey came
malcolm came
so many came
yet things remained the same
stokely remain
continued the years of struggle
revolutionary words have become
entertainment
revolutionaries sipping coffee and tea
explaining the struggle as it is
supposed to be
while the salvation army is still
leading the revolution
revolutionaries
caught in nostalgic ecstasy
having orgasms of what they did in the
sixties
while black youths die
young mothers cry
was the revolution just a dream
or a black bourgeoisie scheme
[Applause]
were you traveling through a maze
passing through a phase of time set
yet
not seeing that you have become the
oppressor talking about the oppressors
oppressing the oppressors
we are the oppressed
wives totally remain
continued the years of struggle
revolutionaries
becoming the system they thought they
had revolutionized
shouting black power
the hour passes by living a lie
fine suits and tie
white woman making you shy you chill
losing the will to struggle
yet
stokely remain
still feeling the pain of the struggle
revolutionaries scratched by the paws of
the panther
lost in the midst of capitalistic bliss
affirmation of their africanness yet
africa is in a mess stokely remain
that africa is the prize stokely
realized the game is the same but who
can we blame but ourselves in the
struggle
money spent to integrate
who will choose to report to aid
africa awaits its creators
gun shots in the streets
echoing the need for revolutionary
spirits to be rekindled
the youths declare like a nightmare
black power without fear who care they
share this power through the crack and
coke this is no joke a revolution is
taking place right in your face not of
your desire now you cannot stop the fire
you lit the fuse then refuse to let it
explode
revolutionary words being digested with
mcdonald's nuggets
whoppers popcorns ice cream
in brightly lit buildings oppressors
talking about oppressors oppressing the
oppressed
have you become the oppressor
another poem written
another song will be sung
another body will move to the rhythm of
liberation
just another of the same
another poet
trying to understand
just what is your idea of a revolution
and stokely remain
continuing the years of struggle
action
ladies and gentlemen we would like now
to have david brothers to come forward
david brothers uh
former president of the new york city
black panther party
and a member of the all african people's
liberation party david brothers
[Applause]
thank you
greetings brothers and sisters comrades
and friends
my name is david brothers i'm an
organizer and a member of the central
committee of the all african people's
revolutionary party the party
the party of crumby and crewmember and
secretary
standing beside me is sister marina
coyete she's a member of our central
committee also a representative of the
all african women's revolutionary union
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for earning the life of one of
african's noble son
kwame to reyes a pan-africanist of the
pan-african
movement
pan-africanism
is an objective and not an ideology
this is the total liberation of africa
under scientific social social
government
this can be achieved
africa can unite and use this resources
for africans and all humanity
kwame the ray in our opinion has never
wavered from this
from this year's sec objective he's
following the great pan-africans of the
century
henry sylvester williams
the honorable marcus garvey w.e.d boys
george padball c.l james cromian kruma
secretary comradeship bouquet armel
cabral and others
kwame jurey in our opinion ranks in the
forefront of african revolutionaries
your presence here is truly a
testimonial to how we revolutions can
touch the lives of the people
the aaprp call on every one of you to
truly honor our brother is to join an
organization which is
fighting for the people
light to fire ready for revolution
did you talk about the presentation of
bamboos
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much david
um ladies and gentlemen there are a
couple of
people in the audience that we don't
want to overlook there's the cuban
intersection first secretary felix
wilson will he please stand up and be
acknowledged
there he is great
hey
yes
we we we also have two representatives
from the vietnam news agency will they
please um stand up and be acknowledged
okay
thank you very much
um
ladies and gentlemen
some 30 years ago when when kwame and i
were roommates one of the things that we
did every sunday was we went to church
and one of the churches that we
frequented was uh
reverend walter front royce i would like
to introduce him former congressman
walter formroy is he there
now ladies and gentlemen we don't want
to forget
among the purposes of our meeting this
evening
it is intended to be a fundraiser
when we
moved from howard university to this
hotel it became more expensive
and so we've asked brother akbar
if he would be kind enough to say a few
words
in that regard
[Applause]
in the name of allah the benefits and
the merciful thank you bill
um
to the deus guest and i want to make
this short but first of all i'd like to
say that we thank everyone for staying
here i was looking to see who would say
oh i got to go i got to go
but this is an hour that we're honoring
kwame and you've stayed much later for
much less programs
so i want to do two things quickly
one uh if i can get some of the brothers
from the foi brother captain we want to
take up some money
and uh i said kwame in saint louis he
came to saint louis i really didn't want
him to come
but he's a man that honors his word and
he said i told the brother i'd be there
he came to st louis we didn't raise a
lot of money but we promised him ten
thousand dollars and we reached that
goal
kwame has to go back to africa i talked
to him in st louis in his hotel room and
he made it final i'm going back to
guinea
and at the end of the month
and i said well kwame if you're going i
know you're a socialist and you like to
fly in planes that only have one class
service i say but this time you need to
go first class back to africa
so he laughed
and when he gets beginning
he needs some people to be there with
him naiji you have to go with him that's
his sister please stand up she's a
stand-up sister naijin she's a nurse she
looks after her brother
i don't want her to worry about the job
in miami when you got to get back and
leave your brother
we want him to have enough money that he
can keep her there with him and when he
needs something in america or needs to
come to america he shouldn't call the
party to see if they got a speaking
engagement
if they can raise some money so he can
buy a ticket that money should be in
place
and if we want to say kwame we love you
and thank you for your sacrifice because
many of us have positions in this
society it comes from the struggle of
brothers like kwame toray and others
so therefore
tonight we want to we thank you for
buying the ticket but we want some money
tonight and we want bill we want you to
put it in the bank and whatever he calls
say a check is on his way
so let's do it and we have to do it
quickly
and and good now if there's someone who
has like uh congressman john lewis a
thousand dollars we want to recognize
you right away those who have five
thousand ten thousand minister louis
park thank you one thousand dollars
right here
if your organization wants to do it do i
have another thousand these lights are
in my eyes i can't see you
okay there's another thousand dollars
can i where give me the name
one thousand dollars
say your name please
rose daniel 1 000
listen
from selma alabama 1 000 thank you let's
get the money we got the trades coming
around please help us let's do it is
there another thousand dollars in the
house one thousand dollars
one thousand dollars
or is that a thousand dollars over here
watch the way you raise your hand now
i'm looking over there is that a
thousand dollars
five hundred dollars who has five
hundred dollars
five make your checks payable to
a medical fund
kwame toure medical fund
and it's a 501c3 you can write it off
all of the high rollers that looking for
something to write your money off at the
end of the year here's a cause tonight
so go on and write those checks
one thousand dollars henry thomas and
yvonne thomas let's give him a round of
applause from stone mountain georgia one
thousand dollars thank you very much
do we have any more one thousand you can
bring it right up they're moving the
receptacles through just put your check
or the cash right
in i see another is that a thousand
dollars or is that just hand waving over
there
500 you can bring the check right up if
you'd like us to announce it we want to
thank you thank you thank you and on
behalf of kwame and i watched kwame and
saint louis he was excellent the people
loved his spirit even in the pain so we
want to make sure kwame if you're going
to guinea when you need something we
want to make sure that everything is in
place and this is the audience that will
make it happen for you
as everyone had an opportunity to give
and you can also promise if you don't
have the checks with you you can get
them to build and he will make sure that
it's in place
the tennessee teachers credit union
fifteen hundred dollars give them a warm
round of applause thank you very much
thank you very much
do we have all of the collections have
we had all any table that has not had an
opportunity raise your hand right over
here in the center make sure we pick
them all up
so we want to thank you very much
bill and thank you very much for this
opportunity to help out tonight thank
you assalamu alaikum
[Applause]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen there were a few
more contributions that has been made
we have here from minnesota khan's wife
two thousand dollars
we
we also got a uh a fax communication
from um the steel pulse in london david
hines 500.
and uh we we certainly don't want to go
um without thanking doug moore who
hosted the um the reception uh this
evening doug thank you very much
um we also got a a very fine
contribution from gwen patton gwen thank
you
okay
um
now i would like to reintroduce the uh
the mayor
of the district of columbia
you know i'm not going to be very long
good evening one other person who really
ought to be introduced who was uh
in mississippi leading the mississippi
democratic party
lawrence guillermo
we now yeah leading the struggle i'm
going to very quickly uh do this
uh
these mean spirit republicans are trying
to take a lot of power from us here in
washington
but one thing they cannot do is stop me
from proclaiming this day commentary day
in the district of columbia
and i'm not going to read all of it it
says through his life the legacy of
african-american history has been
enriched by many of those who have
followed him
whereas individuals who devote their
time and talent to improve the quality
of life over their praise and public
recognition and kwame toure is one of
those individuals now therefore why the
mayor of the district of columbia
to hear bradford claim april 8 1998 as
cormier day in washington d.c develop
all the residents this great city to
join me in honoring this phenomenal
individual and his extraordinary
achievement and marion barry junior
mayor
i also like to present to uh i very
rarely do this only for very very
special people uh present a key to the
city to kwame toure
we don't have a lot of money but we've
got a lot of spirit here
for you
and as mayor of the district columbia
i'm honored to present the key to the
city to kwame toure symbolizing the
bestowal of the public trust on the
individuals who sirs
are inspiration to us all in ancient
times this token represented the key to
the municipal gates and indicated that
the reciprocal could forever be free to
come and go enjoy the hospitality the
city has offered today we the residents
of america's first city washington d.c
of bestowing this honor on kwame toure
recognition of his outstanding
contribution to civil rights and human
rights international revolution as an
organizer for the student nonviolent
coordinating committee his crusade for
justice on behalf of african-american
people in america and in the world great
pleasure on behalf of the residents of
our nation's capital
hereby present the key to the city to
come to uh proclaim
that it is entitled to all the rights
and privileges therein again signed
marion barry junior mayor i'll take it
over to palmy give him the key and the
confirmation god bless you for me you
know
you spill all of his blessings upon you
keep us i'm around you we just love you
we respect you admire you and you've
been a good teacher for me
[Applause]
thank you marion
uh ladies and gentlemen
brothers and sisters uh the person that
you've been waiting for to hear
from this entire evening
after you hear
from our brother
we will be asking minister
farikan to
uh offer the final prayer
um
we've asked brother kwame to
keep this short
short for us means five minutes
i hope short means five minutes
we will also have um
we
we we will give him as much time as he
chooses to have
uh
what can i tell you
um
but we
it's it's like it's it's been a long
evening for him
and uh we want to be mindful of that as
well
while kwame is giving his um his remarks
his son will be with him
kwame
[Applause]
uh good evening
we wish to
thank you
about uh ten weeks ago i came into the
country from africa
and uh
[Music]
you
to be brutally honest i'm hoping to go
ahead because you know them africans
they just
[Music]
do you know all this is put together in
heaven
and you know we had absolutely doing
this
to
and we must learn
to understand that we have unity
in the widest diversity
and saint louis
who is a brother who was in
they want to attribute
and the newspaper said oh well here's
this black capitalist
coming to help this black socialist what
can they have in common
of course we understand the intention
just to buy us
any democracy way
and we reminded of the history
in world war ii
[Music]
the united states of america the leading
capitalist station the world
join hands as the soviet union the
leading socialist country in the world
to fight against fascism in north
america
if certainly
stalin
and rutherford
enjoy the hands together
great digital brother here
[Music]
we must have unity
in our community
our mind is their lives
and we should call
calling for a united fund among all our
organizations
where deeply touched by your love
the overwhelming love which has been
given to us
but those of us who work in the state
know that this love is normal
this room
once put together
right now
is very powerful
you have individual positions
[Music]
there's nothing worse in life than
having worked for a principle and before
that it seemed that principle probable
and you do ask nothing about it
in order for life to have any meaning at
all that which you work for when you are
alive must continued after dead
otherwise your life had no purpose at
all
we have send young people that we worked
to absorb oppression
we work to upward exploitation and we
work with the unity of the oppressed
that is not principled
this people will continue easily
a system is never condemned simply
because the adherents do not live up to
the businesses that's
principles
right
that's right
jews betray christianity but
christianity is alive and lovely even
though
the principles defeated the justice will
continue even every
[Music]
[Music]
in the morning with his new lover and
she's not just coming to his job you
know i gave you the best part of my life
whether you like it or not the rest
belongs to you
if we gave you the best part of
lives or not the rest should be done
whether we our
[Applause]
[Music]
is
i'm very blessed
and deeply deeply honored to see
brothers
we say we want unity
and unity must be structured
we are pushing hard at the united states
what will taught us is
this meeting represents what the aware
of it or not
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the religious parties in those areas
where some call fascist parties sit down
together nobody says anything right
but if i sit down with julian in the
same room the entire place
our
is
[Applause]
better than all of us
that the position which he occupies
belongs to the blood of his people
[Music]
[Applause]
this position must be used to benefit
the masses of the mind
it cannot be done cannot be used if in
fact john lewis is isolated from faraga
who is isolated
[Applause]
[Music]
especially now
the system is precious
it is an economic crisis
it is in the political crisis
we have a responsibility here
to ensure that we begin we become a
leading force
in making to order the politics the
economics of all forums
[Applause]
we'd like to thank you to take your
responsibility
congressman john
i'd like to join you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
there's only one thing that counts as a
political capital for us
and that is the confidence which the
people have in you
we shall always work
every day every day to increase these
confidence
we shall increase his confidence by
being ever faithful to the
cause responsibility
you
coming together over and over again
as jonathan mentioned you see each other
in canada atlanta and alabama and
georgia america and everywhere all of us
and we come together and this super come
together spontaneously and turn
[Applause]
that's
[Music]
and then
[Music]
[Music]
washington
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
we can sit down together and organize
and put together united armed
coordinators
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
1965 and 1968 over 350 cities were
burned in this country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
you might just not embody the game
one of the things this game taught me i
already thought the rest of us was the
true spirits of non-violence
the example they gave is detected all
the time
the
attacking
i'm
[Music]
to unite these people because we know
once they are united go forth on
everything thank you
thank you kwame
now ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
it's healing time
and now ladies and gentlemen
the final prayer from minister fargo
in the name of allah the beneficent the
merciful
my dear brother kwame
to all who are gathered here tonight
brother kwame gave us
our marching orders
i want to say to brother kwame before i
say this prayer
that very few people that come this way
find
immortality
very few of us who come this way
find what jesus called
eternal life
one day i sat with the honorable elijah
muhammad
and he said
brother you are always talking about
love
[Music]
what is the definition
i gave him webster's trite worn out
definition
and he looked at me and said no brother
the essence of love
are the principles upon which life
and the universe is based
and those principles are freedom
justice
and equality
and those who truly love
struggle for these principles
and since these principles are eternal
those who struggle for these eternal
principles ultimately find
eternal life
my brother kwame toure
in my judgment
has fought for these principles
all the days that i have known him
so i believe as a lover
he has
very few peers
because he has never wavered
from this struggle for these three great
principles of life
and so i say to you beloved brother
and struggler for justice and freedom
and equity
there is never going to be a death
for you or for those who struggle like
this
we will live
in that which we have given our lives
for
and when the history is written
and they talk about the struggle
of freedom justice and equality
for black people and human beings on
this earth
they will always mention
with honor and distinction
because you have earned it
and the lessons that you have taught
all of us
we will retain
and the marching orders that you
have given us on this most
important occasion
the people
must hold us
to those orders
that we must create
a united front
and so as congressman john lewis and i
embraced and
mayor barry and i embraced and
congressman rush and i embraced
mutabaruka and i embraced
this must not be just for tonight
but if we pledge ourselves to work
for the total liberation of our people
then our lives
shall not have been lived
in vain
and no grave
could ever contain
us
that only can contain our flesh
but the spirit that has driven us toward
these three great principles
is eternal
and we
like those eternal principles
are
brothers and sisters would you please
stand
[Applause]
and i'd like to ask if we would just
hold each other's hands
o allah
guide us among those whom you have
guided a right
preserve us among those whom you have
preserved
befriend us among those whom you have
befriended
and bless us in whatsoever you grant us
deliver us from the evil of what you
have judged
for surely you judge
and none can judge against you
and those whom you befriend
are not disgraced
blessed are thou our lord and highly
exalted are you above
what is set up beside you
o allah we thank you
for this evening and for all who have
attended
we thank you for the words spoken by all
who spoke and the songs
sung by all who sung
but above all we thank you for taking us
back to the beginning
of our struggle
for the freedom of our people
because in that beginning
we found camaraderie
we found strength in each other
and even though our paths
have gone in different directions
tonight by calling us back
through the presence of kwame toure
to how snake
began
and how those who began snake
began with snake
but you've called us back to remember
so we can make a new beginning
our hair a little gray
our step a little slower
but our minds
stayed on the prize
we can bring victory
so we ask o allah that you bless
kwame toure
and bless all those who have struggled
with him
and bless all of us who struggle
for the liberation of our people and for
all oppressed
wherever they are on this earth
and we pray that as he leaves
this auditorium that you will go with
him and strengthen him
and comfort him
and make him whole
and heal him
for only you can heal
for we need kwame
into the days and months and years in
the future
imbue his son with his spirit
imbue those whom he has taught with his
spirit
his life having touched all of ours our
life has been enriched
by his presence among us
so let us take what he has given us from
the creator and let not his life and
work
be in vain
he lived for
a united front
let us pledge
that we will make that front a concrete
reality in his name and in the name of
those who struggle to achieve it
bless his mother
bless his sister
bless his family
comfort all of us
knowing
that we know
that our life shall not be
forever
this physical life will pass away but
what we do
in the struggle of our people will live
long after
we are gone
long live
kwame toure
long live those who struggle for the
liberation of our people
i bear witness
that there is but one god
i bear witness that abraham moses jesus
muhammad and all of the prophets
wherever they have come from whatever
part of the earth
they are one god is one
and as kwame has asked tonight
there must be unity
in our community
oh allah
let it be
amen
[Applause]
uh ladies and gentlemen uh just just uh
some house cleaning as you notice we
finished on time
there is a book written um on the life
of ruby dars smith
um it's written by uh
dr cynthia fleming we would encourage
you to purchase that book
we also got a a western union
cable grant from jim foreman
unfortunately he was not able to join us
we're going to try and see if we can
structure a uh a group photo with the
snick folks
if those
who want to be in this group photo we
were asked that if you would move to
your left my right
all the snick folks who want to be a
part of the group photo if you would
move to my right your left
then as kwami is leaving what we will
try and do is to stage
an opportunity for a
photo so
thank you very much for coming
is
is
um
[Music]
here's a look at this afternoon's
programming lineup
report congressional correspondent major
garrett also a u.s representative for
the palestinian liberation organization
will discuss middle east peace efforts
and two guests will be on hand to
discuss the ronald reagan building and
international trade center to be
dedicated this tuesday
coming up an interview with kwame tori
1960s chairman of the student nonviolent
coordinating committee also called snick
mr torrey formerly known as stokely
carmichael is a leader of the black
power movement during the 1960s snick
led voter registration efforts in the
south and rural areas of the us
but first the speech by him from a 1966
rally in los angeles
i'm tired and negro leaders telling us
how to be non-violent without teaching
us how to be non-violent among each
other
and respect each other first
our people are to teach us non-violence
among ourselves and that's where it
stops
that's where it's stopped
we'll try together ain't nobody gonna
mess with us
that's the one thing we've got to
understand all those people running
around here talking about the rebellions
didn't do no good the rebellions didn't
do this to do that the rebellions did
one good thing for this country it let
white america know that if they think
they're gonna play nazis black people
are not jews
[Applause]
and that means that we must move to a
position where we begin to bring those
factors together
we are the only people in this country
who have to protect ourselves against
our protectors
we are the only people that do that we
have to get community alerts to trade
and the only reason we do that is
because we are black
the only reason they're oppressive is
because we are black not because we're
stupid lazy deep watermelon and gas good
rhythm
[Music]
but because we are black
and that's what we must begin to
understand we cannot accept the lies
that this country has sold to us and to
everybody else we must begin to tell the
truth to each other and move from there
this country told us that if you work
hard if you sweat that you would succeed
if that were true black people would own
this country
[Applause]
because we are the hardest working
people in this country
and our trouble has been that we've
cared more for this country than we have
for ourselves
and it is time that we begin to think
about us
that's what we need to do
we have sent our mothers
to leave us as babies and go take care
of this and babies first before they
take care of those
we have yet our fathers want to fight
wars to help polish americans fight his
love and when they get back home those
same problems fight us in cicero we got
to take air
[Applause]
care about us because there's nobody in
this country that cares about us
the only protection we have is each
other that is all
that is all
and the minute we begin to recognize
that then we move on a true path for our
liberation that we begin to let this
country know that if they shoot a black
man
walking down the mississippi highway
with a bible in his hands if they shoot
a black man taking his life to the
hospital in los angeles they're not
dealing with one black man but they
dealing with 40 million black americans
[Applause]
now an interview with kwame tori
conducted recently in harlem new york mr
toray is in the united states for
medical treatment now 56 he's battling
prostate cancer
let me start with the
basic questions about your health we
keep reading that you're a sick man how
sick are you i'm fairly sick i have uh
cancer with starting the prostate it's
um
metastasized the stretch of the bones
you know uh
which gives excruciating pains and uh
on a gleason scale of 10 i have a seven
so it's uh it's a killer cancer
when you have something like that what's
it do to your mind
well it depends actually upon your frame
of mind you know
uh all my life uh death and life has
gone hand in hand um you know so um
as a matter of fact uh just to
be brutally humorous you know i should
have been dead a long time ago
so um
death in life doesn't do anything uh all
it does is makes you perhaps uh
prioritize your life
a little bit more precisely than you
would have haphazardly
and what do you do for it
physically i mean you go to the hospital
a lot you have to yeah well you know you
take these general treatments whatever
they can give you but um
i'm about to maybe just surpass all of
the treatments that you know they can
give to uh get rid of the pains you know
and what are you doing in new york now
i'm doing some work for the all african
people's revolutionary party
doing some recruitment work to organize
and then i shall return home to africa
by the end of this month where is home
it's in guinea in west africa and how
long have you lived there
30 years almost
29.
are you still an american citizen i
carry an american passport yeah and are
you a guinea citizen okay give me a
password yes
how american do you feel after 56 years
well you know i'm um
i'm not your unique i'm not your typical
person uh you know i wasn't born in
america or i was born in the caribbean
in trinidad and so i spent uh
my early childhood up to about 10 11 uh
there
so um
and i spent in america no more than 15
or 16 years before i moved to africa
so it's kind of hard just quantitatively
speaking to see it in that sense there's
no question now that
america has had a uh
very strong influence upon my life that
what can i be denied
what do you think's happened to america
since you were an activist
oh well i'm still an activist but i
think america has become more ripe for
evolution
the people have become more conscious
and even the right wing are becoming
more aware of who their real oppressors
are you know and uh begin to see that we
africans and we can't do we have no
power we cannot do anything you know and
uh they're beginning now finally to wake
up and see that they must fight the
power not the powerless
so i think our conditions are more rife
revolution people are more conscious
women are more conscious
the environment movement is more
conscious in every area you will see
new uh domains of struggles which you
had not even thought about in the 60s
you gave a speech at the university of
massachusetts in 97 and i want to quote
back to you what you said and have you
talk more about this
practically every profound change in
this country since the 60s is a result
of the mass movements of africans in
this country
can you give us an example oh let me
give you a real funny one
uh
some years ago maybe about uh
10 15 years ago
uh my our party there committed me to
go to do a recruitment drive that the
mormon school is that in iowa salt lake
salt lake city utah utah utah
and um
of course when i first saw it i said who
did this you know well you know well i'm
a disciplined organized man once the
organization you know
gives orders as long as they're not
contrary to humanity i can follow them
you know
and uh it's all right so i went and of
course at that school there must have
been about eight african students and
all of them came to the airport to meet
me
none of them wanted my feet to touch the
ground you know and they're just fussing
and bubbling nobody ever comes here you
know you're the only one nobody thinks
about us all right so they take me to
the
hotel campus hotel where guest guests
stay
and behind the desk is a white college
student there was
working at students
and he has long hair you know and he
sees them making all this fuss over me
you know even though you want me to sign
my name when it's time to sign so
finally when i have to sign the card at
the hotel i come and he said who are you
anyway i looked and i said so why am i
making all this fuss over you i looked
at him i said you see that long hair
you're wearing you have to thank me
of course if i came in the 60s you'd
have a crew cut and bobby socks
you know just the conformity in which
america had lived in the 60s was
completely broken open
uh when you see people wearing uh simple
things as dungary suits
you know i said just in terms of a dress
you know all this was part of the dress
code that was thoroughly broken down in
the 60s i mean just on that level
the 60s have profoundly touched the
country of course the uh powers that be
tried to make it appear as if it had no
profound effect upon the country but the
effect has been uh in every aspect of
life in america i have been touched
this gulf the handicapped golfer who
just was stolen by a case when i saw
that case he was talking he knows an
individual i said oh this is mrs rosa
parks victory
why rosa parks victory because uh once
you start against discrimination where
you're gonna stop you have to get rid of
all discrimination that's natural
so any uh once you start off and you
agree that discrimination based on
natural selection the way a person is
born or whatever is uh unjust then uh
it goes all the way because it was made
by fact it was after that that you began
to see the handicaps on the streets
before that the handicaps were afraid to
go on the streets they had no
access routes for them you know but
since the uh 60s even the handicap in
this country have become conscious and
have protested and have changed the
conditions of their very life yeah
what's happened to racism in america
uh it's still strong it's very strong
it's become more subtle um but its
subtleties of course are being exposed
more and more and by none other than the
bourgeoisie themselves who uh
they call it have reached the ceiling
you know
so uh
it's become more vicious there's no
question about it in its uh subtleties
and uh
the people are more determined to fight
it in every aspect
if you were to go back in the 60s and
pick the moment when you were the most
well known in the united states or the
moment when you had reached your peak of
of uh
i don't know either fame or of value to
the revolution when would it when would
that have been
today
[Laughter]
because every day of course we learn
more
people get carried away with the media
and publicity but
actually some of the best work i've done
has never been recorded on the cameras
or in the history books uh
and every day we become if we're
determined we become more knowledgeable
and more experienced which i have and
become every day so every day i am of
more value than the day before but uh if
we were to look back to uh to be more
precise
on your question if we were to look back
probably you know the student nonviolent
calling committee when i served as chair
gave two slogans to this country one was
hell no we won't go and the other one
was black power
of course very few people look at the
hell no we won't go
but hell no we won't gold's job was to
smash the draft which it did uh black
power of course has not been arrived yet
we don't have black power yet and have
some way to go before we get to arrive
at black power some people get confused
and think that uh individual african
electoral politicians equals black power
i don't know how they come to that
conclusion with
you can have an african mayor in new
york and the conditions of the african
masters
not only do not change but in fact can
become worse
go back to that hell no we won't go did
you invent that well it came out of
snake yes when i was chair do you
remember the moment when you invented
that particular i remember we said it
yes it was uh when that arrested me here
in staten island in new york uh
because of a refusal to uh get drafted
and uh they held me there i think
overnight or maybe 72 hours i can't
remember
and then when upon my release
the press said are you going hell no
no intention of going to vietnam how
much did that take off around the
country it went like wildfire um
you know i remember i remember as a
young representative snick going to a
peace meeting and all these big people
that read about books you know dave
dillinger you know
spock you know i mean all these big
people you know braden you know big his
heavyweights you know and i'm a little
student i'm taking copious notes and uh
at the end of the meeting the one of the
people said oh but the representative
snick is here and um they've said
absolutely and nothing says oh i'm sorry
i said oh and my organization just came
to tell you that we're going to smash
the draft
and i sat back down they said no you
can't do that i said i'm sorry i'm just
tell you my organization told me to tell
you and i sat back down that was their
attitude but uh of course we persisted
and we pursued and uh where the hell no
certainly did smash the draft not only
that it caused a lot of uh
of a disruption of the draft machinery
in the country with youth by white youth
building up real resistance against the
draft we wanted to move them from
protest to resistance and uh hell no
it was a slogan effectively didn't move
from protest to resistance you know
we're not protesting the war we're just
not going
why didn't you think you should go
to the war in vietnam there was
absolutely no reason for me to go i mean
especially me
from the time i was 19 years old i was
tortured i was in prison i was beaten in
the south just being trying to give the
right to vote to africans there
so there was no way in the world
that i who were beaten in mississippi
for trying to get the right to vote it's
going to go to vietnam and give somebody
else the right to vote with a gun by
those who deny me the right to vote i
mean the logic says
it just wasn't possible there's no way
he couldn't see out of there there was
no way it was clear if i can't vote mr b
hell i'm going to go to vietnam and
fight give me a gun and mississippi get
my vote here then i will see about
vietnam what happened were you drafted
at any time yeah i refused to go so what
happened you go to jail you know they
said that i when they classified me once
they give you that
mentally
unstable unstable mentally insecure so
that was crazy in one word another i
forgot what the classification was but
they gave me a crazy classification said
i was crazy
well this pleasure showing being mad
which number the madman knows
black power came at what moment that
slide the slogan uh came in uh
mississippi on the marsh mississippi
and that's interesting to note that uh
the africans in this country had went
from uh
freedom now
in 1963
on the march in washington to black
power in 1966
on the marching mississippi in three
short years
the consciousness had uh leaped um
black power of course had to come
dr martin luther king occupied the
center of the stage which he should
there's no question about that but um
there were
areas where in fact
where there was progress in fact those
areas were not making progress anymore
for example where to arouse the people
and say freedom now would stir them
once they got up and saw all the
problems before them saying freedom now
again doesn't uh
exactly stir them you have to be a
little bit more precise as you uh go
along and struggle and
one of the reasons black power came was
to begin to bring more precision
uh to the movement
it came to clarify number one that
though dr king was loved admired and
respected by all of us
non-violence was a principle for him but
for him alone
and of course people who don't study the
struggle seriously didn't understand
this but of course i knew dr martin
luther king and i follow him very
closely and uh
as early as 1955 my memory serves me
correctly
i think he recounts it in stride towards
freedom in the book
when his house was dynamited
you know after his house was dynamited
uh the you know he missed death by about
this much
and uh the african community in
montgomery was steaming you know
and uh but you know dr king has a silver
tongue he can talk to sweet out of honey
you know
and
he wanted to pick up guns dr king you
know he's
brought out his silver tongue calm them
down you know told them no wasn't need
for retaliation
and then there was discussion about
whether he had a gun in the house and he
refused to keep a gun in the house but
the montgomery improvement association
the organization which he had at that
time
imposed body guards at his house 24
hours
and he king had to accept it
so once this was done he was clearly
saying all right me king i understand
this is my principle but this is me king
as an individual for the rest of my
community they have not arrived there at
this point so more work here and there
etc etc but at least they're not there
now
when did you develop and did you develop
the black power salute
no not really the black power slogan's
been around for some time uh
richard wright has a book entitled black
power which he dedicated to kwame
nkrumah
uh adam clayton powell
congressman uh of new york was fond of
uh not only saying black power but he
said audacious black power
so uh it wasn't anything new it was just
uh
the uh right time of the mass movement
to write the to launch the right slogan
that's all
what was the reaction when you started
using black power and the salute in this
country well of course the reaction was
overwhelming
uh
but for me
i expected of course the press eye we
knew what the reaction would be there
but what was overwhelming was the
response of the masses we really didn't
know that we would touch such a
responsive cord
among the mass of the people with the
slogan which of course it did at that
time yeah
so i was
was myself individually just overwhelmed
by the reaction the response and the
enthusiasm that was generated around the
slogan i mean it uh it sent people uh in
a thousand different directions you know
doing a thousand different things trying
to benefit the community by the way
where are we sitting
we are sitting in harlem on convent
avenue this is the apartment of
a sister of mine
sister geraldine price who's a professor
at city college which is
not too far from here this is the middle
of harlem
and
where were you
growing up in this area i grew up in the
lower bronx uh stebbins avenue right
across the bridge as a young man
what year did you come to the united
states uh i think 51 or 52.
why
my
mother and father had been united states
my mother
came to united states i left my father
because
she had some
problems with my
paternal aunts
within the same house she had to live so
her mother was here in america so she
came
and my father um feeling loved beats in
his hearts stowed away on a ship to come
to america to join my mother
and
that's how
we ended up here with my grandmother my
paternal grandmother who was raising us
when she
passed away uh then we were brought to
america my sisters and myself how many
in the family are beside you there are i
have four sisters i'm the only boy i'm
the second and where are the sisters uh
one's in new york here two are in
florida with my mother and uh one's in
mississippi and what did your parents do
for a living my father was a cop in
child
my mother uh uh raised her family uh
took care of a house and uh when my
father died i worked as a waitress on an
ocean liner
what year did your dad die
uh 61 or
when you think of your parents each one
of them what what did they give you
my father gave me honesty
my father was
aggressively honest
and
my mother gave me my fighting instincts
my mother looks for confrontation
why
i guess it's a nature
and when did you first notice this in
her a long time ago that nature is just
i guess the conditions under which she
grew up and the insults which she
refused to take
the fighting is
i that was very early my mother's
fighting instincts are recognized very
early along my father's honesty
what do you first remember when you came
to this country and you lived in the
bronx at age 10 or 11. the first thing i
remember was that as a child in trinidad
when the moon was full and bright we
used to love it to go outside in the
yard and play
and when i came to america and stebbins
avenue i couldn't see the moon
in the apartment building where we lived
where's the moon
i want to go outside and play
you know so uh my biggest that couldn't
see the moon is unbelievable you know
that's where i started from not seeing
the moon to um what concrete jungle i
guess it was the uh where i was
transferred to yeah in every sense of
the world did you lack things as a kid
not really no not really um
we were taught anyway uh not to
want what you uh couldn't have
uh so uh and that uh philosophy was uh
embedded in us early in life uh so uh
enough so i think it had an effect on
most of us that uh we never wanted what
we could not have what were your high
school years like
my high school years were very
interesting it they quickened my
political consciousness i attended the
bronx high school of science here and uh
at that time my name being carmichael
said to him sat close to a man by the
name of dennis who happened to have been
eugene dennis the son of eugene dennis
of the communist party of the usa
and uh so through him and we also
went out to play on the soccer team
together we're co-captains in our senior
year
developed very strong friendship and
also a lot of political contacts and
political discipline and study of
marxianism so i quicken my political
consciousness is he still here with us i
don't know where dennis is i'm trying to
track him down in years we keep trying
but he's somewhere around i keep
slipping and sliding missing him here
and there what did it mean then to be a
communist
right you're talking about
1956-57 right what
if you woke up pick it glad you were
communist yeah they uh what they kill
you you know be a communist even if the
enlightened bronchus for science we'd
have uh
big fights just to have rallies outside
of school for the right of uh someone
from the socialist party or the
communist party to speak
yeah so um no no it was um
really these africans have broken
america wide open from its conformity
there was no i mean there was no uh
political dissent on the question of
course this oh no it was terrible
what did what's the definition of a
communist 1956-57
style in your opinion well of course the
same thing it is for me communism is
nothing other than a scientific economic
system uh whose principle is from each
according to their ability to reach
according to their need which is a
governing principle and of course you
must just make your governing structures
to ensure that this principle is uh
carried forth so i thought it's ever
meant to me because i have known it i've
studied it unfortunately in america at
that time communism and anybody you
didn't like or didn't agree with
whatever reason
when was the first time you got
attention yourself for being an activist
high school or college like uh no
probably in college probably in college
in that sense probably in college yeah
and you went where
well of course by the time i was a
freshman i already joined the student
alvin korean committee so uh we were
doing four regions of south doing
vacations we did work in virginia
we did work on route 40 in maryland
because you know washington dc to get
into it you have to go either through
maryland or virginia and at the time i
was a student at howard university both
states were segregated so no matter how
i went to uh school i had to go through
segregated states to arrive there so we
took on these states and
a man by the name of julius hopson who's
dead now but who was then the congress
of racial equality direct in washington
dc also trained us in a northern
struggle if you will so being
technically in the north in washington
d.c and touching the south maryland
virginia
gave me and those of us who were in a
non-violation group at howard an
opportunity to see northern and southern
struggle being waged at the same time
and how to combine them why did you
choose howard
well it's very funny
as a senior at bronx high school of
science
there was a demonstration against huwak
house of an american activities
committee in washington d.c
in my senior year may of 1960
and uh of course i had a special hatred
for huak for his treatment of paul
robeson of course i had hatred but this
was even special hatred for what
they were doing to paul robson and uh
any chance of course to uh
avenge uh huwak uh would be gladly
seized upon especially as a young man
so when they said there would be this
picket line i was very enthusiastic i
knew there wouldn't be many africans on
the picket line because you know it's
communist and socialist groups in
america
but i was very surprised when i arrived
in washington dc to find a large
contingent
of africans who were marching under the
socialist party in washington dc
so of course i immediately ran up to
them you were the socialist party they
said no no we would snick you know but
uh we're against you act two they bother
so we're picketing us your picket you
like it yo with snake they say yeah we
would nag and they gave me the uh
organization on campus and contacts and
i'd been thinking about going to howard
but
at clinchett i couldn't wait to get to
howard
and how long do you spend at howard it's
four years i did a bachelor's degree in
philosophy
and what were you studying what kind of
philosophy philosophy political
philosophy political philosophy and i
think i had a double major in sociology
and history and as you look back on the
philosophers that you liked
who would you name uh the ones i of
course would be the materialist you know
uh marx
of course angles yeah the uh
the others who are idealist uh
uh just try to make confusion for people
and they just try to reflect the
thinking of the ruling classes at any
given time and make it appear as if that
is the status quo
in the speech you gave at amherst
at the university of massachusetts
amherst
um last year you talk about primary
sources
and you say that america is arrogant
and that you kept challenging the
students to go to primary sources talk
more about that what do you mean by that
well we gave an example and it's a true
example you do it even your what they
call random
telephone
surveys
i'm sure that if you ask
the people in america
at least 90 percent of the people in
america over 15 years of age have heard
of adolf hitler i'm certain at this time
and i'm sure if you ask all of these
who've heard of adolf hitler if they
have an opinion about him i'm certain at
all they all do
and if you ask them how many of them has
read one book by hitler
or one article by hitler i'm sure less
than two percent
so these people form their opinions
about a great man like adolf hitler
wickedly great badly great a man who
affected the world anyway so there must
be something there
and
without even reading him they just uh
read what's been passed down to them
it's just like if
you know lamb writes that hitler's a bad
man and i come i read it hitler's a bad
man all right hitler is a bad man you
get an a you know but uh i can read just
as well as lamb if i can read lamb i can
read hitler
so
i think it's better to send us to
primary sources of course as a
philosophy student we were urged to go
to our primary sources i couldn't accept
what someone said about uh karl marx i
have to read it myself i wouldn't accept
what someone said about kwame nkrumah
i'd read it myself i want to accept what
someone said about seculare i'd read it
myself you know about mao citong i'd
read them myself so
i would not accept what anyone said
about it or fiddle about anyone i can
read and if i can read them i can read
hitler where would we go to find the
primary source on
kwame toure stokely carmichael well you
can find them in some sources in library
and documentation but have you have you
archived the speeches you've got uh
they're archived and uh we're also doing
a uh book now which uh social pressure
has imposed upon us because death is
lingering above our heads
and we're
working on completing that book how long
do you think you'll live
i don't know but um what the doctors say
well the doctors keep saying they're
buying time they gave me um
two years ago about five months you know
so uh
doesn't make any difference to me it's
not as the bond lutheran would say it's
not how long you live but the quality of
life that you live in what is the
quality of your life now well uh
one thing that we are most proud of and
grateful of is that uh we've always
carried our people's struggle with a
dignity with integrity we've never
compromised we've never lied to anyone
so these are things for which we are are
proud and things which we would want to
leave as legacies
how do you afford to to live these days
oh no um
when i was a young man working for snake
the student non-violent committee and
had a college degree
i worked for nine dollars and some cents
a week wasn't it uh if you got it
and half the time you didn't get it so
um
i have really functioned all my life as
a gorilla i can live off the people i
can travel around the world without a
penny in my pocket and i will be fed and
i will be housed everywhere i go i'm
certain do you have medical insurance uh
no i have no medical insurance at all so
how do you pay your medical bill well
i'm a poor man so um
medicaid will pay this one will pay and
i have a lot of
people like
dr
bill hall who's been a good friend and
they've put together a medical fund to
help with
extra medical expenses now recently we
covered an event that you
you didn't do it somebody did it for you
and watch again dr bill hall helped to
organize that with karen spellman
exactly and did they raise money for you
there they did raise some money there
yes
uh i don't know how much they raised
that's not my uh department so people
want to contribute to your
health fund there there is one there is
one there's the medical fund uh for it's
called the quality of medical fund and
the addresses uh will be given to you
okay yeah i've got i've got to copy the
address here we'll put it on the screen
if people want to see it but
how much does it cost to keep you
medically treated
uh well it depends you know depends uh
cancer and well anyway medicines in
america is a very uh
expensive affair for the uh sick
and a very profit-making affair for the
rich and those who own it so it's very
costly but again these areas of budgets
that's never been my problem you know
i've
worked in organizations all my life i've
never been a treasurer of any of them
so
i'm usually away from the treasury
department uh it's being handled again
by dr bill hall and others they handle
all those bills whatever is needed
they take care of it so that i can
continue in my last days to give my last
energies uh completely to struggle
why do they do this for you do you think
well because i've sacrificed for the
people once you sacrifice for the people
that people sacrifice for you they're
bound to do it they have no choice i
tell them i worked for you
and they know it's true
and then what did you do for them i
struggled for them i continued to
struggle for them you know and uh will
continue to struggle for them and i
continue to uphold the struggle with
integrity for them yeah where do you
want to live out your last days no in
africa no question about it in guinea no
question and what is it about guinea
that attracts you well uh you know i
first went to guinea over the 30 years
ago close to 30 years ago and that
i went there because it was the most
revolutionary country in africa so was
the revolution that attracted me to
guinea at that time there were
co-presidents uh kwame nkrumah and
secretary
and
under these two geniuses of the african
revolution i
was able to get a thorough
political education on the african
revolution obviously both in theory and
practice and
guinea has been the breathing ground so
it's the place i know best it's the
place i've spent most of my life and
it's the place i've done uh most of my
organizing where is it in africa it's
the west coast of africa it borders uh
sierra leone
borders uh
senegal it borders mali it borders
liberia it's in that area and of course
atlantic ocean and do you want to be
buried there of course
what do you have in the way of personal
family left
my mother my sisters and children my
sons how many children do you have i
have uh two sons how old are they one is
uh 17 and the other is four and they
live where
one is hearing one is in guinea the
other one's with his mother uh somewhere
here in virginia
in the speech again and and by the way
how important was that speech to you it
seemed like that you said an awful lot
in that
um well um you know it was organized by
people again who were demonstrating uh
love uh
judy richardson bill strickland mike
filwell and they're
within the academic circles uh there and
uh they were doing their very best to be
of help again in trying to raise our
funds for the medical fund and
for us
as organizers very rarely do we appear
before uh white audiences of this type
we do every once in a while just to test
their fiber their determination to
maintain the status quo and so this one
represented a chance for us to uh tap
them fairly hard and see what the
response would be
what's the reaction uh that you see
from your eyes that when you're around
whites
uh
from now you mean um just now right now
i mean
no reaction how do they react to you is
there a depends uh it depends changing a
lot i'm sometimes very surprised uh
sometimes i fight uh white uh males my
age and they look look look look then
finally they decide and they say it must
be him and they come they sit there and
say are you i said yeah and i said let
me tell you something
about 30 years ago i was against you you
know i want to kill you you know but i
want to thank you because now you know
you've helped me i see you know that you
were doing the right thing you know and
so i get that
that reaction which of course is um
is reassuring and uh affirming and uh
but i don't get uh too much hostility
today
and the reason is because uh since the
1960s
whites cannot blame us for the problems
that they've had
they know that we are not capable of
bringing all the problems whether or not
there's uh prayer in the school or not
we have no control over that and the
general policies which they are opposing
we have no uh
no control over that so i think that
they begin to see more and more that uh
you know we have no power and there's no
need to waste time fighting us
hostility has been reduced
c-span's interview with kwame torre
continues in a moment here's what he had
to say about integration in 1966
i want to make it crystal clear
that when we say integration is
irrelevant that isn't to say that one is
opposed to it to do that is to commit
the fallacy of the undistributed middle
integration is irrelevant i assume that
we're integrated here that's well and
good when i go out to catch a white cab
driver he's still going to pass me by i
don't know how that has helped
we're talking about racist institutions
that exist in this country not
individuals
my friends are my own they're not for
public view i believe in the right of
free association
so we will just stop that right there we
do not organize black people to move and
sit next to white people that fight must
be waged by white people
it has to be waged by white people
because when they deny me the right to
live in their neighborhood they lose
they miss me and that's tough for them
and that for me to beg to get into that
community is for me to dehumanize myself
and i shall not do that i am a human
being i am black i am equal
it is the problem of white people who do
not see me as equal and they have a
problem to civilize themselves that is
their problem
now i want to touch that on the problem
that mr russell raises about the lesser
of two evils is about time this country
tells the political leaders that we do
not vote for evil men period
mr rustin makes a fallacy when he says
that mississippi is a bastard state she
is not bastard she is 100 american
and that is the assumption that snake
has always moved on that the south has
not been some individual bunch of races
but that hub power is strongly invested
in washington dc
[Applause]
i want to say then that what mr rustin
moves from is how to solve individual
problems and that's his biggest fallacy
he starts off with a freedom budget
which states that we're going to get
money and give them to individuals
because they're the reason why people
are poor as this country tells us is
because they're stupid they're apathetic
they're lazy they didn't go to school
they were born on the wrong side of the
track they had too many children they
went in the army too early that's a lot
of nonsense poverty is well calculated
in this country
2 000 families own and control 85
of the resources in this country that's
calculated poverty in this country
and that you don't find institutional
calculated poverty on an individual
basis you organize to fight it on an
institutional basis and that's where we
proceed from in the student nonviolent
coordinating committee
and then finally i would just like to
reiterate about the assumptions that
what is good for this country is not
good for black people this country is
racist from top to bottom
from right to left
and for black people to become a part of
that is for them to become in fact
anti-black and to hate themselves
that is precisely why you have the
frustration of the so-called black
bourgeoisie and that is precisely why
you have the frustration of black people
cutting and shooting each other on
friday night inside the ghetto the
question of a black image is necessary
it is necessary it is not sufficient we
recognize that in the student nonviolent
coordinating committee but in order to
unite black people you've got to get an
image which they are proud of and this
country has made them ashamed of their
image
and once they have got that
and once they begin to see themselves as
a group and not as a bunch of
individuals who can work in ibm or work
uh in standard oil who exploit south
africa and work on wall street null and
nonsense once they begin to see
themselves as a group then they can
wield group power and that group power
is going to be very very effective
because i reiterate
that if in fact you can control
the political politics of your community
you will control economics for example
if black people control lowndes county
they've got the tax assessor the tax
collector and the guns the sheriff
they're going to raise the property tax
since they don't own property in lowndes
county white people either go sell or
pay the taxes and we can all go on
welfare for a decent salary
and it becomes crystal clear to me that
if you had black people who were
responsive to the manhattan where they
control it since they're 60 they can
begin to change the economy of that
country and the pressure that black
people will fight for will in fact
motivate and move the rest of this
country because this country moves
precisely because of the civil rights
movement that's why this country must
stop it
johnson must stop the civil rights
movement because it is the biggest
threat to his great society
[Applause]
but i want to point out one further
thing
it is crystal clear to me that all the
people who call for coalitions are
coalescing with not one person who has
spoken out against the war in vietnam
[Applause]
and that what is necessary in the black
community is that we do develop an image
of blackness which is healthy
and that secondly we begin to develop a
political sophistication which comes
from inside our community because the
external politics is built to contain us
always has been it has been the history
of this country
and that for the change of that we must
develop those new politics and that we
are on the way of developing because we
are raising basic questions about the
type
of political system that runs this
country it is outdated we need new forms
and that is what we're working for and
those forms mr rustin once articulated
if you have what you call the good
forces inside the racist community will
begin to speak to them that is for them
to speak to it not to us
we will then continue
inside the student non-violent court and
equity to build out of the ghettos of
this country's communities where we have
the power and to begin to build
political forces inside the different
states which will force
the two
evil parties to stop becoming the lesser
of evil parties and start readdressing
itself to the problems that face this
country looking back what worked
violence versus non-violence
both worked you know for me uh the
difference here must be clear between
king and i we started to talk about it
before and precising the black power
but as we said king took it as a
principle
as a principle being an honest man which
he was king had to use at all times
under all conditions for us navaj is a
tactic if you go back and look at some
of your documentation you will see me in
nonviolent act
i've been beaten i've been sent to
hospitals on non-violence and i've never
broken non-violent demonstration only
once in my life and that was on the
mississippi march when the policeman
pushed dr king
have i ever broken a nonviolent
discipline so uh i accept it you know
but if it's no longer working now i'm
not going to like dr king to become
hostage to
what i consider to be a tactic as a
principle i might pick up guns how many
times have you been arrested
sure they asked me the idea that i know
they think they checked between
something between 29 and 36 i think how
many days or how many different jails
have you been in
[Laughter]
i
i've seen jails in uh ghana i've seen uh
yeah i've been arrested in ghana i've
spent night in jail in ghana
i've been detained in
france i've been
detained in senegal i've been expelled
from senegal
i've seen jails all of america i've been
expelled from canada so
how many jails in america oh i can't
even count but i've seen jails in new
york when i was a young student here we
went to with the hospital workers here
union 1149 i believe uh we went to jail
uh here in new york along with union
strikes and of course uh
in maryland and from there all the way
down to uh texas i've seen jails what's
the longest you spent in jail uh
probably when i was young at parksman
penitentiary in mississippi in 1961 the
freedom rides
maybe two two two and a half months
three months and what happened there
torture every night this 1961.
[Laughter]
1961
[Laughter]
how did you get to jail in mississippi
freedom rides i got on the you know just
breaking the law of segregation
was there a moment though and i i
remember reading somewhere where
somebody called you boy and you didn't
accept that well well of course uh this
by 1964 of course now i was a
experienced organizer with a lot of
experiences on my belt facing a
policeman and
this policeman was a rather uh
rather racist and
in front of a whole group of people uh
you know decided to insult us using me
you know and
he said boy i tried to go there
my name is roy
you know he said would you say i said my
name roy he said i said roy i said boy
that's what i said my name is roy
you know and what's your name i said mr
stokley carmichael oh really all right
you're arrested we'll see you later all
right
and uh
he arrested me and uh threw me in jail
and he had to do some work and uh
i'm almost sure that uh well of course
uh the snake comrades got me out of jail
and they just they got me out of jail
his car was coming to the jail but i was
certain he was going to come back and
try to torture me and i was certain that
i wasn't going to let him i was going to
fight him to death
but get back to the vines because in
this speech at umass you talked about
first of all
you said that you met with the crips and
the bloods out in los angeles what was
the reason for that to try and bring
unity among them we understand that
these gangs are spurned by uh the cia
and the fbi to cause insecurity inside
our community
and
our job is to try and to
bring down these hostilities you know
and not only do that but to show them
that they need to be defending the
community instead of bringing in
security to the community but we've been
meeting with uh these gangs since the
1960s if my memory serves me correctly
in chicago they were the black stone
rangers and the
i forgot the name of the other ones that
they had but they had
quite a few of them but new york
wherever we go we've always been meeting
with them to try and to uh bring some
sense of unity what's their reaction to
you when they meet you well usually
since they they know me but
the crips and the blood's there and uh
last time they met me they thought i was
passe you know i talked about hey we've
got to fight oh that's the 60s we're not
fighting no more
but after rodney king they called back
to go we got to fight at it yes we have
to fight what i wanted to ask you about
was this little passage you say so i
said listen you ain't got to do nothing
difficult just some little tactics like
they do in northern ireland
nothing big you know get some gasoline
get some bottles get some rags you know
molotov cocktail is the easiest thing in
the world to do just pour gasoline in
the bottle put the rag in it light the
rag throw it
anything it hits it's got to explode
against it i said when you got to see
the biggest buildings you have in los
angeles put some snipers up there to
keep the police and the army at bay
nothing big you know and then you get
some rubber tires and gather a lot
uh and when the police start coming you
spread out the tires and burn them it
keeps the police at bay you know very
simple things
what's that all about uh it was an
attempt to show that
as a people
we
continue to resist against the enemy but
the resistance is spontaneous and
unorganized
and
we lived through the watch rebellion of
1965
to see the one in 1993 was it here with
rodney king was 1993
and if you look at just like a repeat
performance you know all of them all the
rebellions in this country every last
one of them has occurred over an act of
police terrorism all of them without
every last one of them police terrorism
and always response to these police
terrorism but the response is
spontaneous and
so i was saying we're touching
unorganized people we don't even do
simple things you know like they do in
northern ireland you know it's not big
thing you know burn some rubber tires to
stop cars from coming that's simple you
know it costs nothing but the point was
we don't even think of these simple
little things like that you know molokov
cocktail simple things because once the
rebellion started the snipers went up on
the roofs
the molokaff cocktails were thrown
they looked for the tires to burn so uh
the emphasis was to say let us move from
spontaneity to our organization since
we're going to do it anyway
how far would you go with violence
to bring about the revolution all the
way
all the way what's that what's that mean
uh whatever is necessary whatever it is
uh
in terms of carrying out uh to destroy
the enemy whatever's necessary what will
you say that the revolution is coming
when will it come we don't know that's
the only trouble but it's coming and
what will happen when it comes oh when
it comes there's going to be a real uh
real experience of genuine equality and
democracy
there's going to be a clear
understanding of the needs that
humanity must be at all times and all
conditions be concerned about advancing
humanity
and that all human beings who are
involved in this
aspect of life must make a contribution
to advance humanity and there there's no
question that this is what's going to
happen
what would you want
the result to be
from a revolution how would we see it
change in a country like the united
states well here you would see about
disappearance of the poor
you know you would see a disappearance
of inequalities
you will see redirection of human
energies away from profit
towards
serving humanity
since you first got active in the 60s uh
you hear a lot about the black middle
class
in this country doing well
what's your view of them uh they're not
doing well at all
but uh
they're doing better than those before
them but they're not doing well at all
and i think that's becoming clearer and
clearer to them more than anybody else
uh
the racism inside america i don't know
what uh
uh made anyone think that it had
disappeared you know but i think somehow
unfortunately many of them uh
probably did believe they had they just
disappeared and when they're confronted
with it uh
it uh
it unbalances them to say the least
will the revolution be violent
uh it depends depends upon the uh those
who uh unjustly hold power
and we've never seen them uh
past power you know without struggle
even though they have unjustly acquired
it
is there a place in the world where
socialism communism
um
equality exists
and successfully all right um
let me ask you a question
in a philosophical matter then come to
it practically
uh the error that we make in judging
systems
is that we judge the adherents not the
principles
not too long ago a man came to tell me
that socialism was dead you know so i
told her really
he said yes he said you're still a
socialist i said yes he said why i said
i'm intelligent she said but it's dead
it's buried gorbachev did you hear about
it i said all that i said no
that's not death that's just betrayal
you know
and uh he said what do you mean i said
that socialism cannot die he said no i
saw it these people in russia they gave
it up you know i said no you cannot
judge socialism by socialist
he said what did you say i said you
cannot judge socialism by socialist he's
not mr judge and i said by its
principles
it's only by its principles you couldn't
understand anything so i asked him do
you judge christianity by christians
uh he took a breath here i said no
we judge christianity by principles the
thought deeds words and actions of jesus
christ peace be upon his name that's how
we judge christianity not even by judas
not even by the pope it's just by its
principles so uh socialism
even if it isn't working now will not
deter socialists from striving to arrive
at it
i have been around american churches a
lot in my life and uh to be quite honest
it's difficult for me to find genuine
christians in these churches
but in no way does this diminish my
enthusiasm for christianity and
certainly as a good christian it is my
responsibility to uphold the principles
of christianity amidst all of those who
betray these principles so even if
there's no christian church in the world
i do not believe that it cannot be i
know it will be so i know socialism will
come about to more precisely answer your
question their countries have made a lot
of headway of course we can look at cuba
right south of us here and i just leave
that one as an example
cuba still continues with all of its
problems to occupy itself with the poor
america is the richest country in the
world cuba is the poorest country in the
world but cuba everyone has free
medicine free medical attention even
though it's the poorest country in the
world so it's not a question of money
it's a question of determination and
will to hammer out the injustices in
societies and that's why socialism will
be inevitable because humanity demands
progress instinctively how religious are
you
well uh
not informed but certain spirituality
that is i don't cling to one form i live
in guinea it's a muslim country i've
been living there for years and
i grew up within the christian
background i've been touched by yuroba
of course i've studied all religions in
the world i've studied
the works of
the great buddhist monks i've studied
buddhism i've studied bahism with the
bab so
i've studied all these religions i must
because as an organizer interacting with
people i have to read these books which
they have affected them for so many many
centuries
over such a vast area of the world but
um certainly there is hard put to say
that it's not a creator when one sees
the perfect uh
creation
you know of the earth and even the human
body itself you know so um these are one
of the problems i had as a young man
with uh the theories of marx and
leninism that is accepting atheism was
very bitter for me to accept as a young
man and one of the reasons i hesitated
uh
giving all my energies to these
philosophies go back to the you know
when you're a kid here in
bronze high school you said you met
eugene dennis was that exact name he was
a communist his father was an active
communist can you remember when you saw
something that offended you
about equality back then either then or
when you went to college when was the
first instance or it's difficult many
people asked me this question but um
it's rather difficult
for me the uh
consciousness i've gained has just been
a result of a process rather than any
special or specific events that i could
point to and say this triggered me that
triggered me that triggered well i guess
i would want to know whether it was you
that you were offended by something
somebody did to you or what you saw
happening to others well uh probably
what i saw happening to others in the uh
first instance uh
yeah probably what i saw in the driver's
first instance when did you first notice
when you're active in the student
nonviolent coordinating committee
that the media was paying attention to
you
uh well they made the attention actually
started when i became my chair of snake
in a real serious form
that's the position occupied and that
position called for
public relationships for the
organization so that's the position i
occupied
and
as we said they came along at a time
when we're making a more precise to
struggle and was going from freedom now
to black power or hell no we won't go
and
this was during my uh term as
chairperson for the student nonviolent
committee did you notice that if you did
certain things that it would be
effective in getting attention you'd end
up on the evening news
no no we didn't do things to uh get uh
press attention
um
if you look very carefully you would see
the ratio of snake and the press has
never been very kind
if you go back to the early days you
would see we're always branded as
communist as radicals as ones who
wouldn't listen and
we didn't need the press in our work the
type of work we did was entirely
different from that of
dr martin luther king and his
organization the southern christian
leadership conference they were
mobilizing doing demonstrations we were
organizing so matter of fact they needed
the press we couldn't use the press
if they went to birmingham to have
demonstrations and they wanted the press
to come and cover it so people could see
how brutal uh they were being treated
but if i went into a little town in
mississippi money mississippi where
emmett till was killed and i was trying
to organize that town i couldn't go in
and call a press conference say hey here
i am you know i had to go in quietly and
build a base and uh try to stay as quiet
as possible until the base was strong
enough to be able to protect the people
inside of it but during the vietnam war
when you were hell no we won't go were
you getting a lot of attention then from
yes again we got a lot of attention from
the media but it's because of the
positions we were taken
uh which the press thought would be
positions once exposed to the people
that the people would say oh these
people are crazy but unfortunately once
again it backfired you think they were
doing deliberately covering you because
they thought yes people would say you
were crazy of course they did they they
made the error with malcolm x also
after a while and they caught themselves
they also made the error with us but
jaguar checked it if you would look at
the fbi files he said the press is
making a mistake no more coverage for
them he said it and he corrected the
error you know oh he finally caught it
huh
we've been voting you said on the record
that you think the fbi may have given
you this cancer i'm almost i'm certain
they did i'm sure and they did the fbi
have uh well advanced in uh german
chemical warfare in this country
extremely advanced and uh there's no
question that um
after the assassination of martin luther
king they themselves claimed in their
intelligence magazines that they had to
change the method
of eliminating
what they considered to be leaders
and of course german chemical warfare is
one of the best ways to do it but how
would they have done with you anyhow any
number of ways i mean uh we say just
jokingly that um
if in the 1600s
indians could get smallpox from blankets
by osmosis they'd be able to give us
cancer with the laser beams today
and of course america studies german
chemical warfare does the fbi in your
opinion watch you now all the time
how do you know
oh thanks to the
right white they're having less time for
us
having less time for us what do you mean
by that because the right whites which
were their stabilizing force and the one
they could depend upon to attack us is
now attacking them and attacking them
seriously you know i see white people
with guns in the hands saying we want to
blow off the heads of the fbi
wow you're passing me white man come
back here
i'm supposed to be doing that you know
so uh they've got their hands full there
they can't uh also devote their
attention uh in the 1960s uh the african
community was the major threat
to what uh j edgar hoover and the fbi
considered to be the status quo in the
country but today we're not the major
threat any longer these are the forces
are
how do you know the fbi what sense do
you have what evidence do you have that
they're following you now oh
of course i'll be following them if i
were them
and they would be
as they know
i'm not going to change we have a
program that we've been running since
1974 called smash the fbi and the cia
and our party's been doing just about
alone but they know if our party is
alone we're holding up the banner we're
going to smash them yeah but are they
tapping your phones of course no not
they're more sophisticated they don't
need to do that you know
i used to laugh in the old days in the
south like oh sheriff you're sticking
with the big boomerang mike you know
let's sit down your sheriff's card hold
it out the window to record the mass
meetings they don't need to do that to
their satellites
you know there's just that much advance
anytime you see i remember once years
ago i was passing through germany the
airport they had all these gadgets you
know you could put something in your
telephone go all around the world and
pick it up in your bedroom and the man
next to me said you see that i said if
they're giving this to the public could
you imagine what they have
could you imagine what they have the
intelligence services of the world today
can just about follow anybody they want
to on camera 24 hours a day of that
we're certain
one of the things you you mentioned when
you talk about the
part of your tactics is that you repeat
repeat and repeat your your philosophy
and recently
in pat buchanan's new book
he says that the road to success
requires brute repetition
now are we seeing a pattern here from
both the left and the right and the root
repetition is the success well i
wouldn't use the word brute but uh
certainly a repetition is a means of uh
embedding uh into the mind uh certain uh
aspects of life that you would like to
no question about it what do you repeat
most often the need for evolution
your slogan
ready for ready ready for the revolution
and you yeah they answer the phones here
that way ready for the revolution we're
always ready for it uh
revolution is our only solution
and since we're aware of that we must do
everything possible to create the
conditions to help bring it about but
revolution is permanent now it's not an
event
that's why we say it's a transforming uh
event if you want to see
the best
transformation process in this country
you should look at malcolm x
and you can see how uh what
revolutionary can transform
i mean malcolm x was a pimpu
transformed to be a genuine
revolutionary
so our revolution
does not just transform the conditions
but also transform the individual to
strive to be a better individual to be a
more useful to humanity and more service
to the people who's doing the most
effective job of representing the poor
today
in the united states
well they're not really being properly
represented today
most of their grassroots organizations
have been destroyed by the fbi uh but
these organizations coming back and
we're
looking for them to build a base of
almost irreversibility if you will
that is to say that once they form as
organizations they will not be a
pushback as in the past
um so that uh since the um
middle 70s uh every and anybody has been
representing them and you know the poor
people are so easy to be fooled
you know
if you would the easiest people to fool
are the poor and the powerless
just go and sit down in their little
cabin and have a dinner with them
they'll vote for you for the rest of
your life
they're very easy to be fooled but uh
they become more conscious
uh i remember i'm your age i remember
back in
the 60s that one of the things that you
did was speak a lot
um
and the slogans you're talking about
hell no we won't go and black power all
came through in those speeches did you
have
did you do anything as a speaker
purposely to keep people's attention
no not at all did you train to be a
speaker not at all um
i uh traced my uh early years of uh
speaking uh abilities to uh
125th street here in harlem on the
corner
you had something unique i've only seen
one other place in the world and that's
in the hyde uh hyde park is it in london
you know the street ladder speaker at
125th street when i was a young man 15
16 in my teenage years they used to have
these uh speakers who would get up on
25th street on the ladder and just speak
about africa and about revolution about
nationalism about the need for struggle
and they'd be on those corners and they
attracted my attention and there was a
bookstore there called michoas bookstore
which i spent a lot of my time in and
these attracted my attention my second
grain of speaking came from baptist
preachers in the south
yeah now both of these speakers had
terrible tasks i mean they had burdens
in harlem they would try to speak to
these africans here in the 1950s about
africa
[Laughter]
try and catch their attention they're
trying to go party and it's not talking
about africa so uh you have to be very
sharp and uh
harlem of course is most indisciplined
so once you will get up on a
ladder you're inviting all the
indiscipline elements to attack you
so they have to be very sharp
and in the south uh
here were sharecroppers who picked
cotton you know from sun up to sundown
you know were very tired
on saturday nights they went out to
enjoy themselves and then sunday morning
the preacher had to make enough noise
make them happy enough to give them
election to put money for gas in his
cadillac
so he had a lot of work to do and
i got my two strains of early speaking
from these uh my my early speaking from
these two strains the uh nationalist
speaker in harlem and the delta preacher
himself of course later on on their uh
kwame nkrum and certainly on the
secretary i would develop more and more
revolutionary uh speaking patterns
can you remember back in the 60s the
biggest audience you ever spoke to
or can you remember a speech that had
a particular impact on the country
i can't
i can't think maybe berkeley
maybe the berkeley speech in terms of
the relationship between uh white
liberals and africans we started out
probably clearly there at the berkeley
speech
i remember that might be 1966 1967. did
you write your speeches no
uh
snick would write uh some of them when
we had to present positions
and then the snake people would outline
the positions and from the positions
outlined by snick i would develop the
speeches did you ever notice a certain
length of a speech that mattered more
than others could you talk too long no
not at all um overall i've
no i'm not a long-winded speaker
what about the famous and i say famous
because it's written about several times
carmichael grinn
do you know you're doing that
uh no it's really uh it's really natural
uh it's natural
that's really natural yeah who are you
more like there your mother your father
my father
a father
and what your father died in 1961 62.
and your mother's still alive living in
florida kicking hard just like all the
women kill off the men i tell you you
kill off our men and then you all enjoy
life
kill my poor father now you're enjoying
life and what is your family that still
lives here the four sisters and all
think of what you're doing well uh my
sisters have always given me full
support uh in every aspect of my life
which i'm very grateful
and um
even if i disagree with me uh
politically they've never let that
affect our relationships
and what do you want people to remember
about stokely carmichael kwame turi
just another human being just another
brother on the corner doing more that's
what they all do
maintaining the struggle upholding
integrity
thank you for your time thank you ready
for evolution
for more information contact the kwame
toure medical fund in care of the black
united fund of illinois 2302 east 71st
street chicago illinois 60649
american perspectives continues in a
moment with former congressman robert
walker
if you'd like a vhs videotape of this or
any american perspectives program call
one eight hundred cspan 98 full campaign
then we'll hear comments from 1996
presidential candidate steve forbes
road to the white house sunday evening
at 7 eastern and pacific here on c-span
now from new york a memorial service for
kwame toure
last weekend the civil rights leader
formerly known as stokely carmichael was
remembered in a ceremony attended by
relatives friends and former co-workers
speakers of the event included nation of
islam leader louis farrakhan this event
runs about two hours
[Applause]
brothers and sisters
on behalf
of the officers
staff and members
of the riverside church
i bid you welcome
this afternoon
this place
has been dedicated to justice
from the laying of the first cornerstone
even until now
and across the years
champions for justice from around the
world
have come into this place
and have found hospitality
and a greeting of love and respect
in this place
even before it was popular
oliver tombow while still being
considered a rebel
was welcomed in this place
dr martin luther
[Applause]
[Music]
dr martin luther king jr
while he was challenging the war in
vietnam was welcomed
in this place
and
when nelson mandela
had finally
stood the test
and had come forth in victory when he
came to the united states first after
being released from prison
was welcomed with a tumultuous adoration
and praise for the work that he had done
so now you see
it is so fitting that on this occasion
another champion
who fought in the context of the civil
rights struggle
at a time when it was barely
imaginable that there could be a cry
black power
he made that cry into
a slogan for a determination for justice
not just
sentimentality but justice with full
economic political liberty for all
so this day is no different we continue
to celebrate and i trust that all of you
who have come here today
will know
that if your cause is justice for all
humankind
this is the right hour and this is the
right place and we have before us a
focus of one whose life was dedicated to
that end that all god's children not
just some not just a few of a particular
hue but that all god's children would
have power peace and love i would like
to say to you that in the early days
many of us
when stokely carmichael was the time and
the name
we often thought that's too radical
that's too rough
but think about it what would the
struggle have yielded if in addition to
all of the other things achieved there
was no sense of self-determination
no sense of power no sense of
participation without any compromise i
therefore having at first said stokely
too strong
i joined with king stokely it won't be
good
but now in retrospect with the
dismantling of affirmative action with
the rolling away of gains made in the
civil rights movement surely the issue
of power
is at the heart of the struggle and for
that reason we celebrate this life let
me say to you then that the program this
afternoon we'll move along
we see the names i will sit here and if
there's somebody who is not present i'll
help move it along but we're going to
follow this program as it has been
printed or as the orisha
augments our program planning with
unscheduled visitation
let me
say my word of tribute then and then the
program will proceed i want to give
thanks to stokely carmichael
to
kwame to ray
for
inserting into the struggle
the evidence that black and power are
not oxymorons they belong together and
thank him
i would like to say that remember the
good old days in the civil rights
movement when we used to join hands and
sing we shall overcome
and at that time stokely called michael
says there's got to be more than
swinging and swaying and carrying on
there's got to be some power to that so
in a sense i suspect that this poem is a
sort of inspiration from the person we
have come to celebrate today and with
this i close my opening remarks
it says we shall overcome has got to be
more than a freedom song
it's joining hands across the land for
children safe and strong
we shall overcome it's got to be more
than a memory
it's a new resolve to get involved in
building community
we shall overcome it's got to be more
than a protest song it's a loving vow to
learn somehow we all can get along we
shall overcome it's got to be more than
a distant plan
it's housing health and jobs right now
it's time to hope again we shall
overcome it's got to be more than a
fervent prayer it's sacrificed at any
price to show them that we care we shall
overcome it's got to be more than a
state of mind it's faith in god and
working hard to leave no child behind oh
there's a place for everyone let us face
the rising sun
then
we shall overcome may the program begin
do
[Music]
yay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is as it has been for centuries
when one leader is gone
another has been born
today we are talking
of a man who never died
who will never die
the ground that eats flesh
never eats his name
no one has a name
unless you work for it
with blessings of the ancestors
with the good work of the mother
this is the water that grows the flower
kwame toure
these two names symbolize to us the real
creation of god
of day
of night
touri is not unknown
in africa
kwame toure is not an unknown person to
africa and africa's descent
[Music]
today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they swore on their lives africa would
be free
summary fought against colonization for
33 years
so that no other nation would claim to
own any piece of africa that was the
desire of kwame nkrumah
that was the desire of al-fayaya
that was the desire of
sunyata keta of the four families of the
cheddar warriors
this legacy means africa is too
important
too big to give away
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
has continued the work of the ancestors
we believe kwame toure is one of the
protectors of our race and our land
believe in god
believe in the ancestors
believe in each other
kwame toure's legacy is passed on to all
of us
so that we may continue
their work
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well good afternoon
i want to thank all of you
it's been a
long
long planning
event
and it's finally arrived
and so we're delighted that you're here
to share with us
kwame's
life some time ago when we were making
calls about this event
i could tell in the voice of some people
they were saying do we need another
memorial
and what we were trying to say
was that we wanted to have an
opportunity
to reflect upon our brother's life
in a fashion
that would be complementary
to those other memorial services that
have been held
and so we hope today to
share with you
some of those personal
remembrances
that we have of kwame
one of the things that
kwame did before he
left the country
he agreed that howard university would
be the
archival for his papers and other
materials
he
held
in great affection the institution
and that he indicated
to the moreland spingon research center
in writing that they would
be the repository of all of his papers
and so i would encourage you those of
you who have
memorabilia
to make your own photocopies
and send the
either the photocopier or the original
to howard university
so that there will be an archive of his
materials
at that institution
also as many of you may know kwame
was preparing a book
that book hopefully
will
um
be published and released
if not the end of this year
certainly the beginning of of next year
and we're all
very anxious to
have an opportunity to read
his own reflections
of his life
as well
you may also know that
three weeks after kwame became ill a
group of us came together and formed a
medical fund
the purpose of that fund was to try and
address
kwame's
medical expenses
and we have trying to do that as best as
we know how
we plan to go out of business
come march one
there really is no need for us to be in
business any longer
and so we're hoping to use the the time
that remains between now and march 1
to address the expenses that remain
and then
go out of business
this was not a position that i
wanted
but i think it was a position that was
needed
because what we really wanted
juani to do is to focus on his health
and not have to be concerned about
his medical expenses
or whether or not he could afford to
have one type of treatment
or another
and so we tried to take that burden off
of him
so that he could focus
on his medical
situation
we passed out
today a and a a statement that kwame
made back in february
of 1998
it's about prostate cancer
and that we truly hope that you all of
you will take time to read
that article
or that statement really
and for those of us who are over 40
we should be guided by his remarks
there will be a couple of insertions in
the program
today
because we wanted very much to have this
as a personal remembrance
we thought that it would be that you
would want to hear from his personal
physician
and so the speaker that will follow me
will be dr barbara justice
his personal
physician there will also be
announcements
and there will also be acknowledgements
they will come
much later
in the program
i think if there's anything that i will
miss about kwame
it will of course be his smile
his laughter
and that finger
they would always wave at you
i will never forget that
i will always remember it
thank you very much
hotep
and greetings to you all
to mother carmichael
we love you
the family
and friends
we bring all our support
and everything that we have for you
spiritually
we want you to know that you're always
surrounded by that
you know
each
life that comes into the world
has equal importance
and our brother taught us that
to have respect for all living beings
but some of those spirits
grow
greatly
some of those spirits are old spirits
some of those spirits turn into raging
fires
and they cross continents
and they take over entire country just
like it's their neighborhood block
when you see someone with that spirit
you know
as soon as you walk into the room with
that person you know
you hear the voice
you see the clarity of the thought
and you feel the love and courage that
emanates from that spirit
that spirit
walks with very large footsteps
that
was and is our brother kwame toure
the love and the courage that he had
the clarity of thought
the direction and the leadership that he
provided for us all
will not go in vain
the vessel that contained him
was only temporary
but the spirit is eternal
and that spirit
which has lived through the ages will
live again
i had a very unique relationship
with brother kwame toure
i was honored and blessed
by allah
and by the ancestors
to be
the head of the medical team and i took
care of kwame actually
years before he had this he had this
diagnosis so we made this diagnosis with
prostate cancer
so i got to know him over time
trying to be
the doctor and healer of principle
and of insight into the genocide of this
world
and at the same time
to remain an african woman
and nurturer and
healer so i was fortunate enough to go
to tunisia with brother kwame to go to
libya
and later to go to cuba and spend a
great deal of time there with him
i was also
given the blessing and the burden
of shepherding the shepherd through the
final days of his illness
how do you shepherd the shepherd
that was the question for me
how do you shepherd the shepherd
and it's only by having watched
this tremendous
courageous brother
that i learned
that what you do is you walk tall
you stay true to your heart and your
soul
you love humanity
although you're critical of its wrongs
you put your life on the line for your
brothers and sisters and for those who
are to come
healed me
of doubts that i might have had of
weaknesses i might have had
kwami made me stronger
he made me
able to recommit
and to walk taller
we love our brother kwame he'll always
be with us
the vessel of his body just was not big
enough to hold him
and we love you mother caller michael
for bringing to us thank you
[Applause]
to our
to our um
to our
to our friends
to our friends of kwame to ray kami to
ray was a strong african he was
he
he will always
you always that
he will always be a good man to us
he was the first bright light he is our
friend he gave us the idea to be bright
lights
want me to to us to get knowledge and
share it with others
he was a great african who helped us
african children
he taught us to
to get knowledge and to read for
knowledge that leads to power he told us
to do that every day until we die
he gave us the courage to
he gave us the
he gave us the confidence to be bright
lights a bright light
a bright light reads gets knowledge and
shares it with others apply light also
lights up dark corners
juan mata ray was an honest man juan
monterey was never a follower he always
lived
kwame toure loved every bright light
in
whittier and pierce schools
in philadelphia we love him
when he came to our school
he bought he bought love
and when the bright lights came to new
york
to see to see him he was proud of us
he helped many
he helped many africans get knowledge
and be proud of our haircut
he gave he gave us
the idea that
we could go to africa too
we surprised him with
we surprised him with our determination
our skill raising money and
the success of our trips we know that
when we went he always smiled with that
big great smile
he made us confident
that we could make a difference in our
community
he worked to put justice in the world
our journey is to continue what he
started
our promise was to continue the journey
we take we take the light that kwame
toure sent to us we will make the light
we have
the responsibility
to me
you know we have the responsibility
to make
a difference in people's lives
we will honor him
by always working hard to
to improve
for
all of eternity
our lights are on and bright we must
pass it down thank you kwame to ray
refill your light
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
like
[Applause]
we would like to present my move with
these special flowers and bright light
bright light badge
we thank you for
having kwame to write and if it wasn't
for her it wouldn't be bright lights
[Applause]
we would like to present my move with
these special flowers and bright light
bright light badge
we thank you for
having kwame to write and if it wasn't
for her it wouldn't be bright lights
[Applause]
so
[Music]
for all the years
kwame
known to stokely
known as kwami
all those years that we walked and
talked together
[Music]
the right hands
the right hands of slavery
reaches inside the drone
the white hands of slavery reaches
inside the drum
the drum
the drum being our way
be in the way
[Music]
of calling for a civilization in time
butts moving
legs stomping
feet flying
between
dimensions
the right hands of slavery transported
the dreams
and drums
the right hands of slavery transported
the dreams
and drums
the dreams and drums of us across an
ocean of blood
into islands and colonies of greed
dreams
and drums
dreams
and drums
nations are built
on dreams
nations are built from dreams
if you wake up
if you wake up
nations are built from drums
nations are built from dreams if you
wake up if you wake up
the drum has a right to wake you up
the drop
the drum
[Music]
the drum being
touch
the drum being touch
the drum can smash your face
the drum can
touch
the drum being touch can destroy the
inside of talk
the drum being touch
can build the inside of why we exist
the drum
the drum is touch
the drum is low
the drum is all right
kwami torre
is our drum
kwami tori is our right
kwame tori is touch
is love is black power is africa is
african peoples
is calling us it's screaming at us it's
whispering to us it's rising up wake up
get up wake up move up
screaming it up
whispering to us
rising up
wake up
get up
move up
organize
organize organize organized
ready
ready
ready
ready
ready for the revolution
ready
ready
ready for the revolution comrade
ready for the revolution sister
ready for the revolution brother
[Music]
ready for the revolution brotherhood
ready for the revolution sisterhood
ready for the revolution mankind ready
for the revolution humankind
ready
ready
[Music]
ready
ready for the revolution
the revolution ready
the revolution
the revolution
[Music]
the revolution
ready
[Music]
ready
for the revolution
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we stand up and robby singers will be
coming
[Music]
[Music]
oh is
[Music]
[Music]
is
save
us
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
oh
overshot it
it's okay
thank you
i have such a loud booming voice i
actually don't need a microphone
when i was working with the people who
pulled this together one of the things
that i
was rather insistent on was
placing carmichael uh my friends
kwame toure but known to me as stokely
as a student at howard because i think
it's important for young people to
understand
that
he came from
ordinary
circumstances
a mother who worked very hard i knew
about his mother working in ships
before i knew anything else about his
family and i knew that he had tremendous
respect for his mother
and i knew another thing i knew that he
was very serious about getting knowledge
when i walked into
a meeting of the
action group in the winter of 1961
it's a room full of people it must have
been about 150 people in that room
representing students from all across
the city of washington dc
but i will tell you one person
burned brightly in that room
and that was stokely carmichael
we were having a demonstration
the next day at the justice department
and he identified me as the person who
was going to do the communications
my first meeting
he said don't worry i will teach you
and by six o'clock in the morning the
next day
because he had taught me through the
night
who to call how to talk what to say
how to say it
by six o'clock in the morning the next
day
i was on the phone delivering our
statement to mr john dore at the justice
department what we were demanding from
our student base at howard university
i want to encourage people
to understand the leadership is in fact
you know the
the combination of a belief
and determination
and that
epitomizes that
but within all of us
our leadership capabilities
and it would be
a real sad legacy
if from his burning bush
others would not stand to take his place
as time moves on the demands on our
population are increasing
you know he raised with us the issue of
africans being an african people being
pan-africanists well when i was in
howard university
to be known as an african was not
considered a very good thing
there were only three of us who took
african studies
in the entire university
and i can name them doreen jackson
myself and a young man from africa named
apophium and we took all of the courses
together
out of a class of entering class of 1500
students
i can tell you too that out of the
grouping of people there were only two
black women probably in the united
states in 1961 who wore their hair
unprocessed
mary felice lovelace and her good friend
muriel tilikas
[Applause]
because mary said to me one day muriel
please don't press your hair
i need somebody to be with me people
stare at me all the time
so when i went to the hairdresser that
day i said
after you wash my hair do nothing and my
hairdresser thought i had lost my mind
okay
and over time people began to understand
and we didn't wear our hair
as a statement of fashion
we wore our hair as a statement of
determination and political
understanding
and in many ways it was fashioned after
the kukuyu women
of kenya
who were shaven head
and they were the kokuyo's who raised
the issue in
kenya about african land run by african
people
so i want you to understand that this
brother has been a bridge
from the past into the future
but you are to walk across the bridge
you are not to just acknowledge that
there's a bridge oh how lovely the
bridge is
oh and tell your your children about the
bridge that you once knew you are to
travel across that bridge you are to
learn every day and when i heard someone
saying that
you must learn something new every day
my grandmother said that
you know my grandmother belonged to many
organizations we come out of a tradition
where our people were engaged in the
betterment of our community i mean that
is the stone that you touch how you
choose to do that is of your choice but
that you must move that you must make
the choice that you must improve and
that you must bring others with you that
is your promise
and so i wanted to tell you a couple of
things about
the person that i knew as a student at
howard first of all i want you to know
that he had a contagious personality
you either loved him or you hated him
there was nobody in between and in most
cases mr carmichael was determined that
you were going to love him because he
was going to meet you on your ground
i remember teachers like sterling brown
who said to me one day in the black
theater class because he knew that i was
gazing off into the mist he said come on
child
come on come michael i'm going to take
you to the theater i want to show you
something and we went to the circle in
the square
and one in washington dc
and there we met a number of people who
are now stars who were just beginning
working in a small
operation
and he began to talk about what theater
was and what culture was and how it was
important to transmit certain
information to your
your community and how that's not always
possible to do by lecture a lot of times
it's important to do it by singing so
when i went to mississippi and i
understood how in these small churches
sometimes surrounded by white hate
someone would start off key
singing a song
that said we are together
we are connected we are one and we will
move from this place this day
i want you to
understand and just a couple of other
things about carmichael he understood
power he understood it in innately
when we were at howard
we were pretty isolated in some ways and
one of the things he said you know we
need to take over the school newspaper
because the school newspaper is the
vehicle that explains to the student
population what's going on on the campus
and at that point and i won't
put him in a particular light at this
point but let's just say that the
brother at that point in time did not
have a good understanding so the nag
meetings in some cases just took place
in the editor's office of the student
newspaper
and we made a point of making
one mr michael felwell come to
understand and to know
that nag was on the campus
that nag was going to investigate the
construction do you remember that the
construction of various buildings that
had white only craftsmen on those
buildings this was a black campus that
we were going to raise the human cry
that black people had to be responsible
all the way down the pike and who was
leading that brigade
call me to ray no question about it and
you see when i say that he met you on
your own turf as opposed to
mr um the editor whose name has now
escaped me moving against him he met him
with argument on argument and he was
convincing because he had information
not anger
information and information is what
brings people to you and along with you
so those are some of the reflections
that i have on this wonderful person who
is now transcended and i'm hopeful that
you will be serious in terms of
understanding that your knowledge of him
is a touchstone that you are now
responsible for passing the information
forward thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
my name is bob zellner and i'm a former
stick worker
and i think it's very uh
appropriate that muriel telling has
said that stokely carmichael kwame toure
would meet you on your own turf
because i came from l.a
lower alabama
and stokely not only met me on my own
turf he changed it forever
i i come from
a southern background of course
my father was a member of the ku klux
klan
and my grandfather was a member of the
ku klux klan
so if stokely carmichael swami toure
could meet me on my own turf he could
meet anybody in the world
and i know he could meet anybody in the
next world on their own turf he could
deal with it
i want to say a few things about stokely
carmichael kwame toure
that are probably not
i want to remember
the person that people love to be with
stokely was the kind of person that
people gravitated to him
we have to remember that with all of his
profundity and all of his teaching
stokely carmichael kwame toure was funny
he was also
he was also wherever the action was
i remember in the summer of 64
when snick was locating its headquarters
in green
greenwood mississippi
stokely had been running things in
greenwood
and things were picking up so much that
he spent almost all his time
in the more dangerous areas
greenwood as bad as it was was already
considered a liberated area
so after the initial events of the
summer of 64
when i went to try to investigate the
murders of our civil rights workers in
philadelphia mississippi
i wound up in greenwood because my wife
dottie
miller zellner at the time was working
with
julian in the
communications department so i found
myself in greenwood for the rest of that
summer
and stokely was
going out every day
to organize tallahatchie county and all
the outlying counties and so finally
foreman said well somebody has to run
things here for a little while so
zellner you don't have anything else to
do
you run them for a while here in
greenwood
so for a part of that summer i was the
acting project director in greenwood
mississippi
and i was able to see the effect that
stokely guamitore had on the young
people in greenwood
and the effect that he later had on
people in my own state of alabama
stokely carmichael kwame toure
perfected
and practiced
the theory and practice of revolutionary
suicide
he was so uncompromising that he said
i personally will die before i will live
with this system
but also he was human enough
not to be a martyr not to want to be a
martyr deliberately
but sometimes you wondered in watching
stokely carmichael kwame toure
if he wouldn't step right over that line
because he would press a southern
sheriff
he would call him all kinds of names
he'd talk about his mother
in front of people
especially in front of african-american
alabamians
and you'd wonder how is that man going
to survive this day
but stoke with carmichael kwame toure
knew what he was doing in lowndes county
he knew what he was doing in la flora
county in tallahatchie county in
mississippi
he was taking that fear
the fear of centuries and removing it
surgically
saying i put my life on the line
we put our lives on the line so you can
no longer practice the oppression that
you've been practicing we refuse anymore
to cooperate
with our own oppression
he was a freedom fighter
[Applause]
[Music]
stokley was a freedom fighter to the
very end
uh recently many of us had the
opportunity to be in
washington
at a a memorial service or a remembrance
of
of stokely carmichael fuemiture where he
participated
the luminous quality of his leadership
was no
was never so apparent as it was there
with a
whole array of leaders from around the
country from one end of the spectrum to
the other and stokely said we have to
come together to finish the unfinished
revolution
he was with the revolution until the
very end
i recently was asked to write
a small remembrance of stokely
carmichael kwame toure for newsday
newspaper in long island where i now
live and teach history of the civil
rights movement and i tried to think of
all the things that i could think of
stokely and i kept thinking of these
small things and the one of the small
things was what i run into as a history
teacher
one of the things that stokely is kwame
ture is mostly known for
is his statement about the position of
women in snik
it's unfortunate
that that is the one thing that people
know stokely for in the broad population
so this is why it's necessary for us as
bringers of the truth and teachers of
the truth is to bring and correct some
of those misapprehensions that's
shorthanded
[Music]
many of the people for instance who
criticized uh stokely carmichael kwame
in his last days and after his recent
death
if they had ever walked one day in his
shoes if they had ever put themselves on
the line we would take what they say
with a little more song or a little less
salt
they they didn't know where the man came
from they didn't know where the movement
came from and the very idea that they
would take stokely's very humorous
comment remember i said he was funny he
was always rapping he was always right
on the on the edge of
hilarious humor and also insight
so when he talked about the position of
women we can't obscure the fact that
women played a major role in the civil
rights movement and continue to do so
uh andy young recently said uh
one time not too long ago said on
television that all of the leaders of
the civil rights movement were ministers
did that include ella baker fannie lou
hamer
ruby dar smith
diane nash
muriel tillinghouse
september clark
rosa parks
the leaders of the movement were
grassroots people
and stokely was of the people kwame
toure was of the people when i recently
asked him if he would participate in a
suit that we were bringing against
mississippi of the sovereignty
commission suit
stokely
in all of his power and all of his glory
of his last days said i will be there
with you in this suit i would be the
lead
plaintiff in the suit against the
mississippi sovereignty commission
so stokely was true to revolution to the
end he was ready for revolution
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
so
i want to read a poem
[Applause]
interesting i think that
one of the things that
kwame always held to was a black
humanity front how necessary that is
and i just want to say the black radical
congress
has been meeting for the last year and a
half
uh 122 west 27th street 2127
saying that because i don't want us to
just be flapping our gums
when the news of
kwame's
passing
came to me i looked through
some of my
mountainous
collection of things
and came up with a photograph of
leroy howard and stokely
who later became a midi owusu
and kwame
it's interesting because in this film
this flick here we thought that we would
win by probably next week we thought
maybe
10 days
maybe 12 before we whip these people
into submission
a protracted struggle
is called understanding readiness
um
we want to know
how do we understand readiness
for kwame toure
who was stokely carmichael
how do we know who we are
except in the world
going through it together
how do we know where we are
except with each other
facing reality like god straining on a
leash
how do we know who are our friends and
who are our enemies
[Music]
only by what they do
who they hold on to
who they fight for and support
who they help who they feed in the storm
whose side they're on
how do we know who can lead
only by seeing them do it
only by feeling the realness and
hopefulness their sincerity and courage
only by touching their love for the
actual selves of us
only by their suffering in our name
the jailings the beatings and torture
only by the way our enemies describe
them
only by their wisdom and plans their
affirmations their pronouncements and
positions what they think and move on
what direction they give us to transform
our slave conditions
can we name those who are our heroes
yes if we are conscious even when they
are still alive
who is it that will take this brother's
place
all of those who understand what his
life was
what he wanted what he did and who in
the end he looked to us comrades and
struggle whatever their names or
philosophies or ideologies or uniforms
or preparation
all who want democracy and freedom
how do we know we must struggle
how do we know
is that why we are here to listen again
to see again to feel again
can we still ask the brother we
celebrate whom we loved whom we still
desire to lift us with his transforming
fire
we know if we call his name he will come
but what do we need him now to do that
he has not already done
we need him with us because he is part
of us now
part of our consciousness and feeling in
history
we need him now because without him we
are not whole nor will we go anywhere
but backward which he would never do
how do we speak to him now
in our love our understanding our
developed consciousness
we speak to him with our acts
with our commitment
with facts with our unyielding will and
struggle to be free our
self-determination our sole deep pledge
to help unite and liberate oppressed
people everywhere with the same
fierceness we fight for pan-africa
africa for american nation is that clear
and what
is this brother's name
organizer
black panther
lowndes county
snake
black power
black united front
pan-africa increments scientific
socialists ready for the revolution
undying love for the people all african
people's revolutionary party starkly
carmichael kwame toure comrade warrior
ideologue thinker revolutionary leader
hero hero
my man my main man my brother our dear
brother our dear brother
thank you
[Applause]
and now brothers and sisters
i want to present to you
a person who does not need an
introduction anywhere in the world
because of his visibility for the cause
of justice
and therefore
i say that although today has been a
very busy busy day for minister
farrakhan
who has spoken several locations
throughout the city and will move from
here to continue his speaking in the
city will you please receive now
minister the honorable minister farah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the name of allah the beneficent the
merciful
we give him praise and thanks
for his goodness and his mercy
his goodness and his mercy is seen
by his bringing into the world
from the womb of women
those men and women
who will dedicate their lives
to the process of
development
human perfection
i thank allah for moses and the torah
for jesus
and the god
muhammad and the quran peace be upon
these worthy servants of allah
as a student of the most honorable
elijah muhammad
i could never thank allah enough
for his intervention in our affairs
raising up from among us
one to lead teach and guide us in the
person of
the most honorable elijah muhammad
i greet all of you my dear brothers and
sisters
and those who have come to honor the
memory
of our wonderful brother
i greet all of you with the greeting
words of peace
to the reverend dr forbes
rev gentilly
to all of those who have been up
of this program
to the mother
of our
and to brother david brothers
i am more than honored
to be here to pay respect
to a man
that
i see unfortunately
greater now
i saw him
some months ago and years ago it is
life
i one day
when dr king had passed away and
i was watching on television and tears
were in my eyes
and we in the nation of islam were at
odds with the direction of dr king
but we loved him as a brother
but now he's gone
and i find myself
weeping
and so i went to the honorable elijah
muhammad and i said why is it
that we always seem to wait
until someone leaves us
to recognize their tremendous
value
to us
and he said
these words he says
brother while the testator lives
he is writing
his testament
but when death comes it puts a period
to his testament
then the historians can come
and gather up
every aspect of his life
and assign him
his place
in history
in truth
nobody gets their reward while they live
in truth
we get our greatest reward
after we are gone and i tried to ask
myself why is this
and in my study of the holy quran
when god is going to raise an individual
or
a nation to eminence
they must learn
how to handle praise
they must learn how to handle the honor
of the people they must learn how to
handle the adulation
of the people and so
allah knew he was going to raise
muhammad peace be upon him
and the nation of islam 1400 years ago
to eminence so the first verse of the
quran
was
all praise
belongs to god
for he is the lord the nourisher the
sustainer and the evolver
of us
making us attain stage after stage until
we reach our eventual perfection
none of our gifts are really ours
we are descendants
from our mothers from our fathers from
our ancestors and the genetic
coding
that is a part of our very being
if we are placed in the right
environment that nurtures what god has
placed within
then we burst
like seeds placed in the proper earth
with proper water and sunshine and we
send a route down
into the knowledge of history and then
we spring off and blossom to make
manifest what god has put within us
in the bible
john
said that
is
love
now i don't know what you think about
that scripture and how that has
relevance to
the kwame
but
if you look at the english construction
of that sentence god would be the
subject is would be the verb
to be
and love would be the predicate
nominative
the predicate nominative is equal to the
subject so is
is like an equal sign what is on this
side
is born witness to on that side so when
you say god
is love you're saying that god equals
love love
is of god
well
we usually define love as this emotional
feeling this tender warmth that we have
toward someone that is close to us and
we say we love you
but that's not the love
that we yet are talking about we're
talking about that
powerful creative force
out of which everything we see has come
into being so when you say god is love
that means god
is the force the power the creative
force of love out of which all creation
comes into existence
i used to always talk about love love
love and one day the honorable elijah
muhammad asked me to define it
and i came up with a weak
definition
that i got from webster
he's all right
but the honorable elijah muhammad
is
comprised of three
essential principles of life
freedom
justice
equality
if you tell me you love
then you have to be
for the freedom of every human being
you have to want every human being to
justify their existence that they can be
equal before god
and man
so no man that deprives another of
freedom can say they're a lover
no human being that deprives another of
justice can be a true lover so since god
is love love is rooted in these basic
principles of freedom justice and
equality when i look at my brother kwame
i see love
personified
i was blessed
to meet this brother
in a day of love
i didn't know
our brother kwame i
heard him
saying black power
handsome brother articulate
and when he came to boston where i was
ministering
i went out to meet my brother and we
hung out
on that day and we became
friends
kwame took the political path and i took
the spiritual path and but kwame was
both spiritual and political
kwame
was a political giant
he studied
under masters kwame
uh nkrumah seku toure
he was a voracious reader
and as a voracious reader his command of
principles
was without
peer
i not only loved my brother
but i admired him
and when i think about kwame
i think about a verse in the quran
that says
speak not of those
who die
or are slain in the way of god as dead
they are alive
but you understand not
the question before us is did kwame
work
in the way of god
did he live
his life
in the way of god and did he die in
service to the way of god but many of us
who are quote unquote religious
you may say well kwame never joined
our church
kwame never joined our mosque kwame
never said he was in fact a religious
person
but
was the
quintessential
manifestation of what real true religion
is about
true religion is about not coming to
church with our hands held in this
beautiful manner looking holier than
thou taking the sacrifice and going out
into a world of human beings who are
suffering and doing nothing to alleviate
that suffering yet we say we're
religious men we're religious women no
no we're not
we don't understand that the life force
of religion is never seen in the singing
of songs
the life force of religion is never seen
in the good preaching
the life force of religion is seen in
the transformation
people's lives and in the life of the
society or the nation of the world kwame
was interested and a fighter for the
transformation of human life
he's a better creature than most
he used to get angry with me sometimes
he's very smart brother boy
kwame you know he loved this united
front once this united front that was
all that he
focused on the united front well he knew
that the honorable elijah muhammad had a
big headline in the old muhammad speaks
let us form a black united front so he
came to me one day and he said fair khan
do you think that is right that we
should have
a united front well if i had said no
he was prepared to pull out this paper
you know
so i said of course we should he said
well the reason i'm here brother
is because i believe you are the man at
this time to bring that about
well i didn't really think that i was
the man at that time but kwame thought
so and i respected his judgment and he
took me to john jacobs
of the urban league and he made sure
that i met with ben hooks of the naacp
and it really looked like maybe it was
time
that we could form this united front but
there are forces in america
that don't want to see a united front of
oppressed people
so that through our unity we could
address our needs and address the
oppressor and address the oppression in
a way that we can relieve ourselves and
pass on to unborn generations the legacy
of freedom
of justice and of equity
well i did something that he didn't like
i was in atlanta
why are you talking like this fair condo
well i want to talk about my brother
and he really
was and is my brother
and brothers will take you to task
when they think you're wrong
brothers who love you
and love the revolution
if i may put it in the language of kwame
was always ready for the revolution
those who love
the people more than they love
individuals will always address
individuals when individuals fail the
people
brother kwame
came to me
i was in atlanta
and reverend jackson had done some great
thing he had seven
million votes
we were going to the convention not i
but jesse was
and then the reverend jackson said well
you know
when a man
picks the cotton
and bales the cotton
you ought to be at least invited into
the big house to count the cotton
well i didn't kind of like
that expression because to me it sounded
like he was working for the master
and got upset because massa didn't let
him in the house to count the votes
so i kind of
talked to my brother in a brotherly way
and stokely called me a kwame called me
and said brother
i got to teach you
the way of dr martin luther king
i said what do you mean brother
he said dr king was non-violent you
can't produce a united front upgrading
the brother like that
[Music]
so we argued on the phone
that
for a little while
we were estranged just shortly
but i know my brother
and i know that this man
more than most of our time
one of the most consistent men
for the struggle of our people
if you want to know what love looks like
let's look at kwame
started off loving
black people
for me ended up loving humanity
kwame wanted to see
a fair distribution of the wealth
that the masses of the people
might share
in the richness of the earth out of
which we came and to which we will
return but while we're on the earth it
is a sin that a small percentage of
human beings should own the majority of
the wealth which really belongs to all
of us
[Applause]
[Music]
swami
was always fighting for a higher
principle
did not die
leaving a lot of money
[Music]
for family members to fight over
remind for the great leaders
[Laughter]
left us the greatest legacy of all
it was his life and his will
to see people free
i thank allah for the life of my brother
i thank allah for his precious mother
and her womb
that produced this giant
his mother from the caribbean from
trinidad
my mother from the tiny island of saint
kids
but i'm not talking about the womb of
these two mothers that made kwame and i
brothers
but most of you in this audience are
people who struggle for change people
that are here today to honor this man
are people that want to see the masses
lifted
so your life
is a mirror or a reflection
of
his
life
kwame
kwame lived
his life
but kwame came from a bigger womb
than the womb of his mother
kwame came from the womb
of time
and the longing of human beings to be
free
and when that wound produces a child
that child could be moses that child
could be jesus that child could be
muhammad that child could be kwame in
puma that child could be mao tomo fidel
castro or amiri baraka that child is you
and me who come from the biggest womb of
all the womb that produces those who
struggle
to make life better for all humanity
and so
when i made a lover
kwame the man
of freedom of justice of equality
kwame the man that fought all his life
for the betterment of the little people
who found it difficult to fight
for themselves kwame the organizer kwame
the teacher kwame the guide kwame
the brother
i love my brother
and i miss
him
but i know the only thing we can do to
pay adequate honor to kwame
is to keep on struggling
to make humanity
free
keep on struggling
to make our people free
keep on struggling
to make
a nation
like america
what america should be
america is a long way from what she
should be but it's men who struggle
women who struggle
who are the best friends
of this nation
i thank you dr forbes
for allowing this beautiful
remembrance of our dear brother to come
from these hallowed halls
this great magnificent edifice
which martin luther king spoke at with a
time at a time when people were
frightened of dr king because he was
standing up against the wall in vietnam
this house has been a house that stands
for change and stands for good and
stands for what is in the best interest
of the people so it's no wonder that dr
forbes and
his associates would allow this day
to be in honor
of a giant that walked
and still walks
among us
we don't see his face
we don't see
his beautiful smile
but now we can deal with kwame
more than the smile more than the words
his manner
we can deal with kwame's mind
as it reflects in his words and in the
legacy of his life and when his true
story is really told
the little children that are here
tonight
will pick up the mantle of kwame toure
and march on
to victory for me
is not dead
guamay
is alive and those of us who love him
and those of us who continue to struggle
for
freedom justice and equality
may allah bless
his mother
and comfort her
and his family and sisters
his children and son
may allah bless the son
to walk in the footsteps
of his illustrious father
his father taught us that life is not
closed life is not cause
life is not money in the bank
life and love
is the same word
the i is interchangeable with the o and
the v is interchangeable with the f if
you have life you have love if you have
love you have life don't mean if you
have money you have life if you have
money you have love if you have love
you have life kwame loves
kwame lives
kwame walked in the way of god so speak
not of those who die or are slain in the
way of god as dead he and they are alive
but we understand not
thank you for allowing me these precious
moments to reflect
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
uh ladies and gentlemen we have made
another insertion in our program
uh we
among the things that we're attempting
to do obviously is to
raise
some funds to retire the
medical expenses and
i've asked brother i thought he would be
kind enough to
to assist us
in the name of allah to be necessary
merciful i bear witness there is no god
but allah and i bear witness that
muhammad is the messenger of god
first of all i'd like to thank god for
blessing me to be here this afternoon
and i'd like to thank bill hall
and those who put the program together
i know that we are getting near the hour
and i want to thank brother minister
farah khan
for those words
about her brother who we
love dearly
and uh i just want to say this that
kwame
knew how to close doors he could fight
with you today
and in my home in africa we have had
some arguments at that table someone
looking in would think we would fight
the next morning he closed that door and
we were off to business
so i thank god for him but i just want
to say something that bill said that on
march the 1st he wants to close down
the
committee
that was raising funds to take care
the responsibility of kwame's hospital
bills
and i'm making an appeal to you
that number one we don't close it down
and as i said in my seat and listen to
the children
and as i heard them i live in ghana in
west africa
and what i think that in guinea
and west africa
we need a kwame and puma home
as we have a w.e.b du bois home in ghana
uh we have a george padmore library
william nurse from trinidad in ghana we
have a kwame nkuma memorial in ghana
and when these young students make their
trip to africa and it's the desire i
have not run into a black american an
african in the diaspora that does not
want to visit africa one time in his
life
but kwame went to the students
he he loved africa and he talked about
africa
he was the one that invited the nation
of islam he kept talking to minister
farakhan you need to open an office in
africa and when i we opened that office
in africa and minister farah khan sent
me it was kwame toure who came to my
home and helped me get my feet on the
ground on the african continent when he
went to college campuses yes africa has
problems but he encouraged africans in
the diaspora to come home visit see for
yourself go back and forth and become
involved in what's happening on the
african continent and i think that bill
those who love kwame those who he has
touched their lives
in a meaningful way would continue to
support
the effort to put a kwame nkuma home in
the country of guinea so when these
students visit africa they go to
synagogue they may go to the gambia they
may go to ghana but they will go to the
country of guinea and when they go to
guinea they will go to the home of kwame
and puma the papers may go to house but
kwame wrote enough said enough did
enough that we can have some uh howard
and some in the country of guinea and
west africa
so i'm appealing
and if uh
may carmichael will permit us
if if if she will permit us
then because she is the mother
that his name should ring among every
student when they talk about africa
kwami's toray's name should be the next
name out of their mouth when they talk
about imma visit africa kwame toure
should be remembered we have to make
that a reality the economist magazine
and doing the obituary of kwame toure
all of us should have written it we
should have thrown dots at him the
little ap reporter who was allowed to
interview the family of kwame toure and
the trike that he wrote and sent to
america we have to make a difference
because we know what kwame toure meant
to us so
i'm here to make an appeal
for you to go in your pockets and to
give some money
to help retire what debts
we have left but it does not have to
stop there we can continue in this
effort there are enough people in the
africans in the diaspora and other than
africans who love kwame who know what
kwame has meant to them personally who
will champion this cause and bill we
need to talk about let's continue this
effort and have the kwame toure memorial
in the country of guinea in his home we
can buy one of those homes the one by
the seaside and when we bring these
children they can go there this is where
kwame lived and worked this is where
kwame's vision took place this is the
country that kwame loved so i'm making
that appeal and if anyone say akbar will
you help i will help i will give all
that i can and i will call on my big
brother minister farrakhan and i know i
can get some help from him
so i would like to
make this appeal of bill we have
receptacles or envelopes
what do we have
we have we have a hat
the ushers are here if the ushers would
come forward and the checks bill what
should be checked
out
kwame toure medical fund that's how you
should make out your checks and i don't
want to stand up here and talk about it
so i got to go in my pocket first and i
would hope that everyone
uh i'm on my way to africa tomorrow and
whenever i get on a plane to fly across
the ocean my mind is always on brother
kwame toure and i know how he
criss-crossed that water coming back and
forth so please the ushers could you
move the basket and i would like to make
sure that someone equals my my amiga two
hundred dollars if i can find the other
one here somewhere
i have two hundred dollars towards that
effort and i know there may be a
thousand or more in the audience and if
those who want to make the check out and
if you want us to announce your donation
uh this is my two hundred dollars thank
you very much
so do not be bashful please if you need
to write a check write a check make sure
that we take up a collection and those
who have traveled from near and far we
thank you for being here to honor our
brother we thank his family
so please move the receptacles through
thank you very much and what i would
like to do for those who are members of
the party and those are former members
of snake maybe through bill who are in
constant communication i can write up
something and we can put in the country
of guinea and west africa and there's a
lot of money to make it happen out there
we can get that money and we can put
there something that represents the work
of kwame toure his papers his work in
every young student that makes the
pilgrimage to africa will make a
pilgrimage to guinea i'm sure that the
government of guinea whatever one is in
power would welcome this because it will
bring more african americans uh and
people africans in the diaspora to the
country of guinea to visit the final
resting place of palmy toure and those
who have been to ghana you see how the
ghana government and africans throughout
the world have helped to put in place a
place for w e b du bois we can do the
same on the african continent for
brother kwame toure so i want to thank
you very much for your donations and
those who would like to talk to me about
it i'll make myself available and i want
to do it in consultation with the party
with the mother of brother kwame toure
and all of those who are concerned about
his memory that his memory may be intact
and
thank you may god bless you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
with my oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we gonna walk
uh
[Music]
this
is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
we are returning to the source and we
are
very glad to
be here today
you know music was a very important part
of the movement
as muriel tillinghurst pointed out it
didn't matter that everybody sang in
tune what mattered was it everybody sang
and sometimes these songs
were what made the day because you had
to go out and face the clan with nothing
but your heart and mind and soul and
these songs somehow brought it all
together
so i know the student body right knows
these songs
i'm not worried about them singing
but we want you all to sing with us
these songs are very important so this
next little song that we're going to do
is something called this little light of
mine
i'm going to let it shine do you know
this song young people all right well
see we know we're going to get them the
same uh snick folks y'all know this song
can we sing this song
does everybody know this song
let's sing this song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let it shine
[Music]
in my neighborhood
i'm gonna let it shine let it shine
let it shine
[Music]
everywhere i go
let it shine let it
shine
i want to introduce this uh next song
because it's kind of special
you know we uh we're based in newark new
jersey and we do a lot of schools and
one of the things we like to do is to
keep this music alive
but we also like to keep the movement
alive
and that's why we're here celebrating
this great brother kwame toure
to keep the movement alive
so we try to sometimes
see how we can change the song around a
little bit
to make it
adaptable to modern ways
so we do spirituals we do freedom songs
we do blues jazz gospel
but we also do popular music
so we're going to show you how how we
can uh
change some of these words around this
next song we're going to do
is a song based on one that i'm sure you
all recognize but let me give you a
little history of it and show you how
the words work
uh i was
fortunate enough to be with snick
in montgomery
in 1965.
it was as a matter of fact that's where
i met
stokely carmichael kwame toure i also
met willie ricks
jim foreman
with long stew house a lot of folks
and on that particular time the problem
was
they wanted to
alice moore sorry
all of them
[Music]
the problem was that uh
they didn't want us to leave the black
community we were at the corner of
jackson and high street
and they had deputized the night riders
to keep us in
they worn horses with big long sticks
and they
salary i guess they got was to whip as
many heads as they could so as willie
rick said we did battle at the corner of
jackson and high speed just to get out
they had the guns and the sticks we had
just the will to resist and we overcame
now on one of those particular occasions
as we were trying to march downtown to
demonstrate in front of the state
capitol
this one particular young man saw his
sister get run over
by a horse
he picked up a brick
and was going to get whoever did that
i saw him go past and so i just jumped
on it and the song is based on what
happened after that it starts off with a
familiar freedom song we are soldiers in
the army
we gotta fight although we have to die
and then it's gonna go somewhere else
and i'll see if you can recognize it
we are so just
in the army
we gotta fight
whoa
though we have to die
we got to hold
up
the bloodstained banner
we gotta hold it up
until we die
oh we are soldiers
[Music]
he
oh yeah one day he got old he couldn't
stand anymore you know he stood up
before anyhow
also
[Music]
[Music]
we got to hold it up
we were walking down the street with
that freedom beat went along came the
police they must have been in here they
tried to go inside my head i ducked and
moved instead they beat a lot of people
and a lot of blood was [ __ ] from the
corner of my eye i heard a brother
thought he had a brick in his hand as he
ran on by and with that brick in his
hand he was headed toward the man who
brought death and misery into his land
we had to hold him up
brother
[Music]
i said brother don't do that they got
too many guns and that's a real fact he
dragged me across the ground there was
chaos all around police on horses were
knocking people down but the people
didn't run from the billet club and gun
we had the real power we knew they had
none we had to hold it up
hold it up
hold it up until we back
we had to hold up the blood banner
[Music]
it didn't fit you can't throw stones and
not get tricked that's how he put the
brick down turned the mood around got
back in the line and marched down
with a bleed shot in his eye you can't
fight the man unless you organize you
can't fight the man
oh
okay
[Applause]
thank you
that goes out to
kwame toure but you see it also goes out
to snick because snake was an
organization of organizers
you see young people today
we have too many folks who organized by
sound bite
and not by hard work
and we're not going to get anywhere that
way
so we just want to
conclude our little segment of the
portion with a gospel program a gospel
number
a gospel numbers by a special request
from karen
and uh this is something that we think
is very appropriate because
wherever
kwame turi is at this point
he has come here among us
and blessed us with that
radiant smile
so we think it very appropriate that we
kind of give him his due
with a gospel number
which goes something like this it's
called
going up yonder please sing with us if
you know it
you can sing it if you don't know it
put your hands together come on
[Applause]
[Music]
if you want to know
[Music]
where i'm going
[Music]
where i'm going
now
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going up and down
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
until i see my savior
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna be here
[Applause]
[Music]
with my my my
thank you very much
jackie jones
joe scott
johnny van klein
quincy tury and i'm juniors williams we
are returning to the source thank you
very much
and god bless kwame toure
good evening brothers and sisters
my name is
i'm with the al-african people
revolutionary party
first of all we want to thank the friend
of kwame
for organizing this affair
we want to thank the family of kwame
tori for sharing him with us
as you know puerbetoy was a person who
was well loved by the people
because he was incorruptable
he worked at behalf of the people up to
the last day of his life the last hour
the last minute the last second he spent
struggling for the masses of the people
his life
represents a life of struggle a life of
revolutionary struggle
it is by no accident that he popular
rise to slogan black power
he understood
that what our people need is power
our people are disrespected
because
they lack power
he spend his entire adult life trying to
empower
the masses
of our people
to empower
the people who have been oppressed
by class
by race
and in our sister case by sex
require revolution
koamitori was a revolutionary
up to the end
being a revolutionary he understood
that no one individual
can liberate the masses of the people
but the people
properly organized with the correct
ideology will be able to liberate
themselves
kwame once told me
[Music]
that once he understood come to
understood the rule of organization
he made sure
that he was always a part of some
organization
because it is organization that decide
everything
if you read some of the latest news
they will let you
they make it appear
that kwame stop struggling after the
60s those of you who know kwame
know that nothing could be further from
the truth
[Music]
[Applause]
took black power to its logical
conclusion
pan-africanism
the total liberation and unification of
africa under socialist government
this is the ice form of unity that we as
a people can achieve an africanism
this is a unity
that brings all the forces together
this unity pan-africanism will give us
maximum power
we must have the bickering
amongst ourselves
we
don't care
where you were born
whether he was born in trinidad
whether he was born in the highland of
jamaica whether he was born in the
united states of america whether he was
born in europe or whether he was born on
the continent we say as long as you're a
black man you're a african
african
[Music]
[Applause]
juan meteor spent the last 30 years of
his life
organizing an independent political
party
he understand that we were not going to
get freedom from the democratic party or
from the republican party we need a
party that come up from the masses we
need a party that come up with his
with his own structure
he made tremendous sacrifice in building
this party we are glad to say today this
party is alive and well
[Applause]
[Music]
we have chapter of this party
throughout the united states in canada
in the caribbean in europe
and on the continent of africa and we
the organization of the african people
revolutionary party will continue to
move forward building this
pan-africanist party the all-african
people revolutionary party
juan mature was also an internationalist
a lot of people just see him in the
context of the black struggle but he was
a internationalist he was a humanist he
was
bigger
than just
just the black struggle
he gave uncompromising support
to the native people of this land
he gave uncompromising support
to the irish
he gave uncompromising
support
to the libyan
he gave uncompromising
support to all people who were
struggling and are struggling for
justice he gave and comma compromising
support to the palestinian to reclaim
their land from the clutches of zionism
and imperialism
the last
days of his life
kwame was planning to go to libya to
show solidarity with president
gaddafi and the masses of the libyan
people to send a message
that economic sanction against libya
iraq and cuba are unjust and they must
be gotten rid of
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign love of the people understand
that we are not going to be
in one organization
we have many organizations amongst us
but kwame
saying even though we have many
organization
with many
point of view
we as an african people must come
together and build a wide front
a front can be very wide
in this front we want those
from the farthest left to the furthest
right and those in the middle we want to
build an african united front
this is part of kwame legacy
we must continue to struggle to build
this front
all those who want to see our people
united
must come together and build this
african united front
we of the african people revolutionary
party are determined to see that this
united front is built
we are sure
that it will be built
we want you to join with us to build
this united front
as you know when kwame was
called me on
minister farah khan
julius mann
were to have a meeting
at the last minute
julius band back out
kwame took himself from his sick bed
drove to maryland and let us sit in
at the naac headquarter
he was determined to stay there until
julius julian barnes
met with him of course this did not
happen
but we will continue
to struggle for this meeting and this
unity
i'm sure the minister who was there
military
is willing to join in to build this
african united front
if the palestinian and the israeli can
get together there is no reason why we
as african cannot get together
[Music]
in the words of kwame tori we stand
ready for the revolution
those of you who would like to know more
about the african people revolutionary
party
we have some
organization people revolutionary party
with the table in the back
as you leave you could come and we'll
give you information concerning the
all-african people revolutionary party
we are determined
now than ever to carry on the legacy of
our beloved brother who toured forward
to revolution
[Music]
[Applause]
at memorial services
it is often
considered an honor
to have the last word to say
as if that word should come from someone
who knows the most about the person who
has been sent forth into eternity
i think it is so fitting today
that in terms of all of the words to be
said
there is one here who had the first word
when she recognized that there was new
life stirring within her womb
and is that one who's perhaps had the
most important word to say during all of
the years of struggle will you join me
in welcoming mrs carmichael the first
word
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before i begin to speak i want to thank
the bright lights
they are for me bright lights and i want
to say thank you
this is mamu
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm going to try to be brief kwame has
enriched our lives
by
broadening the definition of family
and embry to embrace all who are present
here
today and thousands
more throughout the world
you were his brothers
and sisters
and thus
became the carmichael's tribe
to you his extended family
he left no worthy riches
because he did not own anything
material
instead he left us a priceless legacy
rich in friendships
and his own principles and beliefs
kwame
was never rich
except in friendships
and
he
was my gift to the world
as a matter of fact
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a matter of fact i want to say
stokely
was my gift to the world
though my loss is great
i cannot
although my loss is great
i know
i know you have lost
a brother
a sister
and
a friend
and an honest
what is this an honest delegated
uncompromising member of snake
the aarp
the aarp
kwame
was not rich
[Music]
except in friendship
and i want to emphasize that one huami
was not rich
except in
friendship this is so clear
in examining his
con his connection
to the people of the nation of islam
cuba
libya
trinidad
and his social
party and guinea
we cannot exclude
his
respect
and authoration of president and kruma
and president second terrain
[Applause]
[Music]
the movement and his political and
ideological family
black united front and the whole world
he was the undying force in a family
with a fast commitment to loyalty
kwame was a caring son
a father
a brother
an uncle
a nephew and a friend
i want to thank you all
for the friendship
and the support bestowed
and the generosity on for me and his
family
we are especially grateful
for the support during the challenging
changes of the last three years
of his journey
before i go any further
i want to say
that i am going to
ask you all to help me
by supporting
the rest of kwame's
medical fund
and after that
i would like to say
there is a small library and study
institute in guinea
being stated as tribute to our beloved
black united front
may
keep the funds again
i did not ask them yet but i'm going to
this time for the for me to ray
library and work study in guinea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
his son
my grandson
bokobiro toure
is now enrolled in the university he's a
freshman in the university of virginia
[Applause]
[Music]
it was kwami's dream
that he would go back to guinea
and take care of his educational estate
upon the completion of his studies
kwame would expect
the carmichael tried to help me
with that
library yes
i am saying
thanks
in advance
for your help again
in keeping my son's memory alive
i thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now the harambee singers
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
going back to southwest georgia
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you
don't know
[Music]
[Music]
if you
[Music]
don't know
that i'm seeking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
i'm
going back
to southwest georgia
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
was
[Music]
raised
[Applause]
karen says she wanted everybody to
participate so this next song we're
going to do a secretary
has an english translation i don't care
if i go to jail
it's for freedom
that i gladly go
i seek a time no more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
is
i came up yesterday
and we worked last night to try to put
together a song
that kind of spoke to kwame and snake
and so we want you to kind of bear with
us while we kind of go through history
here
it's in the tune of
an old church song
so when you hear it
just join in
now
i didn't hear everybody who wanted to go
to jail a few minutes ago
there was very few people willing to go
to jail so now in this song i want you
to join in
he
[Music]
was
afraid
[Music]
[Music]
didn't have
nobody we could
answer his last call
but he
was
[Music]
he
was
[Music]
he
was a
friend of mine
he
was
a friend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
unity
of gains a mighty force was his harlem
call
united
we stand
divided we
fall
trained the scholar
at howard
but freedom was his home
southern life
as we knew it
would never be the
same
all through
the south
tell me what is this i see
bloodshed and [ __ ] dogs death staring
at me
walking tall in lounge county
alabama
he fought with the people
to
exercise their right
their right
to vote
black power
rick said it
popularized by my friend
uncle toms across america
go down right insane
handful
of rocks
was that deep seahorse
a handful
of rocks brought us shiny new garbage
cans
snake he said
made a stand
every war was anti-war was
the cold
vietnamese
are not our enemy it is you who must
bear this blame
and chroma
to reign
yes every cover calls
and
every revolutionary
must stop and study
his call
some of you might
be confused but i'm here
to take
that every con
liberation day was wanted to raise calls
you must be crystal clear
it was genocide
i know this fool well
i'm like saying now
in an
hourglass i'm
singing things
and he
was
afraid
of mine
he
was
afraid of
didn't have
[Music]
proud
[Music]
and he's standing with brother
featherstone and
standing with cordell reagan
standing with
joking and standing with howard spencer
and he's standing with the wise man
and he's making
a
call
ready for the revolution
my friend my friend my friend my friend
my revolutionary
[Music]
friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
his mother
[Music]
is
down
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as we come
to the end of this program we have a
three-minute video clip
and then reverend false will give
closing remarks
[Music]
the first thing we must say is that uh
all of this is done with uh love that is
nothing less than overwhelming
[Applause]
is the beacon of light
that even when the size of that light is
to come now
[Applause]
black people we've always been concerned
about white america never about us
and what we've always thought is that
white america equal the same interests
as us that is not true we must not be
concerned with us let me give you some
examples
we always want to prove what good
americans we are the very first man to
die for the war of independence in this
country was a black man named christmas
adam
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he was a fool
[Applause]
all but we wanted to prove the great
americans we were we begged the white
folks to let us fight in the war of
independence and they said no so we
organized ourselves in bands of armies
training ourselves with our barefoot to
prove to the white folks what great
americans we will please let us fight
white folks and finally they came and
inspected our troops he said good [ __ ]
you can fight and they had us fighting
the indians like fools we should have
teamed up with the
[Applause]
30 indians since you made the call for
black power
um is there any reason for us to be
optimistic about the future oh yes
victory's hours victory's in their
ruling next generation there's no
question we made a lot of advancements
the cost of our people are rising is
going to rise higher and that's all we
need once that is done then we're bad
with uh extending conditions and rising
consciousness there must be revolution
american capitalism is weaker today than
it's ever been is getting weaker every
day
every
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
a united front when you form a united
front with another organization since
there are similarities and discoveries
with everybody even amongst your mother
you don't highlight the dissimilarities
you highlight the similarities and
there's these that pose you together
so we want you each and every one of you
every time you see members of nation of
islam to thank them for what they did
for the all african people's
revolutionary party thank them for this
great spirit
how would you like for people to
remember you particularly african people
um
just another buzzer from muhammad ali
used to say all the time
just another brother on the corner doing
more or less what they all do
but in addition to that we would like to
remember it as someone who
struggled with integrity
we would want to
know that we represent the best of our
people that we represented uh honestly
they struggle that
corruption is outside of the concepts of
our very thinking
and
we'd like to leave that as example that
if one struggles one would struggle
honestly for the people and
you can't serve two gods you know you
can't serve the people and
also not serve the people
he must serve them and serve them
faithfully so um
we would hope that our legacy is that we
have uh
with a great integrity uh faithfully uh
serve the cause of our people's struggle
we however would like to make a plea
before this audience this being an
extremely special audience
a special plea that you take and
understand the responsibility we have of
forming united fronts especially now
this system is in crisis
it is an economic crisis
it is in political crisis
above all it is a moral crisis
we have a responsibility here
to ensure that we became we become a
leading force
in bringing to order the politics the
economics and above all the morals
within the
society this could only be done from a
unified base john lewis knows better
than all of us
that the position which he occupies
belongs to the blood of his people who
was the major participant
his blood consecrated that victory
this position must be used to benefit
the masses of the people
it cannot be done it cannot be used if
in fact john lewis is isolated from
farrakhan who is isolated from julian
bond who's isolated etc etc etc we must
have a united farm
[Applause]
we have a responsibility to ensure this
unity
there's nothing worse in life than
having worked for a principal and before
death seeing that principle crumble and
you do absolutely nothing about it
[Music]
in order for life to have any meaning at
all that which you work for when you are
alive must continue after you are dead
otherwise your life had no purpose at
all
we must go from spontaneity to
organization
this meeting must not be so spontaneous
where we come together with all this
power and then it evaporates when we
walk out the door
once we begin to organize we shall
organize like wi-fi
my life means absolutely nothing before
the struggles of my people therefore i
have been living in africa it is to
africa that i shall return it is in
africa that i shall die therefore it is
bad i must live with the level of health
service that our brothers and sisters
have in africa if they can have cancer
and live in africa and die in africa we
too can have cancer and live and die in
africa thank you ready for revolution
thank you ready for evolution
[Applause]
and as kwame has asked tonight
there must be unity
in our community
o allah
let it be
long live
kwame toure
[Applause]
i'm reminded that there is a photo in
the rear that's being bidded upon and so
we would hope that you would avail
yourselves to the photo of kwame as you
leave
the church
and so it is time to go
our brother has gone on before us
his book
at least the first printing of it is
completed now
there will be additions as truth comes
to light
and as knowledge is uncovered but
we must continue to write the book
that is the life we live as individuals
and the life we live together as
community
and so i think perhaps the best
way
to show thanks for the life that has
been lived is to rededicate ourselves to
those values
we believe in that we hold dear
he has done his part
we now must do that work which is ours
and as i see the little children here
who are inspired
by the life of stokley komakio
of kwame
turay i want to say to the parents
perhaps
that is the living legacy
even as their words were spoken here
some with hesitation
some with a deep sense of its meaning
and words eluding them
they will be able to carry on the legacy
for which our leader has given his full
measure of devotion so let me close with
these words particularly to the elderly
in regards to these children then we
will rise and say a closing prayer
i looked around the other day and saw
how truly blessed this life of mine has
been
i have health strength and comfort peace
and joy in mind
special care in times of desperation
a helping hand
when friends are few so i said to myself
what can i do to turn some thanks to you
i expected mission impossible a call to
service far away but instead this
special assignment god sends to us each
day love my children that's all i ask of
you
love my children that's the least that
you can do if you love them as i love
them we shall see them safely through
love yourself
love me too
but
whatever else you do
love
these children
and the vision of a world of freedom and
justice peace and love will ultimately
be
revealed unto us who struggle unto the
end so let us stand now and offer a word
of prayer
oh god in this service
a righteous remembrance service we have
heard about a brother that you sent into
the world
who made it maintained his integrity to
the end
gave so much to so many
gave us the courage of our convictions
gave us the awareness of the necessity
of power
showed us what courage looks like
and then lived it out
thank you for his life thank you that he
was not so wrapped into his own ego but
that he could yield his strength for the
good of the cause
revolutionary in intent and diligent by
daily duty for the organizing of your
people
now lord we ask your blessings upon each
one of us
especially upon his mother
and the members of the family
and all those whose responsibility it
will be
to provide the closing moments of his
material well-being and responsibility
may there be unen expected sources from
which resources will come to complete
the medical the library the home
whatever else the living legacy will be
may there be friends who will rise up
and dedicate what is necessary to close
that chapter but more than that we pray
lord look upon each one of us we have
given all we've had thus far but there
is much yet to be done
renew us in spirit and strength and
solidarity with one another help us like
stokely or me to do all we can until our
dying day has come
so now lead us out not with tears o lord
but with a sense of hope and confidence
that you who gave him to the world now
send us forth to be instruments of your
will for liberation for peace for
integrity and for genuine love oh god
this prayer we offer even as we offer up
our brother and his legacy for you who
started us on this journey
will not abandon us until the journey is
over and grant that we shall work so
that together we may hear your voice
saying well done
good and faithful servants enter into
the joy of all of the ancestors and the
joy of the lord in your name we pray
amen
and amen
[Applause]
[Music]
and on martin luther king jr day which
is